CALL THE- BUDGET SUB COMMITTEE
THREE I HEARING FOR MAY
NINETEENTH TWENTY TWENTY ONE TO
ORDER. WE ARE SHORT OF A QUORUM
AND SO WILL BEGIN AS A SUB
COMMITTEE. I'VE BEEN ASKED TO
READ SOME DIRECTIONS REGARDING
PUBLIC PARTICIPATION IN TODAY'S
HEARING TO HELP INSURE THE
SAFETY OF EVERYONE HERE TODAY
WHILE ALLOWING FULL PUBLIC
ACCESS TO THE DISCUSSION AND
HOPEFULLY WE WON'T HAVE TO READ
THESE INSTRUCTIONS FOR TOO MUCH
LONGER. BUT FOR TODAY FOR THE
PUBLIC WHO MAY BE IN THE ROOM
WHERE AN FORTY TWO OH TWO. AND
WE ARE HAVING A PHYSICALLY JUST
AN IN PERSON HEARING. WE CAN
ONLY ACCOMMODATE A FEW MEMBERS
IN THIS ROOM A MAN MINIMAL
CONTINGENT OF STAFF AND A
LIMITED NUMBER OF THE PUBLIC
AND MEDIA SO WE CAN KEEP SIX
FEET OF SPACING THEY'RE ALSO
STRICT PHYSICAL DISTANCING
PROTOCOLS FOR THE PUBLIC TO
ENTER AND LEAVE THE CAPITAL. OF
THE CAPITAL BUILDING ITSELF AND
FOR THOSE HERE TODAY TO MAKE
PUBLIC COMMENTS AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME. I'LL RESTATE
SOME OF THIS AGAIN ONE PUBLIC
COMMENT BEGINS BUT IF ANY
MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC IN THE
ROOM WISHES TO SPEAK. IF YOU'RE
IN THE ROOM PLEASE RAISE YOUR
HAND AND I'LL ASK YOU TO
APPROACH THE MICROPHONE. I
WOULD ALSO ASK THAT PUBLIC
RESPECT PHYSICAL DISTANCING AND
NOT TOUCH THE MICROPHONE.
YOU'LL EACH HAVE ONE MINUTE FOR
PUBLIC COMMENT THAT GOES FOR
ANYONE WHO'S- PROVIDING PUBLIC
COMMENT TODAY. YOU CAN EXIT THE
HEARING ROOM ONCE YOU'RE PUBLIC
COMMENT IS DONE OR RETURN TO
YOUR SEAT BUT PLEASE OBSERVE
PHYSICAL DISTANCING. UPON
LEAVING THE CAPITAL INCLUDING
LIMITING ELEVATOR USE TO TWO
PEOPLE AT A TIME. THE PANELISTS
ON THE AGENDA AND THE L. A. O.
R. APPEARING REMOTELY USING OUR
ONLINE TECHNOLOGY. AND AS FOR
PUBLIC COMMENT WE ARE ACCEPTING
PUBLIC COMMENT AT THE END OF
THIS HEARING BOTH IN THE
HEARING ROOM AND ON THE PHONE.
THE PHONE NUMBER TO CONNECT IS
ON THE COMMITTEE WEBSITE AND
SHOULD BE ALSO ON THE SCREEN IF
YOU'RE WATCHING OVER THE
INTERNET. THAT PHONE NUMBER IS.
TOLL FREE. 877-692-8957 AGAIN
THAT'S. 877-692-8957 AND
THERE'S A PUBLIC ACCESS CODE
THAT YOU'LL NEED TO USE THAT
NUMBER IS. ONE THREE ONE FIVE
FOUR TWO ZERO TWO AGAIN. ONE
THREE ONE FIVE FOUR TWO ZERO
TWO. IF YOU ENCOUNTER ANY
PROBLEMS PLEASE CONTACT THE
ASSEMBLY BUDGET COMMITTEE AT.
916-319-2099 AGAIN THAT'S.
916-319-2099 IF YOU'RE HAVING
PROBLEMS AND A STAFF MEMBER
WILL ASSIST YOU. WE ENCOURAGE
THE PUBLIC TO PROVIDE WRITTEN
TESTIMONY BEFORE THE HEARING
YOU CAN SEND THAT WRITTEN
TESTIMONY TO BUDGET SUB THREE.
ACT ASM DOT CA DOT GOV. BUDGET
SUB THREE THAT'S NUMERAL THREE.
AT A. S. M. DOT CA. DOT GOV. WE
CONTINUE TO BE SHORT OF A
QUORUM SO WE WILL HOLD OFF
CALLING ROLE BUT LET ME-
PROVIDES AN INTRODUCTORY
REMARKS BEFORE WE BEGAN WITH
OUR FORMAL PRESENTATIONS. TODAY
OUR GOAL IS TO HEAR A HIGH
LEVEL OVERVIEW OF THE GOVERNORS
MAY REVISION PROPOSALS AND TO
LEAVE ADEQUATE TIME FOR PUBLIC
COMMENT. THE MAY REVISION
PROVIDED SIGNIFICANT NEW
INVESTMENTS IN A NUMBER OF
AREAS UNDER THE JURISDICTION OF
THE SUBCOMMITTEE. SOME OF THESE
ITEMS MAYOR PROPOSALS WE'VE
HEARD AND CHAMPIONED IN THE
PAST. AND QUITE A FEW OF THE
PROPOSALS ARE NEW OF THE ITEMS
VERY SIGNIFICANTLY IN THE
AMOUNT OF DETAIL ABOUT
IMPLEMENTATION AND OVERSIGHT.
TO THAT END WE RECOGNIZE THE
IMPORTANCE OF HEARING FROM.
THE
ADMINISTRATION ON THESE
PROPOSALS. ANALYSTS OFFICE AND
MOST IMPORTANTLY NOTES FROM THE
PUBLIC. WHO ARE ABLE TO COMMENT
ON THE BUDGET FOR THE FIRST
TIME TODAY. FOR MEMBERS OF THIS
COMMITTEE PLEASE NOTE THAT
WHILE TODAY'S FOCUS IS A
GENERAL OVERVIEW OF NEW ITEMS.
BUDGET COMMITTEE STAFF IS
CONTINUING TO FULLY VET THESE
PROPOSALS AND IS AVAILABLE TO
YOU OR YOUR STAFF FOR ANY
QUESTIONS AFTER TODAY'S HEARING.
THANK YOU FOR UNDERSTANDING
AND- BEFORE WE BEGIN THE MAY
REVISION WE PROMISED AT OUR
LAST MEETING. THAT WE WOULD
REVISIT CALIFORNIA A. B. THIRTY
EIGHT IMPLEMENTATION AFTER
REQUEST OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BENNETT WHO HAS ARRIVED AS IF
ON COMMAND- AND- SO WE WILL ASK
OUR ISSUE ONE CALIFORNIA AB
THIRTY EIGHT IMPLEMENTATION
PANELISTS. TO MAGICALLY APPEAR
ON OUR SCREEN AND- I THINK-
PERHAPS- WE CAN SIMPLY PROCEED
TO YOUR QUESTION ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BENNETT AND TO SEEK
ANSWERS FROM I BELIEVE- MISTER
PORTER AND A CHIEF PORTER AND
TO- HIS- ASSOCIATE DANIEL PEARL
LAUGHED- AND WE HAVE A HOTEL
AND A CHRISTIAN FROM THE L. A.
O.'S OFFICE AVAILABLE AS WELL.
SO PLEASE PROCEED WITH YOUR
QUESTION. YOU I CAN HAVE A
MOMENT HERE AND WE'RE GOING.
SEE THIS OUT FOR JUST A FEW
SECONDS LAWMAKER. LET ME CHECK
AND MAKE SURE THAT- CHIEF
PORTER OR SOMEONE FROM A CAL
FIRE IS AVAILABLE. GOOD MORNING
SHARE BILL. I AM AVAILABLE AS
WELL AS A CHEAPER MORE. DYNAMIC
THANK YOU WELCOME TO BOTH OF.
THANK G. DO YOU DO YOU ASK YOUR
TO OUR HEARING I THINK YOU TO
SOME OF YOUR- CHIEF IF YOU-
HAVE A RECOLLECTION OF- UGH.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BENEFITS
QUESTION YOU COULD TO START
ANSWER NOW IF YOU LIKE.
CERTAINLY THANK YOU AND AGAIN-
THANK YOU FOR HEARING- THIS
IMPORTANT SUBJECT THIS MORNING-
AB- THIRTY EIGHT IMPLEMENTATION
AGAIN MY NAME'S TOM PORTER I
AM- CALIFORNIA OR A DIRECTOR
AND FIRE CHIEF. ALONG WITH ME I
HAVE- THAT- ASSISTANT DEPUTY
DIRECTOR DANIEL BERGER LAMPS
FROM OUR FIRE MARSHAL'S OFFICE-
YOU WILL BE GIVING THE BULK OF
OUR OUR- RESPONSE. AND I JUST
WANTED TO START OUT BY SAYING-
THAT WE- OR- THROUGH THE BUDGET
PROPOSAL- IN FRONT OF YOU-
WE'RE LOOKING TO- AND THE STAFF
NECESSARY TO IMPLEMENT IN THE
STATE RESPONSIBILITY AREA. THE
ELEMENTS OF AB THIRTY EIGHT.
THAT REQUIRE- WHEN REAL
PROPERTY IS SOLD- THAT IT MEETS
THE FIRE PROTECTION STANDARDS
FOR DEFENSIBLE SPACE. ARE UPON
THAT TRANSFER OF OWNERSHIP. AND
SO MUCH CHEAPER LAPSED- YEARS
OUR- ASSISTANT DEPUTY DIRECTOR
OVER THIS PROGRAM AND I'M VERY
FAMILIAR WITH THAT HE WILL
GIVE. THE TESTIMONY THAT I
BELIEVE ANSWERS THE QUESTIONS
THAT- THAT WERE ASKED BY-
MEMBER BENNETT AND- AND THEN
STAFF. THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. RIGHT WELL THEY YOU AND
YOU- IN GOOD THAT BLOOM OF THE
CAN- AS MANY ANYWHERE LANDIS'S
DEPUTY RECTOR WITH CAL FIRE I
JUST A QUICK REMINDER ASSEMBLY
BILL THIRTY EIGHT AS A
COMPONENT OF IT REQUIRE
SELLERS. OF HOMES WITHIN THE
HIGH AND VERY HIGH FIRE HAZARD
SEVERITY ZONES A TO PROVIDE
DOCUMENTATION- THAT THEIR
PROPERTY IS IN COMPLIANCE WITH
THE FENCE WILL SPACE
REQUIREMENTS OUR REQUEST THAT
WE BROUGHT FORWARD TO YOU
ADDRESSES THE INCREASED
WORKLOAD DRIVEN BY THE
STATUTORY REQUIREMENTS RELATED
TO THE DEFENSIBLE SPACE
INSPECTIONS. APPROXIMATELY 75%
OF THE STATE RESPONSIBILITY
AREA OR CAL FIRE'S
JURISDICTION- IS CLASSIFIED IN
ONE OF THESE TWO ZONES ARE A
LITTLE BIT OF BACKGROUND WE
PERFORMED A DETAILED WORKLOAD
ANALYSIS- BASED ON AVERAGE HOME
SALES IN CALIFORNIA
PROPORTIONAL TO THE STATE
RESPONSIBILITY AREA I WE
ESTIMATE THAT. JUST UNDER
TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND HOMES I
WILL BE SOLD I EACH YEAR WITHIN
OUR JURISDICTION REQUIREMENT
INDEFENSIBLE SPACE INSPECTION
TO DEMONSTRATE THAT CAN
REQUIRED COMPLIANCE- WITH THESE
NEW DISCLOSURE REQUIREMENTS.
NOW THERE HAVE BEEN QUESTIONS
ARE RAISED A REGARDING IMPOSING
A FEE FOR THESE INSPECTIONS AND
EVEN POSSIBLY TO FIND WORK ACT
FOR US TO CLEAR OF VEGETATION
FOR HOMEOWNERS THAT ARE ODD NON
COMPLIANT- WE APPRECIATE TO A
VERY MUCH OF THIS DISCUSSION-
BUT WE DO NOT BELIEVE- THAT IS
NECESSARY AT THIS TIME FOR
SEVERAL REASONS- FIRST. OUR
BASE DEFENSIBLE SPACE PROGRAM
HAS FOUND GREATEST COMPLIANCE
THROUGH EDUCATION AND COMMUNITY
OUTREACH ARE INSPECTORS SECOND
WALK HOMEOWNERS THROUGH THE
EASY STEPS ARE THAT IT TAKES TO
GAIN COMPLIANCE AND IT'S PART
OF HER JOB TO PROVIDE
INFORMATION. TO THE HOMEOWNERS
THAT REALLY EXPLAINS WHY IT'S
IN THE BEST INTEREST FOR THE
HOMEOWNER TO MAINTAIN
DEFENSIBLE SPRAYS TO PROTECT
THEIR OWN HOME- AND TO PROTECT
THEIR FAMILY. YEAH IN FACT WE
FIND THAT AFTER THESE
EDUCATIONAL INSPECTIONS WE
ACHIEVE A VERY HIGH COMPLIANCE
RATES. IN THE PROGRAM BEFORE
YOU TODAY A HOMEOWNER IS
MOTIVATED TO SELL THEIR HOME-
SO WE FEEL THAT. COMPLIANCE IS
ACTUALLY GONNA BE RELATIVELY
HIGH I- UPON OUR INSPECTION
THESE NEED A REALIST TO SLOW.
INSPECTIONS LASTLY THE COST IN
RESOURCES TO ADMINISTER A NEW
FEE PROGRAM WE BELIEVE.
OUTWEIGH THE BENEFITS GAINED BY
THE WORK THAT THAT WE WOULD
HAVE TO PERFORM. AND SO BASED
ON OUR COMPLIANCE RATES BASED
ON THE COST TO CONTRACT- FOR
DEFENSIBLE SPACE WORK- WHICH
COULD EASILY RUN BY THE WAY
ANYWHERE FROM THREE TO FIVE
THOUSAND DOLLARS ON AVERAGE-
THAT WOULD ADD TO THE COST TO
SELL A HOME- IF THE HOME HAD
DEAD TREES FOR EXAMPLE- THAT
NUMBER COULD LIKELY INCREASED
OVER TEN THOUSAND DOLLARS- THE
AGAIN THESE COSTS- WOULD BE IF
THE STATE WAS TO IMPOSE A FEE.
AND FOR US TO PERFORM THE WORK
AND THE COST REALLY JUST DON'T
PENCIL OUT. ALSO THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME TODAY AND HAVE AN
ANSWER- ANY ADDITIONAL
QUESTIONS THAT YOU MAY HAVE. I
APPRECIATE THE BACKGROUND ON
THIS. AND WITH IT BEING LIMITED
TO WHEN PROPERTIES ARE ARE
BEING TRANSFERRED IN TERMS OF
OWNERSHIP I THINK THAT I WILL
AGREE WITH YOU THAT COMPLIANCE
WILL BE MUCH HIGHER- DO YOU
THINK IT'S POSSIBLE THAT- DOWN
THE ROAD WE WILL HAVE A-
COMPLIANCE PROGRAM SIMPLY
BECAUSE A FIRE RISK- AND TO.
GET SOME KIND OF ANNUAL
COMPLIANCE PROGRAM. WE ALREADY
HAVE STATUTORY AUTHORITY- TO DO
WORK FOR ON HOMEOWNERS THAT
THEY DON'T DO THE WORK AS I
MENTIONED IT'S A COSTLY.
VENTURE THAT WE REALLY DON'T DO
AN OVERALL WHEN WE SIMPLY GO
OUT AND TALK TO HOMEOWNERS AND
EDUCATE THEM WE TRULY DO FIND
THAT THEY'RE MORE MOTIVATED-
THEN OUR REQUIREMENTS ARE TO
CLEAR THEIR VEGETATION YOU KNOW
ALL THE FIRES. OVER THE LAST
YEARS AND THE- TENS OF
THOUSANDS OF HOMES THAT HAVE
BEEN DESTROYED BY WILDFIRES
MOST OF THE HOMEOWNERS THAT WE
NEED TO IN FACT PROBABLY ALMOST
ALL OF THEM. ARE VERY MOTIVATED
TO SAVE THEIR HOME AND DO
EVERYTHING THEY CAN TO ENSURE
THAT THAT THEY'RE SAFE AND SO
THAT'S WHERE REALLY OUR
EDUCATIONAL INSPECTIONS- GET US
I THINK IT WHICH EVEN THE
OVERALL GOAL OF THE STATE AND
THE DEPARTMENT. AND REALLY- YOU
KNOW TO BETTER PROTECT THE
COMMUNITY GREAT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. YOU'RE WELCOME DO WE NEED
ADDITIONAL INFORMATION FROM THE
L. A. O. OR YOU. OKAY GREAT
WELL THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
THE PRESENTATIONS- MISS CARSON
THANK YOU FOR STANDING BY WILL
PROCEED NOW TO ISSUE TOO. AND
THAT IS THE PRESENTATION ON THE
GOVERNOR'S MAY REVISE PROPOSAL
ON CLIMATE CHANGE WE HAVE. A
FIVE FOOT- PEOPLE ON OUR PANEL
SERGIO AGUILAR- WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE BRYAN
FULLER ALSO WITH- AND ELIZABETH
YURI ALSO WITH THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE. AND RACHEL HOURS
AND BRIAN BROWN WITH THE L. A.
L. IT'S A GOOD MORNING IN TURN
MEMBERS SIR DRIVER WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. SO THEY
ARE VERY SIMPLE GOALS WITHIN
THAT THE CLIMATE CHANGE PACKAGE
THAT WILL BE COVERING A PART OF
THIS AGENDA ITEM. ALSO ROUGHLY
NOTING THAT THE COMBINATION OF
THE SIGNIFICANTLY HIGHER FEE
REVENUES AND THE ADDITIONAL
FEDERAL SUPPORT REALLY HAS
PROVIDED A PRETTY HISTORIC
OPPORTUNITY TO INVEST IN THE
ADMINISTRATION'S CLIMB
INITIATIVES. AND OVERALL WHEN
COMBINED WITH THE INVESTMENTS
UP FROM THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
THE MAYOR VISION FOR WAS A
TOTAL OF ABOUT ELEVEN POINT
EIGHT BILLION. IN INVESTMENTS
THAT ENHANCE THE STATE'S
CLIMATE RESILIENCE AND ALSO
REDUCE CARBON EMISSIONS
SALTLICK BASICALLY HIGHLIGHTING
THE WATER RESILIENCE AND GROUND
INVESTMENTS AND I'LL PASS IT ON
TO MY OTHER COLLEAGUES FOR A
COUPLE OF THE OTHER. MAJOR
COMPONENTS AS PART OF THIS
PACKAGE SO. IN TWENTY TWENTY
THE ADMINISTRATION DEVELOPED A
COMPREHENSIVE WATER DOING
PORTFOLIO WHICH OUTLINES THE
YOU KNOW A COPPER THE STRATEGY
AND OVER A HUNDRED ACTIONS THAT
ENABLE CALIFORNIA'S WATER.
WEIGHT JUST TO INCREASING
TEMPERATURES TO AYE SHRINKING
SNOWPACK WRITING FEE LEVELS AND
ALSO MORE INTENSE AND FREQUENT
DROUGHTS AND AFTER TO
EXCEPTIONALLY DRY WINTERS
CALIFORNIA IS ONCE AGAIN
EXPERIENCING DROUGHT
CONDITIONS. SO WE ARE USING YOU
KNOW A LESSONS LEARNED FOR FROM
PREVIOUS TRAVEL AND A WHOLE-GOVERNMENT APPROACH- THE
GOVERNOR RECENTLY ISSUED A-
STATE OF EMERGENCY IN FORTY ONE
COUNTIES REPRESENTING YOU KNOW
PROBABLY 30% OF THE STATE'S
POPULATION. AND IS PART OF THAT
DROP PROCLAMATIONS THAT THE
GOVERNMENT DIRECTED THE STATE
AGENCIES TO RESPOND AND PREPARE
IN VARIOUS WAYS AND ALSO
INCLUDE. ADDITIONAL INVESTMENTS
AND SUPPORT IN IN THE MAYOR
VISION SO CONSISTENT WITH THE
WATER PORTFOLIO AND THE
GOVERNOR'S DROUGHT PROCLAMATION
THE MAYOR VISION PROPOSES FOUR
POINT THREE FIVE BILLION OVER
MULTIPLE YEARS. TO ADVANCE THE
STATE WATER RESILIENCE AND ALSO
SUPPORT- DROUGHT PREPAREDNESS
AND RESPONSE AS THOSE EVEN
VESTMENTS BUILD UPON THE- SEVEN
HUNDRED FIVE IN FIFTY SEVEN
MILLION INCLUDED IN THERE OVER
BUDGET. FOR A TOTAL PASS OF A
FIVE POINT ONE BILL. IN
PROPOSED WATER GOING TO BE. I
JUST TO COVER A KIND OF A
COUPLE HIGH LEVELS OF THE
INVESTMENT IN THE WATER
RESILIENCE PACKAGE ABOUT TWO
POINT SIX BILLION- SUPPORT
PROVIDING ACCESS TO SAFE
DRINKING WATER. BUILDING WATER
SUPPLY RELIABILITY AND ALSO AN
IMPROVING FLOOD PROTECTION-
CLOSE TO ONE BILLION- HELP
SUPPORT IMMEDIATE DROUGHT
SUPPORT. AND THEN ALSO ENABLES
IT IMPROVE DATA COLLECTION AND
MONITORING. AND THEN THERE'S
ABOUT SEVEN HUNDRED AND TWENTY
SIX MILLION FOR NATURE BASED
SOLUTIONS TO HELP RESTORE FISH
AND WILDLIFE HABITAT.
RECONNECTING WILDLIFE CORRIDORS
AND ALSO REMOVING BARRIERS TO
FISH PASSAGE- SO WITH THAT BACK
OVER THE HIGH LEVEL THE WATER
RESILIENCE COMPONENTS OF THE
CLIENT PACKAGE. I'LL PASS IT ON
TO MY COLLEAGUE BRYAN FULLER
WHO WILL SPEAK ON SOME
ADDITIONAL. INVESTMENTS IN
CLIMATE RESILIENCE. GREAT THANK
YOU SERGIO BRYAN FULLER
DEPARTMENT FINANCE GOOD MORNING
CHAIRED MEMBERS- AS SERGIO
MENTIONS I WILL BE PROVIDING. A
BRIEF OVERVIEW OF THE CLIMATE
RESILIENCE PACKAGE THAT WAS
PROPOSED. THIS PACKAGE PROPOSES
ONE POINT THREE BILLION DOLLARS
IN GENERAL FUND OVER THREE
YEARS INCLUDING SEVEN HUNDRED
EIGHTY FOUR MILLION IN TWENTY
TWENTY ONE POINT TUNE. TO
ADDRESS CLIMATE RISKS IT TOOK
ME TO SING THE IMPACTS OF
CLIMATE CHANGE. THE STATE'S
EFFORTS TO CONSERVE 30% OF OUR
LANDS AND COASTAL WATERS BY
TWENTY THIRTY. THIS PACKAGE CAN
BE BROKEN DOWN INTO FOUR PARTS
FIRST THE PACKAGE INCLUDES
THREE HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION.
OVER TWO YEARS AND THE SUPPORT
EFFORTS TO EXTREMELY. INCLUDING
URBAN THREE PROJECT AND
EFFICIENCY UPGRADE FOR LONG
HOUSEHOLDS AND STRATEGIC GREEN
AND COOL SERVICES BLOWING
RESIDENTIAL BUILDING. IT IS THE
PACKAGING TWO ONE ELEVEN FIVE
OVER TWO YEARS TO PROTECT
COMMUNITIES FROM SEA LEVEL RISE
COASTAL WETLAND REST. AND IN
POSTAL. AT STATE. IT'S ALSO IN
FOUR HUNDRED NINETY MILLION
OVER THREE YEARS BRADFORD TO
PROVIDE A MULTI. APPROACH TO
CLIMATE WAS WAS RESULT. THIS
INCLUDES. PROJECTS SERVICE
MODEL FOR. YOU TO IF IT'S AND-
AS WELL AS LOCAL AND COMMUNITY.
AND RESILIENCE PLANS AND
ASSOCIATED PRODUCTS. FINALLY
THE PACKAGE INCLUDES TWO
HUNDRED EIGHTY SEVEN BILLION
PROJECTS AND PROGRAMS THAT
ALIGN WITH THE STATE'S
FUNDAMENTALS INCLUDING CLIMATE
ASSESSMENT. AND THE PLUGGING
AND ABANDONING WORK IN THE OIL
AND GAS WELLS AMONG OTHER
PROPOSALS. WHAT HAPPENED AFTER
MY COLLEAGUE WAS HEARING. WILL
BE PROVIDING AN OVERVIEW OF THE
SET BACK. THANKS BYE AND
HEARING. OF FINANCE. SOME
TOTALING ONE POINT EIGHT
BILLION DOLLARS IN TWENTY
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO AND THREE
POINT TWO BILLION DOLLARS OVER
THREE YEARS. THE ZERO EMISSION
VEHICLE AND INFRASTRUCTURE
INVESTMENTS IN THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET IN MAY REVISION WILL
HELP SCALE THE ZERO EMISSION
VEHICLE MARKET IN WAYS THAT
BENEFIT ALL CALIFORNIANS AND
ACCELERATE THE STATE TOWARD
MEETING. CLIMATE IN
TRANSPORTATION GOALS
ESTABLISHED IN THE GOVERNOR'S
THAT EXECUTIVE ORDER
INCONSISTENT WITH CALIFORNIA'S
ZERO EMISSION VEHICLE MARKET
DEVELOPMENT STRATEGY.
SPECIFICALLY THE MAYOR VISION
INCLUDES ONE POINT FOUR BILLION
DOLLARS TO IMPROVE AIR QUALITY
M. DRIVE RECOVERY THROUGH
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT AND JOB
CREATION. THROUGH THE DELIVERY
OF OVER ONE THOUSAND ZERO
EMISSION DRAYAGE TRUCKS ONE
THOUSAND TRANSIT BUSES AND ONE
THOUSAND SCHOOL BUSES AS WELL
AS THE REQUISITE CHARGING AND
FUELING INFRASTRUCTURE TO
ENABLE THESE DEPLOYMENTS. MAY
REVISION ALSO INCLUDES
ADDITIONAL FUNDING FOR EXAMPLE
REBATE PROGRAMS THAT PROVIDE
MORE EQUITABLE ACCESS TO USE
ADS FOR LOW AND MODERATE INCOME
HOUSEHOLDS. THE OTHER THESE
INVESTMENTS WILL TARGET
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES WHO
DISPROPORTIONATELY BORNE THE
NEGATIVE IMPACT OF POOR AIR
QUALITY AS WELL AS IMPROVED
PRIVATE SECTOR CONFIDENCE AND
ENABLE INCREASED PARTICIPATION
IN THE MARKET ALONG FOR THE
ZERO EMISSION INDUSTRY TO
CAPITALIZE ON SCALE. AND
FINALLY THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
INCLUDED THE SECURITIZATION OF
APPROXIMATELY ONE BILLION
DOLLARS OF FUTURE REVENUES TO
INCREASE THE PACE AND SCALE OF
MARKET ENABLING ELECTRIC
VEHICLE CHARGING AND HYDROGEN
FUELING STATIONS. FUNDED BY AN
EXTENSION OF EXISTING FEES
SCHEDULED TO SUNSET IN TWENTY
TWENTY FOUR. THE MAIN REVISION
MAINTAINS THE EXTENSION OF
EXISTING FEES WHICH ARE
NECESSARY TO PROVIDE A
SUSTAINABLE FUNDING SOURCE FOR
PRIORITY PROGRAMS BUT REPLACES
THE SECURITIZED ATION OF FUTURE
REVENUES WITH FIVE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS IN ONE TIME
GENERAL FUND. FIRST I HAVE A
FEELING INFRASTRUCTURE GRANTS
HAPPY ENERGY COMMISSION. AND I
WILL BRIEFLY TURN IT OVER TO MY
COLLEAGUE A MAN WHO WILL COVER
THE ENERGY PACKAGE. GOOD
MORNING IN MELBOURNE AND- THE
MAYOR VISION INCLUDES NINE
HUNDRED AND TWELVE MILLION
DOLLARS IN FUNDING AT THE
CALIFORNIA ENERGY COMMISSION
THE PUBLIC UTILITIES COMMISSION
THE CONCOCTION THE OCEAN
PROTECTION COUNCIL. WILDLIFE
AND OFFICE OF EMERGENCY
SERVICES WITH YOUR CLEAN ENERGY
INVESTMENTS. THESE RESOURCES
WILL HELP THE STATE ACCELERATED
PROGRESS ON REACHING IT SB ONE
HUNDRED CLEAN ENERGY GOALS. THE
INVESTMENTS INCLUDE TWENTY
MILLION DOLLARS SPURRED BY
MENTALLY RESPONSIBLE
DEVELOPMENT OF OFFSHORE WIND
pDOLLARS TO CARRY A CRITICAL
RESOURCE IN TRANSMISSION
PLANNING TO SUPPORT
UNPRECEDENTED LEVELS OF CLEAN
ENERGY BILL THAT NEEDED TO BE
SPENT CRIME ENERGY AND CLIMATE
GOALS. THREE HUNDRED AND FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS TO SUPPORT
CREATES MARSHALL LONG DURATION
STORAGE PROJECTS THAT ARE
CRITICAL TO THE SUCCESS OF
CALIFORNIA'S EFFORTS CARBONIZED
ELECTRICITY SYSTEM. TWO HUNDRED
AND FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS FOR
INDUSTRIAL SECTOR
DECARBONISATION A HUNDRED AND
TWENTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS IN
THIS GROUP PRODUCTION
INVESTMENT PROGRAMS TO REDUCE
ENERGY SOURCE FROM PRODUCTION
FACILITIES. AND A HUNDRED AND
TEN MILLION DOLLARS IN GREEN
HYDROGEN PRODUCTION TO ALERT
THE TECHNICIAN. AWAY ALSO FEELS.
NO CONCLUDES OUR VIEW IN THE
MINISTRY CLIMATE CHANGE AND-
WERE HAPPY TO. ANY QUESTIONS
AND I BROKE FROM THE APARTMENT
AVAILABLE TO FIELD QUESTIONS AS
WELL. THANK YOU- MS ELLERS AND
MISTER BROWN YOU HAVE SOME
COMMENTS ON THESE PROPOSALS. HI
YES GOOD MORNING RACHEL IT WAS
WITH THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE- SO AS YOU HEARD THERE'S
ONE PACKAGE THAT'S CALLED THE
CLIMATE RESILIENCE PACKAGE BUT
REALLY THERE ARE MULTIPLE
DIFFERENT PACKAGES AND
PROPOSALS THAT ARE. SHOULD YOU
SHOULD BE THOUGHT OF AS AB
RESPONSES TO CLIMATE CHANGE SO-
THAT MAKES THINGS A LITTLE
COMPLICATED FOR YOU BUT WE
REALLY WOULD ENCOURAGE YOU TO
THINK ABOUT ALL OF THESE PIECES
OF THE PUZZLE TOGETHER AND NOT
ISOLATE IT- AND MAKE SURE THAT
ALL OF YOUR PRIORITIES AND
INTENTIONS ARE REFLECTED ACROSS
ALL OF THESE DIFFERENT
PACKAGES. SOME OF THE PROPOSALS
BEFORE YOU ARE CONTINUATIONS
ARE EXPANSIONS OF EXISTING
PROGRAMS THAT YOU'RE FAMILIAR
WITH THEM IN THE CLIMATE
PACKAGE IN PARTICULAR THAT
TRANSFORMATIVE CLIMATE
COMMUNITIES URBAN GREENING
THESE ARE EXISTING PROGRAMS BUT
THERE ARE MANY NEED BRAND NEW
INITIATIVES ACROSS THESE
PACKAGES BRAND NEW PROGRAMS-
ABOUT AS AS YOU MENTIONED IN
YOUR OPENING COMMENTS MISTER
CHAIR THE AMOUNT OF INFORMATION
IS RELATIVELY LIMITED THE
ADMINISTRATION'S BEEN GREAT
ABOUT RESPONDING BUT- IT'S A
LOT OF INFORMATION. AND MORE
IMPORTANTLY THERE'S NOT A
STATUTORY FRAMEWORK BEING
PROPOSED FOR THESE NEW PROGRAMS
THAT WOULD PROVIDE
ACCOUNTABILITY OVERSIGHT
OPPORTUNITY FOR THE LEGISLATURE
TO- PROVIDE GUIDANCE OVER HOW
FUNDS SHOULD BE PRIORITISED
WHETHER THERE SHOULD BE
COMPETITIVE GRANTS OR STATE
SELECTED PROJECTS- YOU KNOW IF
YOU THINK ABOUT WHAT I BONTA
THAT YOU WOULD PUT TOGETHER
THINK OF HOW MUCH OF A
FRAMEWORK YOU USUALLY WORK ON-
TO GUIDE THE EXPENDITURES OF A
BOND THIS IS SORT OF LIKE
MULTIPLE BONDS COMING TOGETHER
WITHOUT THAT FRAMEWORK. SO
GIVEN THE MAGNITUDE OF THE
SPENDING IN A NUMBER OF
ACTIVITIES YOU MIGHT WANT TO
THINK ABOUT TAKING A LITTLE BIT
MORE TIME AND DEFERRING SOME OF
THESE DECISIONS ESPECIALLY AS
YOU'RE WORKING ACROSS ALL OF
THESE DIFFERENT PACKAGES- INTO
LATER IN THE SUMMER THAT COULD
GIVE YOU THE CHANCE TO LEARN
MORE ABOUT SOME OF THE-
PROPOSALS AND- AND WHAT THE
ADMINISTRATION. IS INTENDING.
ALL TO CRAFT STATUTES LINK AND
PER. THAT EXTRA KIND OF BILL
AND- AND OVER OVER EMPLOYMENT.
D. AND ALSO TO MAKE SURE THAT
THESE PACKAGES REFLECT YOUR
LIFE. PRIORITIES FOR A- THAT
SOME OF THE BOND PROPOSALS THAT
I BEEN WORKING THROUGH THE LIKE.
ON BOTH PS. AND THE SENATE
HOUSE HAVE FOR EXAMPLE
SIGNIFICANTLY MORE FOR SEA
LEVEL RISE RESPONSE AND I AM
FOR OUR LOCAL PLANNING AND-
LOCAL PROJECT IMPLEMENTATION
THEN THE PROPOSALS BEFORE YOU.
SO THAT'S JUST A FEW EXAMPLES
OF PLACES WHERE THE LEGISLATIVE
PRIORITIES MIGHT DIFFER- SO
IT'S A LOT TO WORKING WITH- AND
NOT A LOT OF TIME BEFORE THE
DEADLINE I AM BUT- BUT- A LOT
OF. AND IMPORTANT- THAT AND-
WHAT KIND OF AS WAS MY- REALLY
UNPRECEDENTED INVESTMENTS HERE
SO TAKING TIME MAKES SENSE
THANKS. THANK YOU MISTER BROWN
DID YOU HAVE ANYTHING TO ADD.
NO THINKING MEDICATING- THE
DEALERS COVERED IT- BUT- MYSELF
AND MY COLLEAGUES ARE HERE
AVAILABLE IF YOU HAVE QUESTIONS
ON ANY OF THE PACKAGES THANK
YOU- FOR YOUR- IS A LAWYER SO.
MY UNDERSTANDING IS THAT- A
GLOOMY LET ME START BY SAYING I
APPRECIATE TAKE YOUR SUGGESTION
THAT WE MIGHT WANT TO STEP BACK
AND TAKE A LITTLE MORE TIME
WITH SOME OF THESE ITEMS GIVEN
THE- PRESS OF TIME AND WE HAVE.
I DON'T KNOW IF I WOULD CALL
THE LUXURY OF DOING THAT- WITH
WITH SOME OF THESE FUNDS MY
UNDERSTANDING IS THAT- WITHOUT
SOME OF THE FEDERAL FUNDS THE
EXPENDITURES DON'T HAVE TO BE
AGAIN UNTIL- SOMETIME IN TWENTY
TWENTY FOUR. IS THAT CORRECT.
YES THAT'S CORRECT IT IS- AND
USUAL IN SOME WAYS THAT WE HAVE
THIS MUCH FEDERAL FUNDING THAT
WE HAVE AS MUCH FLEXIBILITY
OVER HOW TO SPEND IT AND THEN
WE HAVE THE EXTENT EXTENDED
TIMELINE TO SPEND IT SO YEAH
YOU DO YOU DO HAVE A LITTLE BIT
MORE TIME THAT MIGHT BE TYPICAL
OF SOME FEDERAL GRANTS AND- AND
HOW DOES THAT AFFECT OUR- A
DECISION MAKING PROCESS- ARE
WE- ABLE. TO WAIT THAT THAT
LONG A TIME TO ACTUALLY
ALLOCATE THE FUNDS. YEAH AND
YOU CAN ALLOCATE- DIFFERENT
AMOUNTS OVER DIFFERENT YEARS TO
IF YOU WANT IF YOU HAVE SOME
HIGH PRIORITIES YOU WANTED TO
ADDRESS THIS YEAR YOU CAN
ALLOCATE SOME O THE FUNDS AND
THEN HOLD ON TO THE REST FOR
FUTURE YEARS. SO JUST AS AN
EXAMPLE SOME OF THE FEDERAL
FUNDS THAT ARE IN THE PACKAGE
IS THE HEAD OF BEFORE YOU.
THERE'S ONE POINT THREE BILLION
DOLLARS FOR DRINKING WATER
FUNDS AS PART OF THE WATER
PACKAGE THERE'S ANOTHER BILLION
DOLLARS FOR THE WATER BOARD TO
ADDRESS WATER REARRANGES. SO
SOME OF THOSE ACTIVITIES ARE
PRETTY PRESSING LIKE LIKE THE
WATER DEBT THAT MIGHT BE
SOMETHING YOU WANT TO THINK
ABOUT MOVING ON MORE QUICKLY.
BUT ACTIVITIES LIKE BIG WATER
INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECTS THAT
MAYBE YOU WANT TO TAKE A LITTLE
BIT MORE TIME. ALL RIGHT THANK
YOU AND- A SPEAKING OF- WATER-
INFRASTRUCTURE- FOR THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE- THE
PROPOSAL INCLUDES ONE POINT
THREE BILLION FOR DRINKING
WATER AND WASTEWATER
INFRASTRUCTURE. CAN YOU GIVE US
SOME INDICATION OF HOW THIS. A
SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF FUNDING.
WOULD BE ALLOCATED BETWEEN THE
TWO PROGRAMS- AND STAFF
RESOURCES. YES SIR DRIVE OUR
DEPARTMENT FINANCE AND JUST TO
CLARIFY A LITTLE BIT ON ON THE-
FEDERAL ARE BOTH FUNDING
DEADLINE SO IT HAS TO BE
ENCUMBERED. BY TWENTY TWENTY
FOUR AND THEN TRULY YOU
LIQUIDATED BY TWENTY TWENTY SIX
SO IT'S ACTUALLY A LITTLE BIT
OF THE OPPOSITE WHERE WE DON'T
HAVE TIME ON THE FEDERAL FUNDS
THAT'S THE ONE THAT WE ACTUALLY
NEED TO GET THOSE PROJECTS OUT
BECAUSE- HAVE MISSED A LETTER
SAID YOU KNOW. THESE ARE LARGE
PROJECT BECAUSE THEY TAKE A
LONG TIME TO BUILD AND GET OUT
SO IF WE ACTUALLY DON'T USE
THAT FUNDING WE LOSE IT IT GOES
BACK TO THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
SO THERE'S- THERE IS ACTUALLY.
A SIGNIFICANT URGENCY TO
PROCREATE APP FINDING TO BE
ABLE TO HAVE A DEPARTMENTS
STARTED GETTING THE PROJECT OUT
THE DOOR AND SPEND IT BECAUSE
AGAIN IF YOU DON'T SPEND WE
HAVE TO REVERT IT BACK TO THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT- SO JUST TO
CLARIFY ON THAT POINT. AND THEN
SAT DOWN THE ONE POINT THREE
POSSO IT BE ABOUT THREE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS THAT WOULD BE-
WASTE WATER RELATED ABOUT ONE
BILLION DOLLARS THAT THAT WOULD
BE DRINKING WATER RELATED AND
THEN I GENERALLY LIKE WE LIKE
WE DO FOR BONDS YOU KNOW WE'RE
AUTHORIZING ABOUT FIVE PERCENT.
TO BE SPENT ON ADMINISTRATIVE
COSTS AND SO- YOU KNOW A LOT OF
THESE PROGRAMS ARE OUR PROGRAM
THAT WE HAVE- FUNDED INVOLVED
BEFORE AND WE'RE STRUCTURING
THE- KIND OF THE PROGRAM'S VERY
SIMILARLY- AND SO I JUST KIND
OF KNOW THAT SO IT'S CONSISTENT
WITH HOW WE'VE- IMPLEMENTED
THESE PROGRAMS BEFORE. THERE'S
A TWENTY MILLION DOLLARS.
ALLOCATED FOR A P. FAST CLEAN
UP. AND I GUESS MY QUESTION IS
OF THE- OF THE- PROBLEM IS MUCH
LARGER THAN A TWENTY MILLION
DOLLARS SO WHY IS THE AMOUNT
SOLO. YES ALSO- AND YOU KNOW AS
WATER WORK ACT ALSO ON THE LINE
TO. PROVIDE THIS INFORMATION
BUT THERE'S A KIND OF A NEW YOU
KNOW EMERGING- KIND OF CHEMICAL
THAT IT'S STILL BEING ANALYZED
AND SO I UNITED WE THINK THAT
THIS IS A GOOD A GOOD IT ONE
TIME INVESTMENT- IN ADDITION TO
ALL THE OTHER INVESTMENTS WE'RE
MAKING AND WATER RESILIENCE BUT
NOT SURE IF- ANYBODY FROM THE
WATER BORDER OR THE AGENCY HAS.
MORE AT. TO HAVE SOMEONE FROM
THE WATER BOARD TO WHO CAN ADD
COMMENTS ON THAT. GOING ONCE.
IT SEEMS LIKE- BECAUSE- THE
WORLD WE'RE GONNA HAVE TO WAIT
FOR AN ANSWER ON THAT QUESTION-
MISTER BENNETT ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BETTER I THINK YOU HAVE
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
TO. YOUR BOTTOM OF. OVERALL I
CERTAINLY- PROPITIATE ALL THE
EFFORTS THAT HAVE MOVED FORWARD
HERE AND ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
LIKE TO SAY THAT AT THE
BEGINNING OF THIS IS THAT- THIS
IS. IT IN MANY WAYS IT'S HARDER
TO SPEND LOTS OF MONEY QUICKLY
WELL- WHEN YOU WHEN YOU HAVE A
TIGHT BUDGET THERE IS THAT THAT
DISCIPLINE THAT COMES WITH A
TIGHT BUDGET- AND- I APPRECIATE
THE EFFORTS TO TRY TO MOVE UP
QUICKLY AND AT THE SAME TIME-
PAY ATTENTION TO SO MANY NEEDS
THAT WE HAVE. IN PARTICULAR I
BELIEVE THAT THE GOVERNOR STAFF
HAS CERTAINLY. MADE A GOOD
FAITH EFFORT TO LISTEN TO THE
COMMENTS MADE BY- MEMBERS-
PARTICULARLY IN THIS COMMITTEE-
AND I'LL I'LL POINT OUT A FEW
OF THOSE SAYS THAT AS I MAKE
SOME AS I ASK SOME QUESTIONS
AND MAKE SOME COMMENTS BUT- IN
TERMS OF SEA LEVEL RISE-
FUNDING FOR SPECIFIC PROJECTS.
I THINK IS IT GOING TO BE AN
ONGOING NEED FOR US WITH THE
CLIMATE CHANGE IMPACTS THAT WE
HAVE- I HAVE A PARTICULAR
QUESTION ABOUT THE COASTAL
COMMISSION BECAUSE COMMISSION
IS. HEAVILY INVOLVED IN MANY
CHALLENGES DEALING WITH- THE
IMPACTS OF CLIMATE CHANGE OF
THE IMPACTS ON COASTAL ACCESS
FOR OUR CITIZENS. THERE BUDGET
WAS CUT LIKE EVERYBODY ELSE'S
BY 5% THOSE. THOSE BUDGET CUTS
HAVE NOT BEEN RESTORED AND
SMALL AGENCIES MY EXPERIENCE IS
IT IS THAT THOSE. PERCENTAGE
CUTS ARE MUCH MORE DIFFICULT
FOR THEM TO ADJUST TO- IS IT IS
THERE. A REASON WHY THERE
HASN'T BEEN ANY FUNDING AND IN
ADDITION TO THAT THERE'S BEEN
NO FUNDING INCREASE FOR THE
COASTAL COMMISSION RELATIVE TO
OTHER AGENCIES. AND THE COST
COMMISSION IS VERY INVOLVED IN.
MAKING IMPROVEMENTS AT THE
COAST WITH SOME OF THE GRANT
PROGRAM SIX ADDRESS I'M NOT
JUST A REGULATIONS SO COULD TO
COULD ANYBODY ADDRESS. AT ONE
FOR ME AT THE THIS POINT TIME.
SO SURGERY. HOW DO THAT IN ON
THIS- AND THEN ALSO YOU PASS IT
ON TO MY RESEARCH AGENCY-
COLLEAGUES ON THE- PROBLEM YOU
KNOW SEALEVEL RISE COMPONENTS
OF THE CLIMATE PACKAGE- SO YOU
KNOW A LOT LIKE- LIKE ME EITHER
AGENCIES AND THERE WERE. 5% YOU
KNOW EFFICIENCY TARGETS- THAT
THAT WERE INCLUDED- ANKLE TO
COMMISSION WAS ALSO PART OF
THAT WHERE- IT'S KIND OF GEARED
TOWARDS- MAKING OPERATIONAL
EFFICIENCIES- WITHIN GOVERNMENT
SO THERE WERE- YOU KNOW SO FIVE
PERCENT- FROM THAT. I WILL NOTE
THAT THERE IS FUNDING FROM- CAP
AND TRADE- FOR THE COASTAL
COMMISSION SO FOR THIS- NEXUS
WE ARE FOR TWENTY ONE TWENTY.
ONE POINT FIVE MILLION WHICH
SUPPORTS THEIR WORK ON SEA
LEVEL RISE- WE HAD INITIALLY
INCLUDED OPERABLE WHAT PART OF
OVERLY ACTION THAT I WAS NOT
ADOPTED. SO WHAT WE DID WE HAD
SHIFTED THE AMOUNTS THAT WAS
NOT ADOPTED IN EARLY ACTION TO
THE TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO
BUDGET CASTLE THERE'S ABOUT ONE
POINT FIVE BILLION DOLLARS
THERE THAT. WOULD GO TO THE
COASTAL COMMISSION FOR THIS
NEXT UPCOMING YEAR- TO THE FOR
A LOT OF THEIR- KIND OF THE C.
C. LEVEL RISE EFFORTS THAT ARE
FUNDED BY CAP AND TRADE FUNDS.
AND THERE'S THE YOU KNOW TWO
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS
INVESTMENTS- IN SEA LEVEL RISE-
WHICH- MY COLLEAGUES FROM THE
AGENCY COULD YOU COULD SPEAK TO
ADVOCATES SPEAK TO THE
COLLABORATION THEY HAVE. WITH
THE- COASTAL COMMISSION ON THAT
EVER. THANK MUCH SERGIO B. JUST.
A YOU PROCEED WITH THE ANSWER.
I THE- IS. TO FUNDING FOR THE
COASTAL COMMISSION- AND- IF YOU
AS YOU RESPOND. TO THE QUESTION
NOW. IF YOU COULD EXPLAIN HOW
THE COMMISSION IS EXPECTED. TO
INTEGRATE WITH OTHER AGENCIES
AND DO ADDITIONAL WORK IN
COLLABORATION WITH OTHER
AGENCIES WITHOUT ADDITIONAL
FUNDING. I'D BE INTERESTED IN
KNOWING. THANK YOU FOR
FOLLOWING UP. THANK YOU FOR
THAT FOLLOW UP TO THE- KAREN
ASSEMBLY MEMBER THANKS SO MUCH
FOR THE QUESTION AND FOR
PRESIDING OVER THIS HEARING I'M
WAY CROAK WITH THE NATURAL
RESOURCES SECRETARY- FIRST OF
ALL HAS GONE UP. MAYBE STATE
THE OBVIOUS WHICH IS WE SHARE
YOUR PRIORITY TO IMPROVE AND
EXPAND INVESTMENTS IN OUR
PROTECTING CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITIES IN NATURAL PLACES
AGAINST THE LEVEL RISE AND IN
COASTAL INUNDATION- BEFORE I
GET TO THE POINT AROUND THE
TYPICALLY THE COASTAL
COMMISSION WERE REALLY EXCITED
WITH THE TWO HUNDRED AND ELEVEN
MILLION DOLLAR PROPOSAL. I AS
IT RELATES TO IMPORTANT THINGS
WE KNOW NEED TO HAPPEN ON THE
COAST TWO HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS FOR COASTAL WETLAND
RESTORATION WHICH OF COURSE
ABSORB OUR STORM SURGE AND SEA
LEVEL RISE AND NATURE BASED
SOLUTION TO HELP ADDRESS SEA
LEVEL RISE AND THEN OVER ELEVEN
MILLION DOLLARS TO ENABLE THE
STATE PARK SYSTEM. TO IMPLEMENT
THEIR- UPDATED SEALEVEL RISE
ACTION PLAN. COASTAL COMMITTEE
IS ABSOLUTELY BEEN A LEADER
WITHIN OUR ADMINISTRATION AND
OUR AGENCY- I'M HELPING BRING
DISPARATE OUTSIDE ENTITIES
TOGETHER WITHIN STATE
GOVERNMENT TO REALLY GET ON THE
SAME PAGE WITH WHAT WE NEED TO
DO. I'M THE LEVEL RIGHTS WHAT
WE DON'T WANT TO DO IS
OBVIOUSLY REQUIRED THAT THE
COASTAL COMMISSION ON A PERMIT
BY PERMIT BASIS ADDRESSED THE
ISSUE YOU WANT A MORE HOLISTIC
PROACTIVE APPROACH. SO OUR
AGENCY AND OTHER AGENCIES WITH
THE COASTAL COMMISSION OF
DEVELOPED. I'M JUST OUTLINED
SET OF PRINCIPLES. PLANNING
PRINTABLES ON SEALEVEL RISE
THAT'S GOING TO GUIDE OUR OUR
INVESTMENTS MOVING FORWARD SO I
DO THINK THAT THE POINT OF
PROGRESS. SERGIO CAN CORRECT ME
BUT I BELIEVE THAT COASTAL
COMMISSION IS MUCH LIKE OTHER
ENTITIES WITHIN OUR AGENCY IN
ACROSS THE GOVERNMENT WHERE-
BECAUSE WE ARE OVER TIME HAVE A
DEMONSTRATE A- OUR SYSTEMIC- OR
SORT OF I'M GOING DEFICIT IN
OUR ON GOING GENERAL FUND- WE
HAVEN'T- PLUS STOP- BUDGETS
WITHIN THE COASTAL COMMISSION
OR OTHER ENTITIES WITHIN OUR
AGENCY AND AS YOU POINT OUT
THOSE. THOSE OP ADDITIONS THE
CUTS ARE ARE. ARE REMAIN IN
PLACE- WE'VE BEEN FOCUSED ON
HOW DO WE SPEND THIS ONE TIME
FUNDING. I IN A WAY THAT
DOESN'T- EXTEND OUR GENERAL
FUND LIABILITY. BUT THAT BEING
SAID I THINK WE RECOGNIZE THAT
ON SEA LEVEL RISE AND OTHER.
CLIMATE DRIVEN THREATS WE'RE
GOING TO HAVE TO CONTINUE TO.
INVEST MORE OVER TIME- BOTH IN
ONE TIME AND PROBABLY IN THE
CAPACITY OF OUR ENTITIES WITHIN
OUR AGENCY. I APPRECIATE THE
RESPONSE- AND I UNDERSTAND THE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN THE ONE TIME
FUNDING AND THE ON GOING
CHALLENGES- THAT WE HAVE IN
TERMS OF THAT FUNDING I THINK
GIVEN THE CRISIS AND EVERYTHING
THAT WE HAVE OUT THERE. MY
EXPERIENCE COMING FROM LOCAL
GOVERNMENT IS AT THE COAST
COMMISSION SEEMS TO BE SORT OF
AT THE APEX OF ALL OF THESE
DIFFERENT AGENCIES EVERYTHING
COMES BACK TO WELL THEN WE HAVE
TO SEE WHAT THE CAUSE OF
COMMISSION SAYSENOUGH THAT. IN
AND SO AS YOU SAID THEY PLAY
REALLY PIVOTAL ROLE FOR ALL OF
THESE AGENCIES ULTIMATELY-
COMING TOGETHER SO IF THERE WAS
A WAY TO TAKE SOME ONE TIME
MONEY AND STRETCH IT OVER A
NUMBER OF YEARS YOU KNOW- FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS STRETCHED OVER
A NUMBER OF YEARS TO HELP WITH
ALL OF THIS. FAST MOVING
IMPLEMENTATION EXCITER IT
STRIKES ME AS A AS I I'M JUST
THROWING OUT AN EXAMPLE OF THE
NEED TO DISTRACT ME AS A AS A
REASONABLE EXAMPLE GIVEN THAT
YOU KNOW SOME OTHER AGENCIES
ARE RIVAS RECEIVING SIGNIFICANT
FUNDING INCREASES. AND I DON'T
HAVE THAT MUCH INTERACTION WITH
BECAUSE I JUST SEE THAT
HAPPENING OVER AND OVER AGAIN.
THE OTHER THING I WOULD POINT
OUT IS COMING FROM LOCAL
GOVERNMENT- CONSISTENTLY PEOPLE
WOULD HAVE TO BE TO WORK WOULD
BE CONCERNED ABOUT HOW MUCH
TIME WOULD IT WOULD THEY HAVE
TO WAIT FOR STAFF TO ANALYZE-
PROJECTS AND- YOU KNOWHOW MUCH
ABILITY TO CAUSE COMMISSION
STAFF HAVE HAVE IME TO DO
THAT. SO WITH THAT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR THAT RESPONSE AT
AND IF ANYBODY ELSE HAS A
RESPONSE ON THAT I'M GOING TO
JUMP TO SOME OTHER TOPICS BUT-
IF SOMEBODY WANTS IF WE WANT TO
STAY ON COSTA COMMISSION. IF
ANYBODY HAS ANYTHING ELSE ON
THAT I'M HAPPY TO HOLD OFF
THEIR- ALL JUST ADDED A QUICK
COMMENT- IF YOU DON'T MIND IS A
FORMER COASTAL COMMISSIONER-
THE COASTAL COMMISSION- IS
INTEGRAL TO ALL THESE EFFORTS
AROUND TO C. LEVEL RISE. AND I
JOIN YOU- DIRECTOR CRAWFORD AND-
CELEBRATING THE TWO HUNDRED
ELEVEN MILLION DOLLAR PROPOSAL
HERE I THINK IT'S GREAT- BUT I
DO THINK WE HAVE TO RECOGNIZE
THAT- OVER THE YEARS THE
COASTAL COMMISSION HAS BEEN- A
YEAR AFTER YEAR- HAD TO KIND OF
BEG FOR CRUMBS- WHEN IT COMES
TO- TO. FUNDING SO WHEN YOU ADD
THAT THE 5% EFFICIENCY- A
CIRCUMSTANCE- THAT PUTS IT
ADDITIONAL PRESSURE ON THEM TO
DO THE JOB THAT THEY ARE
CONSTITUTIONALLY REQUIRED TO
DO- WITH ESSENTIALLY LESS AND
LESS AND FEWER AND FEWER
RESOURCES- AND THEN ADD TO THAT
THESE ADDITIONAL
RESPONSIBILITIES THAT ARE
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT I THINK WE
ALL AGREE- AND- IT'S HARD TO
IMAGINE HOW THEY CAN ACTUALLY
GET THE WORK DONE AND WE KNOW
THAT WE WANT EVERYBODY TO BE
COLLABORATING GETTING THIS
WORKED OUT SO. TO SUBMIT
ADDITIONAL COMMENTS- FOR YOU-
AND YOU HAVE SOME ADDITIONAL
POINTS OKAY AND THEN WE HAVE-
IS RIVAS WAITING. AND IT HERE
FOR COMMENTS ON KANNST
COMMISSION AND SHE PREFERS TO
GO NOW THAT'S FINE BUT- I THINK
SHE'S ON TOP OF ANOTHER TOPIC
GREAT- IF IS THERE MORE DETAIL
ON THE BIOMASS TO HYDROGEN AND
BIOFUELS- PILOT- I'M AT I WOULD
LIKE TO MAKE SURE S. AS WE'RE
TRYING TO MOVE FORWARD. AT THAT
MOMENT I'LL TALK ABOUT HYDROGEN
AND IN INTO CONCEPTS- AND THE
THAT IS WHEN IT COMES TO.
CHARGING STATIONS AND- THEN WE
HAVE THESE OTHER HYDROGEN THAT-
YOU KNOW PILOT PROGRAM PROGRAMS
OUT THERE ARE BIOMASS TO
HYDROGEN JUST IN TERMS OF
CREATING IT. SEEMS TO BE THE
RIGHT NOW WE ARE. INVESTING
SIGNIFICANT FUNDS INTO THE
EEVEE CHARGING STATIONS WHICH I
COMPLETELY SUPPORT- MY BELIEF
IS FOR. THE BEST THING FOR US
TO DO IN CALIFORNIA IS TO DO
THE SAME THING THAT THEY'RE
DOING IN EUROPE WHICH IS TRYING
TO. HAVE THE RESILIENCY OF BOTH
HYDROGEN AND ELECTRICITY- AS
THE OPTIONS FOR US TO MOVE
FORWARD IN TERMS OF CLIMATE
CHANGE- IT SEEMS LIKE WE ARE-
WE NEED TO WE NEED TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE HAVE THAT THAT HYGIENE
MOVING FORWARD ALSO. A NUMBER
OF PEOPLE ARE CONCERNED ABOUT
THE HYDROGEN NOT BEING A 100%
CLEAN YET. AND I WOULD POINT
OUT THAT THE ELECTRICITY WERE
USING FOR ELECTRICITY CHARGING
STATIONS IS ALSO NOT A 100%
CLEAN YET- SO I WOULD SUPPORT
POLICIES THAT WOULD SAY THEY
BOTH NEED TO BE A HUNDRED
PERCENT. RENEWABLE SOURCES OF
ENERGY. AT WHEN THE TIME COMES.
WHEN THAT IS SHOULD BE ON THE
SAME SCHEDULE IN TERMS OF
NEEDING TO BE THERE- BUT FOR US
TO HOLD BACK ON GETTING THE
INFRASTRUCTURE GOING FOR
HYDROGEN- DOESN'T- DOESN'T MAKE
SENSE IF WE SAY HEY WE WANT TO
THE INFRASTRUCTURE OF THERE'S
NOT SUPPORT FOR THE INSTRUCTION
TELL HAD REGION IS A 100%
CLEAN. BECAUSE IF THAT WAS THE
CASE WE WOULD BE DOING E. V.
THAT STRUCTURE ALSO. SO WITH
THAT BEING SAID- HE YOU KNOW IT
HI I AM I WOULD LIKE TO- SEE IF
WE CAN COME UP WITH SOME
POLICIES THAT. SUPPORT BOTH PUT
THEM BOTH ON THE SAME KIND OF
TIME FRAME- IN TERMS OF WHEN
THEY HAVE TO GET TO A 100%
GREEN BUT NOT DISADVANTAGE ONE
OVER THE OTHER- WHILE THEY'RE
WAITING TO GET THEIR- BECAUSE
WE- CERTAINLY WITH TRUCKS. AND
BUSES HYDROGEN. I THINK
EVERYBODY AGREES IS A IS A GOOD
SOLUTION- IT SEEMS TO ME WE
SHOULDN'T IGNORE THE FACT THAT
FOR PASSENGER VEHICLES IT'S
ALSO STILL. A VIABLE OPTION-
PARTICULARLY WITH THE LOWER
LIFE CYCLE COST
EXTRATERRESTRIAL AGAIN I'M NOT
TRYING TO ADVANTAGE ONE OVER
THE OTHERS WILL TRY TO MAKE
SURE WE STAY RESILIENT OF BOTH
OF THOSE SO- THE ON THE BIOMASS
ARE THERE ANY MORE DETAILS ON
THE- BIOMASS TO HYDROGEN
BIOFUELS PILOT- AND- IS THERE
AN EFFORT TO ENSURE- THAT WERE
COMING UP WITH A GAME PLAN FOR-
BOTH. THE ENERGY SOURCE IS
BEING- CLEAN AT THE SAME TIME
AND BOTH OF THEM GETTING-
ADEQUATE AMOUNT OF THE
INFRASTRUCTURE CHARGING
STATIONS GOING FORWARD THANK
YOU. ASSEMBLY MEMBER. AGAIN
WAIT CRAWFORD I'LL TURN IT OVER
IN A MOMENT OF TO ONE OF MY
COLLEAGUES WHO CAN ANSWER
SPECIFIC ON THAT I'M THE
PROPOSED PROJECT ALLOCATION BUT
I'LL JUST. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
INSIGHTS ON ON HYDROGEN WE
RECOGNIZE HYDROGEN'S IMPORTANCE
FOR CALIFORNIA IN REACHING OUR
CARBON NEUTRALITY GOAL- THERE
WILL BE APPLICATIONS IN
CALIFORNIA ARE THAT WILL
CONTINUE TO REQUIRE LIQUID
FUELS SO THINK SHIPS AND PLANES
AND MANUFACTURING PROCESS SEES.
AND CLEAN HYDROGEN IS OBVIOUSLY
CRITICAL TO. MAINTAINING
ECONOMIC GROWTH IN THOSE
SECTORS WHILE ACHIEVING CARBON
NEUTRALITY SO REALLY APPRECIATE
YOUR INSIGHTS I'M GONNA TURN
INTO A COLLIE THAT CAN MORE
SPECIFICALLY ADDRESSED THE
QUESTION ON THAT ARE PROPOSED
ALLOCATION. HI GOOD MORNING
THIS IS CANON RITUAL- DEPUTY
DIRECTOR OF THE FILM
TRANSPORTATION DIVISION OKAY.
YES OKAY GREAT YEAH SO OF THE
THAT PACKAGE ON THE HYDROGEN
SIDE WE HAVE ABOUT FIVE HUNDRED
MILLION AND- A GENERAL PUSH TO
CLOSE THE LIGHT DUTY
INFRASTRUCTURE GAP OF THAT WILL
BE ABOUT THE IN BOTH ELECTRIC
AND HYDROGEN TO CLOSE THAT GAP
OF THE TWO HUNDRED MILLION
ABOUT FIVE HUNDRED MILLION TO
MEDIUM DUTY HEAVY DUTY
VEHICLES- BOTH ELECTRIC AND
HYDROGEN ARE VERY MUCH ELIGIBLE
FOR THAT IT'S OFFER CONSUMER
DRIVEN SO WE CAN REALLY GET
HUNDRED UPTAKE BY TRANSIT
AGENCIES AS WELL AS ELECTRIC-
ELECTRIC BOX UPTAKE BY TRANSIT
AGENCIES. SIMILARLY ON THAT
FOUR HUNDRED FIFTEEN MILLION
BAHT TARGETED HEAVY DUTY
VEHICLES- GREAT TRUCK TRANSIT
AND SCHOOL BOTH ELECTRIC AND
HYDROGEN ARE ELIGIBLE FOR THAT
AS WELL BONTA YET WE SHARE YOUR
SENTIMENT THAT WE NEED TO SET
THE FOR BOTH ELECTRIC AND
HYDROGEN I WILL NOTE THAT OF
OUR PROPERTY ONE HUNDRED
MILLION PER YEAR IN THE
CONTRACT PROTECTION PROGRAM
WE'VE INVESTED TWENTY MILLION
PER YEAR JUST ON THE PUBLIC
HYDROGEN OXIDE AND I THINK
WE'RE NOT GO TO THAT EVEN ON
THE MEDIUM DUTY HOW DID YOU
DECIDE. TO ABOUT ONE THIRD OF
THOSE INVESTMENTS HAVE GONE TO
HYDROGEN- ALREADY AND WE SEE-
LARGE INVESTMENTS. HAVE BEEN
GOING FORWARD AS WELL. D. DO
YOU KNOW THE DOWN INTO OF THE
IN TERMS OF PASS REAR SIDE
WHERE WE ARE WITH HYDROGEN
CHARGING STATIONS VERSUS
ELECTRIC CHARGING STATIONS.
YEAH SO WE HAVE ABOUT SEVENTY
THOUSAND ELECTRIC ISSUES OUT
THERE RIGHT NOW AND ABOUT FORTY
NINE HYDROGEN STATIONS. AND SO-
ON THE ELECTRIC SIDE WE ARE
LAGGING- MORE SO AND SO- THAT'S
WHY YOU FEEL GREATER INVESTMENT
ELECTRIFIED WE APPROACH IT FROM
A VERY DATA DRIVEN- PLACE. AND
TO LOOK AT THEY GOT FOR TWENTY
TWENTY FIVE THE LARGER GAP ON
THE ELECTRIFIED. ON THE HUNDRED
INSIDE- THERE'S ABOUT SEVENTY
EIGHT THOUSAND FUEL CELL
ELECTRIC VEHICLES ON THE ROAD
TODAY. AND WERE EXPECTED TO
REACH A HUNDRED AND FIVE
HUNDRED STATEMENT BY TWENTY
TWENTY THREE. AT THAT POINT
WE'LL HAVE PEELING CAPACITY
FOUR HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND
BLIGHTED HYDROGEN VEHICLES. AND
SO WHEN WE LOOK AT IT WE
LOOKED- ON THE DATA ANALYTICS
IN THE LIGHT HE FIRED TO MAKE
SURE WE'RE SUPPORTING BOTH. BUT
ALSO LOOKING AT WHAT CONSUMERS
ARE ADOPTING AND I SIMILARLY ON
THE MEDIA YOU HAVE TO DECIDE WE
LOOK AT WHAT IT DOES DIFFERENT
FLEETS THE CONTRACT ABOUT THE-
DRAINAGE IN THE BY NATURE OF
WHAT THEY'RE PREPARING. AND
WHERE WE CAN SUPPORT THE THERE-
AGAIN PHOTOELECTRIC AND HUNDRED
AND- TO GET TO THEIR MISSION
PETER. HE IF I COULD THAT I
HAVE. THE DALLAS BAY ON. THE
NUMBER OF VEHICLES BEING
PURCHASED AND YOU KNOW WHERE WE
ARE SHORT QUITE FRANKLY WERE
BEAT WE WANT TO MAKE SURE WE
GET THERE WITH. BUT YOU KNOW.
WHAT'S BOTTOM BUT THE- IF OUR
GOAL IS TO HAVE THE RESILIENCY
OF TWO DIFFERENT ENERGY SOURCES
THAT COULD HELP GET US TO
CLEAN- WE HAVE A CHICKEN AND
EGG PROBLEM AND THAT IF WE
DON'T HAVE THE HYDROGEN
CHARGING STATIONS PARTICULARLY-
YOU KNOW WHEN YOU ARE FIRST
STARTING OUT IF I MEAN IF
THEY'RE JUST VERY VERY FEW. A
DIFFICULT TO GET THE PASSENGER
VEHICLE SALES. TO GO UP- IT
SEEMS THAT- IF WERE FORWARD
THINKING WE NEED TO MAKE SURE
WE HAVE AN ADEQUATE AMOUNT SO
THAT WE CAN THEN FIND OUT
WHETHER THE CONSUMERS REALLY
ARE WILLING TO EMBRACE THAT
TECHNOLOGY. I DON'T KNOW AND-
SO I AND I'M NOT SURE I WOULD
ENCOURAGE US TO ONLY USE THE
ANALYSIS OF CURRENT NUMBER OF
SALES BECAUSE YOU WON'T GET THE
SALES UNTIL YOU CAN. TELL YOU
HAVE THE INFRASTRUCTURE OUT
THERE THAT WOULD MAKE SOMEBODY
FEEL COMFORTABLE WITH THAT SO I
HOPE WE WOULD CONSIDER THAT AS
WE'RE TRYING TO LOOK AT THAT
MIX- AND YEAH YOU'RE ABSOLUTELY
RIGHT. ABOUT THAT. WE MADE OUR
GOAL I THINK JUST WE WILL BE
BETTER OFF JUST JUST IT AND
THEY'RE DOING THE SAME THING IN
EUROPE BECAUSE THEY WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT THEY HAVE BOTH
OF THOSE- SOURCES- ALTAIR
BEFORE BECAUSE OF THE-
REDUNDANCY FACTOR. WHO WHO
KNOWS WHAT'S GOING TO HAPPEN
WITH EITHER ONE OF THOSE
SOURCES IN TERMS OF.
TECHNOLOGICAL CHALLENGES SIX
CENTER THAT THAT THAT MAY COME
FORWARD- AND LIFECYCLE COST AND
THOSE KINDS OF THINGS. FINALLY
I JUST A- WORD IT TURNED OVER
TO MY COLLEAGUE- I JUST WANT
TO. LET THE- THE STAFF IN
PARTICULAR AND THE
ADMINISTRATION- I APPRECIATE
THE TYING OF THE CAP ON THE
FEES ON ELECTRIC BILLS. TO THE
CONSUMER PRICE INDEX- THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT WE BROUGHT UP
HERE- IN THIS- COMMITTEE- ROOM-
IN PREVIOUS HEARINGS- THAT IT'S
BETTER FOR CALIFORNIA TO HAVE
FEES TIED. TO INFLATIONARY
INCREASES AND- YOU'VE DONE THAT
HERE AND I REALLY APPRECIATE
THAT- THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
MISTER MULLIN DID YOU HAVE A
FOLLOW UP QUESTION OR A
SEPARATE QUESTION. ALRIGHT THEN
WE'LL HAVE FIVE MINUTES READ
THIS AND THEN YOU MISTER MOLOT.
I AM VERY HAPPY THE INVESTMENT.
ALL INVESTMENTS AND THE FOCUS
ON EXTREME HEAT AND THIS MAY
BUDGET REVISED- IT'S CLEAR THAT
EXTREME HEAT IS HERE NOW AND
I'M HAPPY THAT ADMINISTRATION-
IS SUPPORTING COMMUNITIES THAT
ARE VULNERABLE TO THIS WEATHER
EVENT- BUT WHILE THE FUNDING
DIRECTED TO THE CVC TO CREATE A
PROGRAM OUT OF THE BILL PROGRAM
IS A GOOD STEP. I'M CONCERNED
THAT THAT WHOLE THING CLIMATE
IMPACTS OF WILL NOT BE AS
PRIORITIZED- YOU KNOW THE CC IS
FOCUSED ON ENERGY EFFICIENCY
AND THEY'RE VERY GOOD AT
DIRECTING FUNDING FOR ENERGY
EFFICIENCY BUT EXTREME HATE IS
PERVASIVE IN HARMING
COMMUNITIES LIKE THOSE IN MY
DISTRICT. YOU KNOW THIS FUNDING
IS LIMITED SOLELY TO
RESIDENTIAL UNITS TO REALLY
DRAW DOWN AMBIENT TEMPERATURES-
WELL I THINK TO REALLY DRAW
DOWN AMBIENT TEMPERATURES IN IN
AN ENTIRE COMMUNITY I THINK WE
NEED TO GIVE LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS THE ABILITY TO
DETERMINE WHICH PROJECTS DO
THAT IN ACHIEVE THAT GOAL- AND
POTENTIALLY WORK WITH NGOS THAT
ARE ON THE GROUND AND THEY CAN
HELP IDENTIFY THOSE AREAS- SO
THAT'S WHY I'M HOPEFUL THAT WE
CAN COMPLEMENT THE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS AT THE C. E. C.
AND CAN ALLOW OPR. TO WORK WITH
THE STRATEGIC GROWTH COUNCIL TO
DETERMINE THE GRANT PROCESS FOR
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS UP TO TAP
INTO RESOURCES AND TO EMPOWER
THEM TO IMPLEMENT THE EXTREME
HEAT MEASURES THAT ARE BEST FOR
THEM. THANK YOU. FOR THANK YOU
MR MOHAN. I THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN NOT SURE IF MISTER
SECRETARY IS STILL WITH US BUT
IT WAS GOOD TO SEE HIM- I THINK
THE- OPPORTUNITY EXISTS REALLY
AN EXTRAORDINARY OPPORTUNITY
ACTUALLY TO- INVEST. IN CLIMATE
RESILIENCE AND I HAD A- I GUESS
JUST A COMMENT TO START ON
RESILIENCE PLANNING AND THEN A
QUESTION. FOR THE
ADMINISTRATION ON THE- A CLEAN
VEHICLE REBATE PROGRAM WHICH IS
FIRST ON RESILIENCE PLANNING OF
HAPPY TO SEE THE TWENTY FIVE
MILLION BEING APPROPRIATED. I
TO OPR ON ADAPTATION AND
RESILIENCE PLANNING GRANTS- I
THINK IT NEEDS TO BE
SUFFICIENTLY INCREASED IF WE
WANT TO REALLY INCENTIVIZE- THE
LOCALS TO DO THE APPROPRIATE
ADAPTATION PLANNING JUST TO THE
SCALE- THAT IS NEEDED- GIVEN
THE CHALLENGES THAT WE FACE SO
WOULD LIKE TO SEE. A
CONVERSATION AROUND- INCREASING
THAT AMOUNT AND THEN JUST A
QUESTION ON THE- CLEAN VEHICLE
PROGRAM. THEY HAD THE- ZERO
EMISSION VEHICLE. ACCELERATION
DOES THE ADMINISTRATION PLAN.
TO LIMIT THE C. B. R. P. TO
ONLY LOW AND MIDDLE INCOME
FOLKS THE FOUR HUNDRED PERCENT.
OF F. P. L. THAT HAS BEEN- PUT
INTO A LANGUAGE OTHER SOME
CONCERNS THAT HAVE BEEN RAISED
THAT THAT IS SIMPLY TOO
LIMITING. AND WOULD LIKE TO
JUST GET A FEEL FOR THE
ADMINISTRATION'S THINKING ON
THAT. AND WHETHER THAT IS-
WHETHER THERE ARE SOME. A
POTENTIAL TO MOVE ON THAT. I
THINK YOU DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
I WAS SHORT ANSWER TO YOUR
QUESTION IS YES BUT I BELIEVE
MY COLLEAGUE SYDNEY BRIGUS IS
ONLINE AT AND AT THE AIRPORT
YOU CAN SPEAK TO THIS AS WELL.
HI SICKENING FOR JUST SOME THAT
DIVISION CHIEF FOR THE MOBILE
SOURCE. CONTROL DIVISION AT THE
CALIFORNIA AIR RESOURCES BOARD
CURRENTLY THE ADMINISTRATION'S
PROPOSAL IS TO LIMIT. AB SENIOR
PETE TO. THE LOW MODERATE
INCOME CONSUMERS THAT'S BELOW
THE 4100% OF FEDERAL POVERTY
LEVEL- AS YOU PREVIOUSLY
MENTIONED UNDERSTAND THAT THIS
IS YOU KNOW A CURRENT SOURCE
OF. OF CONVERSATION THAT I'M
SURE WILL CONTINUE. I JUST WANT
THAT ON THE RECORD THAT LOOK
FOR TO THE CONVERSATION I
CERTAINLY SUPPORT THE INTENT
THERE AND STEERING THAT THAT
BENEFIT TO LOW AND MIDDLE
INCOME- LOWER INCOME
INDIVIDUALS BUT LOOK FOR TO UP
CONVERSATION. THANK YOU MISTER
SMITH THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY RIGHT THE QUESTION
IS IT WE WERE ALL IN A DROUGHT
AGAIN WE KNOW THAT CALIFORNIA
THREE YEARS AGO WE DID A BIG
GROWTH DROUGHT STUDY BUT IN THE
LANGUAGE OF THIS BILL FOR WATER
AND NUMBER THREE PRESENTATION.
THAT DOES NOT SPECIFICALLY SAY
WATER STORAGES SAYS ADDRESS
DRINKING WATER SUPPLY
RELIABILITY AND FLOOD
PROTECTION CAN YOU ASSURE
MYSELF FOR MY COLLEAGUES. IN
THE- RESIDENTS OF CALIFORNIA
THAT THERE IS MONEY IN THERE
FOR WATER STORAGE. AND IT
PROBABLY COULD BE MISTER
CRAWFORD. YEAH I THINK SO MUCH
ASSEMBLY MEMBER. YOU'RE
ABSOLUTELY RIGHT STORAGE IS A
CRITICAL COMPONENT OF WHAT WE
NEED TO DO TO CONTINUE TO BUILD
OUR DROUGHT RESILIENCE I'M GLAD
TO REPORT THAT THE PROP ONE
FIVE STATEWIDE GENERAL
OBLIGATION BOND FUNDING THAT
PASSED IN TWENTY FOURTEEN. IS
IN THE PROCESS OF BEING
IMPLEMENTED AND RESULTING IN
MORE STORAGE PROD PROJECTS.
SPECIFICALLY TO YOUR POINT
THERE IS FUNDING IN OUR
PROPOSAL FOR STORAGE PROJECTS.
FOR EXAMPLE THERE ARE WE
PROPOSED THREE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS OF INVESTMENT TO HELP
REGIONS THAT ARE IMPLEMENTING
SIGMAR FOR THE SUSTAINABLE
GROUNDWATER MANAGEMENT ACT. I
MOVE TOWARDS SUSTAINABLE
GROUNDWATER USE. WHAT WE
ENVISION FOR THE THREE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS INCLUDE SHOVEL
READY PROJECTS FOR EXAMPLE TO
EXPAND STORAGE AND GROUNDWATER
STORAGE THAT ALLOWS FOR
RECHARGE BOB IN IN WINTERS AND
WET WINTERS- INTO UNDERGROUND
WATER STORAGE. SO OUR PORTION
OF OUR OF OUR PROPOSED BUDGET
THAT'S FIVE BILLION DOLLARS IN
WATER RESILIENCE IS VERY MUCH
FOCUSED ON PROVIDING FUNDING TO
REGIONS TO GET THE SHOVEL READY
OUR STORAGE PROJECTS IN PLACE.
THANK YOU- AND WE CAN GO OVER
TO OTHER ONES TOO AS WE GO
THROUGH OF ANOTHER BIG CONCERN
ON THE ZERO EMISSION VEHICLES
ON MY COLLEAGUES SPOKE ON IT I
THINK WE SHOULD HAVE MORE
FUNDING FOR THE HYDROGEN R. AND
D. AND TO BE A WELFARE WITH
ELECTRIC SIDE SO THERE EVEN SO
THE RESIDENTS TO CALIFORNIA
WILL HAVE A CHOICE THERE WILL
BE JUST SAY YOU CAN ONLY HAVE
ELECTRICITY BUT THEY SHOULD BE
ABLE TO HAVE A CHOICE. WITH
WHAT THEY DO FOR CLEAN ENERGY
AND- I THINK IT WAS ADDRESSED
EARLIER THAT WE CAN TRY TO GET
SOME MORE FUNDING TOWARDS AT.
IT'S ENOUGH ANOTHER- STICKLER
FOR ME IS WE'RE RENEWING TAXES
WE'RE HAVE A WINDFALL OF MONEY
IN THE STATE WE KNOW THAT WERE
OVERTAXED ALREADY AND WE SHOULD
BE LOWERING THE TAXES OF NOT
EXTENDING THESE TAXES TO THE
RESIDENTS CALIFORNIA SO WE CAN
RETAIN THE RESIDENTS TO STAY
HERE INSTEAD OF MOVING IN AND
OFF ALREADY LIVE MY TIME FOR
THE NEXT COMENTS THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU- I HAVE A
COUPLE MORE QUESTIONS BUT WE
SHOULD ESTABLISH QUORUM- BEFORE
ANY MEMBERS NEED TO LEAVE- SO
WHY DON'T WE DO THAT. HELLO
HERE SENATE HERE. MULLIN
PATTERSON READ IT HERE BUT
THERE. THANK YOU SO WE'RE
OFFICIAL NOW- ON THE TOPIC OF-
JOBS THE CV R. P. B. C. P. SAYS
THE PROGRAM IS GOING TO BE
TARGETED TO LOW AND MIDDLE
INCOME CUSTOMERS. I HOW IS THAT
GOING TO BE STRUCTURED AND- IN
A WAY THAT IS AS INCLUSIVE AS
POSSIBLE- BECAUSE OF THE WAY I
UNDERSTAND THE BCP IT'S VERY
FOCUSED ON- THOSE WITH THE MOST
MODEST MEANS AND I'M AT A
CHURCH SHOULD BE EXPANDED
SOMEWHAT BEYOND THAT. THANK YOU
FOR THE QUESTION AND SO AS WE
MENTIONED EARLIER WE ARE
PLANNING ON LIMITING THE
PROGRAM TO TARGET THESE LOW AND
MODERATE INCOME CONSUMERS HAPPY
TO TURN IT OVER AGAIN TESTED IF
SHE HAS ADDITIONAL DETAIL. I
THINK THEY DETAIL THERE'S AS
PREVIOUSLY NOTED MOST THAT THE
WHAT YOU SEE IN THE MAIN
REPRISES THAT THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL REALLY FOCUSES- QUITE
A BIT ON EQUITY- IS SUPPOSED TO
CLEAN CARS FOR ALL PROGRAM AND
THE CLEAN VEHICLE REBATE
PROJECT ARE REPRESENTED HERE-
AND BOTH OF THOSE TRAITS SERVE
AS YOU MENTIONED. ARE THOSE
WITH- LEAST MEANS SO UNDER
4100% OF FEDERAL POVERTY LEVEL
BUT IF THERE ARE SPECIFIC
PROGRAM QUESTIONS I'M HAPPY TO
ANSWER THOSE WELL I GUESS THAT
THE QUESTION IS THERE ARE THERE
ARE PEOPLE WHO ARE- ABOVE THE-
POVERTY LINE BUT- STILL- BUT
NOT ABLE TO. AFFORD VEHICLE A
CLEANER VEHICLE WITHOUT THE
ASSISTANCE OF THE REBATE
PROGRAM SO HOW DO WE HELP THOSE
FOLKS WHY DO WE WANT TO LIMIT
THIS- AT THE PLACE WHERE YOU'RE
LIMITING IT. WE ARE PROPOSING.
SURE I'M SO I CAN SPEAK TO
PERHAPS THE PROGRAM DIFFERENCES
BETWEEN THE CLEAN CARS FOR A
PROGRAM IN THE C. P. R. P.
PROGRAM AND PERHAPS THAT THAT
WILL HELP I'M IN TERMS OF THIS
THE SPECIFIC DIRECTION ON THE
SEAT EUROPEAN AND THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED BUDGET ALL
DEFERRED A DEAL LAST- BUT QUITE
SIMPLY- WHEN I LOOK AT THE TWO
PROGRAMS THE COMPLEMENTARY
NATURE AT THE CLEAN CARS FOR
ALL PROGRAM IS REALLY INTENDED.
YOU KNOW TO HELP ACCELERATE
BOOKS AREN'T NECESSARILY IN THE
NEW VEHICLE MARKET BUT HELP
ACCELERATE GET THE MENTIONS
GETTING THEM AND IS YOUR
MOBILITY OPTIONS THAT PROGRAM
DOES REQUIRE THE SCRAP OF CAR
IN ORDER TO GET INTO A CLEANER
OR ZERO EMISSION VEHICLE WERE A
SICKLY VEHICLE REBATE PROJECT
IS FOR NEW PURCHASES ONLINE.
OKAY I DON'T WANT TO BELABOR
THE POINT BUT WE HAVE A
TRANSITION- THAT WE INTEND TO
COMPLETE BY TWENTY THIRTY FIVE.
WHICH SOUNDS LIKE A LONG WAY
OFF BUT IT'S NOT THAT FAR AWAY-
AND- I THINK IT WOULD BE GOOD
TO HAVE A- LONG TERM STRATEGIC
PLAN. THAT TO A- PROVIDES US
WITH THE ROAD MAP OF. HOW WE'RE
GONNA GET TO THAT PLACE. OF
WHICH IS PARTICULARLY
DIFFICULT. POVERTY LINE. UNTIL
JUST LEAVE AT. AT THAT SET UP
FOR NOW- I'D LIKE TO MOVE UP
BRIEFLY TO THE- FIVE TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS
IN MANUFACTURING GRANTS THAT
ARE PROPOSED AND ASK- WATER
THOSE. ARE INTENDED TO BE USED
FOR AND HOW WILL THAT BE
STRUCTURED. HI GOOD MORNING
THIS IS CANON RUSSELL- DEPUTY
DIRECTOR KILLED TRANSPORTATION
BUTTON AFTER COMMISSIONING A-
SO I WANT TO OFF BY NOTING THAT
WE- APPROXIMATE THE FIVE NO
DOLLAR. AFTER GRANTS TO DATE
AFTER TWENTY SIX PROJECT WE
THINGS PRO. CHARGE ONE
TRANSPOWER HERE MOTORCYCLE. HI
MOM TRUCK THOSE. AND B. RECEIVE
NOT FUN EVEN THAN WHAT WE PUT
AN- END SO IF WERE TO PROCEED
THE FUND WHAT WE WOULD IT TO
THE THOUGHT THAT AND- SIMILAR
TO GRANDSON PROTECT BEGUN. WE
WOULDN'T- WE THE PUB YOUR
STAKEHOLDER OUT POP WORKSHOP.
AND ALSO BECAUSE- WITH PCS.
CAPE GOBIZ NOW TO THE IT FOR-
IT. WE BELIEVE BROAD- TO COVER
BOTH DAD. JUNE NINTH-
INFRASTRUCTURE RELATED PROJECTS.
WHAT ARE TO BE OPEN TO BOTH
INFRASTRUCTURE AND THE VEHICLES
AS WELL- AS WELL AS THE ICAL
COMPONENTS AND EVEN THE BATTERY
COMPONENT WHICH MAKE UP THE
VEHICLES. SO IT BE BROUGHT UP
IN THE HOLD BECAUSE OF SOME.
WELL I GUESS I GUESS WHAT I'M
GETTING AT IS- I. CERTAINLY
DON'T QUESTION THE IMPORTANCE
OF- INCENTIVIZING GAGA
MANUFACTURING. IN THE- IN IN IN
THE VEHICLE MARKET TO ITS 40%
OF THOUGHT REPRESENTS 40% OF
GREENHOUSE GAS AND IT'S
OBVIOUSLY A BIG SECTOR BUT- THE
OTHER. BIG EMISSIONS ELEPHANT
IN THE ROOM IF YOU WILL- IS-
THE BUILT ENVIRONMENT. AND IS
THERE A REASON WHY. WE WOULD
NOT USE MANUFACTURING GRANTS
LIKE THESE IN ORDER TO
INCENTIVIZE- A NEW BEST
PRACTICES AND STRATEGIES AND
FOR EXAMPLE THE HOUSING MARKET
LIKE WHY NOT- I USE THESE
FUNDS- TO- ENCOURAGE THE GROWTH
OF THE MODULAR HOUSING
INDUSTRY. HERE WHICH- WILL HAVE
THE CO BENEFITS I THANK OF
HELPING TO REDUCE THE COST OF
PRODUCTION OF HOUSING WHICH IS
ANOTHER CRITICAL. NEED AND IN
THE STATE. COOPER ADD FIND ON A
QUICK. YEAH THE- MAY REFER FOR
RESOURCES AGAIN TO COMMITTEE
EXISTING BILL PROGRAM AND A
SUITE OF ACTIVITIES TO DEAL
WITH EXTREME HEAT THAT- AND WE
BELIEVE THAT THERE ARE-
ACTIVITIES THAT ARE TARGETED
TOWARDS DEVELOPERS WITHIN THE
EXISTING BILL PROGRAM THEY DO
ADDRESS THAT. I BELIEVE THE
CHAIR IS RIGHT THAT- MORE COULD
BE DONE BONTA FOR MAIN GRANTS
WITHIN THE HOUSING BUT I NOT
PART OF THE NEIGHBORHOOD. HI TO
SUGGEST THAT WE ALL GET THOUGHT-
EXPANDING GOT WE USE THESE
GRANTS AND PERHAPS- X. THE- THE
AMOUNT OF MONEY THAT'S PUT A
THE- TO. THOSE OF. YES MISTER
SHALL SORRY I AND MY APOLOGIZE
FOR INTERRUPTING ROSS BROWN-
YEAH WAS ONE I. MAKE JUST A
QUICK ON THE DEATH NINETY FIVE
GRANT WHICH IS ALREADY
HIGHLIGHTED I THINK- JUST A
COUPLE OF TO KNOW ONE YOU SORT
OF THE- SPENDING SO FAR ON THIS
PRO. OVER A SEVERAL YEAR AS A
BEEN ABOUT FIFTY FIVE MILLION
AND SO TO. HE IT'S PRETTY OF
TWO HUNDRED FIFTY TODAY THAT OF.
RED APPLE AND I THINK YOU'RE OR-
WHETHER THIS IS THE PLACE TO BE
PUTTING OUR RESOURCES WHEN IT
COME TO VARIOUS. GOAL IS A
IMPORTANT ONE AND I THE ONE.
THING THAT WE DID WHAT TO NOTE
IS ON THE- THE- KICKED UP
PROGRAM WOULD HAVE SOME OF. PRO
APART CASE BUT ARE TARGETING OF
STEP MANY OF. SO THINK YOUR
QUESTIONS IMPORTANT AROUND.
HELLO THIS IS THE BEST- USE OF
THE SPA AND I WAS. WITH OTHER
PRO SO I PUBLIC FOR JUMPING AND
BUT WANTED. THOSE COME THANK
YOU KNOW NO PROBLEM AT ALL-
WE'RE NOT REALLY FOCUSED ON A
LARGE PART OF THE- EMISSIONS A
PROBLEM AND THEN TAKING INTO
CONSIDERATION THE CO BENEFITS-
THAT RELATE TO THE HOUSING
AFFORDABILITY CRISIS SO THANK
YOU FOR LISTENING AND- PERHAPS
SOMETHING GO FOR. FURTHER
DISCUSSION. ARE THERE ANY
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS MISTER
BENNETT. JUST TWO QUICK
COMMENTS ONE. I APPRECIATE-
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MULLINS-
LEADERSHIP ON- SOME LEGISLATION
RELATING TO THE TWENTY FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS IT'S GOING TO-
OPR. AND THAT IS- I THINK IT'S
A VERY IMPORTANT FOR US TO
ADDRESS CLIMATE CHANGE AND I
JUST WANTED TO ECHO THOSE THOSE
REMARKS AND- APPRECIATE HIS
LEADERSHIP ON THAT. I WOULD
ALSO LIKE TO JUST POINT OUT
THAT THE- IT WAS IT WAS
MENTIONED THE OTHER DAY THAT
THIS INCREASE IN BUDGET THAT WE
HAVE THE- SEVENTY PLUS BILLION
DOLLARS ALMOST RIVALS WHAT THE
TOTAL BUDGET WAS FOR CALIFORNIA
OF ABOUT TEN YEARS AGO AND SO.
I AM JUST PERSONALLY IMPRESSED
THAT THE ADMINISTRATION HAS
BEEN ABLE TO ALLOCATE TO SO
MANY DIFFERENT AREAS AS HIS AT
BAT DON'T FIND THAT MANY AREAS
WHERE I GO WHAT ABOUT THIS AND
THEN I LOOK AT THE BUDGET AND I
FIND ITSELF- MY COMPLIMENTS THE
ADMINISTRATION MOVING FAST I
REALIZED MOVING THIS FASTER
THERE'S STILL GOING TO BE
MOVING PARTS- THAT HOPEFULLY WE
CAN ALL- CAN. CAN ALL WORK ON
BUT MY COMPLIMENTS THANK YOU.
OUR I THANK YOU ALL FOR
QUESTION. WE WILL ON AND WE
WILL HAVE PUBLIC COMMENT BUT
IT'LL BE AT THE END OF ALL OF-
THE PRESENTATIONS. AT THE END
OF OUR HEARING. SO OUR NEXT
REPRESENTATION- RELATED TO
PROPOSALS ON ENVIRONMENTAL
PROTECTION NATURAL RESOURCES
AND SUSTAINABLE AGRICULTURE ALL
OF THE PANELISTS INTRODUCE
THEMSELVES TO SAVE A- FEW
SECONDS OF TIME SINCE WE ARE.
GOING A LITTLE SLOWER THAN
EXPECTED. GOOD MORNING OF MIKE
MCGINNIS WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE THE MAIN REASON
INCLUDES TWO HUNDRED AND FIFTY
SIX MILLION FOR OUTDOOR ACCESS
FOR ALL THESE INVESTMENTS
EXPANDED BAYERN MENTAL
EDUCATION ENHANCE SAFE RELIABLE
ACCESS TO STATE PARKS PUBLIC
LANDS COAST AND OTHER NATURAL
HISTORIC AND CULTURAL RESOURCES
INCREASED RECREATION
OPPORTUNITIES SIGNIFICANT
INVESTMENTS INCLUDE ONE HUNDRED
AND EIGHT MILLION FOR OUTDOOR
EDUCATION PROGRAMS TO EXPAND.
EXISTING K. THROUGH TWELVE
PROGRAMS WITHIN THE DEPARTMENT
OF PARKS AND RECREATION AND TO
SUPPORT OUTDOOR ENVIRONMENTAL
EDUCATION FOR UNDERSERVED YOU
STATEWIDE. MISSIONAL ONE
HUNDRED TWENTY FIVE MILLION IS
FOR STATE WHAT PART DEVELOPMENT
AND COMMUNITY REVITALIZATION
PROGRAM WAS PREVIOUSLY FUNDED
THROUGH PROPOSITIONS EIGHTY
FOUR AND SIXTY EIGHT TO FOR THE
CREATION OF NEW LOCAL PARKS AND
BEAUTIFICATION OF EXISTING
LOCAL PARKS. FOURTEEN MILLION
IS INCLUDED FOR THE EXPORT THE
COAST GRANT PROGRAM TO EXPAND
COASTAL ACCESS PROGRAMMING
STATEWIDE AND NINE POINT ONE
MILLION IS INCLUDED FOR
INNOVATIVE PILOT PROGRAMS TO
EXPAND PART PASSED DISTRIBUTION
FOR DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES.
A FOURTH GRADE EDUCATION
PROGRAM. AND PARTNERSHIP WITH
THE STATE LIBRARY. THE MAYOR
VISION ALSO INCLUDES FOR
HUNDRED AND MILLION TO ENHANCE
AND RESTORE THE STATE PARK
SYSTEM. AND INCLUDE TWO HUNDRED
AND SEVENTEEN MILLION FOR
WILDFIRE RESTORATION TO ADDRESS
THE DAMAGE CAUSED IN TWENTY
TWENTY THE TWENTY TWENTY
WILDFIRE SEASON FOR STATE
PARKS. ONE HUNDRED AND SIXTY
FIVE MILLION IS INCLUDED FOR
INVESTMENT IN DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE THIS IS IN ADDITION
TO THE TWENTY MILLION INCLUDED
IN THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET. AN
ADDITIONAL NINETY FIVE POINT
THREE MILLION IS PROPOSED FOR
TRANSFER TO THE NATURAL
RESOURCES AND PARKS
PRESERVATION FUND FOR THE
CALIFORNIA INDIAN HERITAGE
CENTER. THE TRANSFER RESTORES
THE ORIGINAL SET ASIDE FOR THE
PROJECT REHEARSING ONE TIME
GENERAL FUND SAVINGS
IMPLEMENTED IN THE TWENTY
TWENTY BUDGET. NEXT I'LL TURN
IT OVER TO MERION KAPLAN WHO
WILL BE SPEAKING TO THE BIO
DIVERSITY RESILIENCE PROPOSAL
FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND
WILDLIFE. GOOD MORNING. MERION
KAPLAN WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. THAT MAY REVISION
INCLUDES A BIO DIVERSITY
RESILIENCE PROPOSAL FOR THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF FISH
AND WILDLIFE THAT PROVIDES ONE
TIME FUNDING. OF SIXTY FOUR
POINT SIX MILLION. AT INCLUDING
FIFTY NINE POINT SIX MILLION
GENERAL FUND AND FIVE MILLION
CALIFORNIA ENVIRONMENTAL
LICENSE PLATE FUND IN FISCAL
YEAR TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO TO
SUPPORT THIRTY NINE PERMANENT
POSITIONS OVER FIVE YEARS TO
DIRECTLY ADDRESS SOME OF THE
LARGEST GAPS BETWEEN CURRENT
AND MISSION LEVELS OF SERVICE
IDENTIFIED BY THAT SERVICE
BASED BUDGETING PROCESS IT
PROVIDES FIFTY THREE POINT
EIGHT MILLION AND THIRTY ONE
POSITIONS OVER FIVE YEARS TO
SUPPORT ENDANGERED SPECIES
WITHIN CALIFORNIA ACT SEVEN
POINT FIVE MILLION AND EAT
POSITIONS OVER FIVE YEARS TO
ADDRESS MANAGEMENT. AND
OVERSIGHT OF THE DEPARTMENT'S
LANDS AND FACILITIES TO
CONSERVE NATIVE WILDLIFE
THREATENED AND ENDANGERED
SPECIES AND SENSITIVE HABITATS
AND TO PROVIDE FOR PUBLIC USE
AND ENJOYMENT IT INCLUDES THREE
MILLION FOR A PILOT
COMPENSATION PROGRAM FOR
LIVESTOCK PRODUCERS FOR THE
LOSS OF PRODUCTIVITY DUE TO
DEPREDATION EVENTS RESULTING
FROM THE RETURN OF THE GRAY
WOLF CALIFORNIA ACT AND
INCLUDES THREE HUNDRED AND
FIFTY THOUSAND TO DEVELOP A
FEASIBILITY STUDY FOR A STATE
OF THE ART WILDLIFE HEALTH
LABORATORY TO ADDRESS THE AND
CARE FOR WILDLIFE THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA. THE PROPOSAL BUILDS
ON ONE TIME INVESTMENT INCLUDED
IN THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET AND
OTHER MAY REVISION PROPOSALS
THAT INCLUDE ADDITIONAL FUNDING
FOR THE DEPARTMENT THAT ADDRESS
SOME OF THE LARGEST GAPS
IDENTIFIED BY THE SERVICE BASED
BUDGET PROCESS NEXT I WILL HAND
IT TO YOU AND REMARKS WITH THAT
OF FINANCE WHO DISCUSS
DEPARTMENT TOXIC SUBSTANCES
CONTROL INVESTMENTS AND THE
CIRCULAR ECONOMY PACKAGE. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING
ANGELA OF THE OF- FIRST THAT
APART OF TOXIC CONTROL ON- I
JUST TO POINT OUT THAT THE
MAYOR IS MAINTAIN THE GOVERNOR
BUDGET OF FINANCE REFORM TO
IMPROVE GOVERNANCE TRANSPARENCY
AND PROVIDE LONG TERM FISCAL
STABILITY FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF
TOXIC SUBSTANCES CONTROL THE
ADMINISTRATION CONTINUES TO
MEET WITH THE LEGISLATIVE STAFF
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE GROUPS
AND REGULATED INDUSTRY TO SEEK
FEEDBACK AND ADDRESS CONCERNS
WITH THE PROPOSAL AND WE'RE
CONFIDENT THAT THIS WILL BE
INCLUDED IN THE BOOK AND THE
BUDGET AND ACTED FOR- JUNE
FIFTEENTH. NOTHING ON THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET THE MAYOR
VISION INCLUDES AN ADDITIONAL
TWO HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS
GENERAL FUND FOR CONTAMINATED
SITE CLEAN UP FOR A TOTAL OF
FIVE HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS
OVER THREE YEARS I DON'T KNOW
THAT THIS FUNDING IS CONTINGENT
ON THE PASSAGE OF THE
GOVERNANCE OF THE SCORE FARM
PROPOSAL DESPITE THE MAYOR
VISION INCLUDES APPROXIMATELY
SIX MILLION GENERAL FUND FOR
THE AGENCY TO ADDRESS ISSUES
IDENTIFIED IN THEIR WORKLOAD
ANALYSES. SPECIFICALLY THIS
FUNDING WILL BE USED TO
IMPLEMENT THE VIOLATIONS
SCORING PROCEDURES REGULATION
AND MAINTAIN FEDERAL
AUTHORIZATION TO IMPLEMENT THE
RESOURCE CONSERVATION AND
RECOVERY ACT THE MAYOR VISION
ALSO INCLUDES TWO HUNDRED
NINETY ONE MILLION DOLLARS
GENERAL FUND TO CLEAN UP
APPROXIMATELY TWO THOUSAND
SEVEN HUNDRED PROPERTIES- THAT
ARE THE MOST POLLUTED
PROPERTIES SURROUNDING THE
FORMER EXCITED FACILITY IN
VERNON CALIFORNIA IF THIS
FUNDING IS APPROVED BY THE
LEGISLATURE THE STATE LAW
PROVIDED FIVE HUNDRED SEVENTY
THREE MILLION DOLLARS TO CLEAN
UP FIVE THOUSAND NINE HUNDRED
PROPERTIES. IN ADDITION THE
MAYOR VISION INCLUDES ONE
HUNDRED THIRTY TWO MILLION
GENERAL FUND ONE TIME TO
CONTINUE THE CLEAN UP OF THE
EXITE FACILITY ITSELF- AFTER
THE BANKRUPTCY OF EXCITED- THE
CORPORATION COMBINED WITH THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET THE MAYOR
VISION PROPOSES A TOTAL OF FOUR
HUNDRED FIFTY FOUR POINT FOUR
MILLION GENERAL FUND OVER THREE
YEARS TO FIND CLEAN UP
ACTIVITIES. RELATED TAX SIDE.
NOW ON TO THE CIRCULAR. OF THE
MAYOR WAS IN A ON THIRTY NINE
DOLLARS FUND TIME TO SUPPORT
THE DEVELOPER. THE OF EMPRESS.
REQUIRE TO PROCESS RESEARCH.
AND THEN YOU PRODUCTS FROM
RECYCLED. TO HELP CALIFORNIA
MEET SOLID WASTE DIVERSION
GOALS. INCLUDING THE 202575%
ORGANIC WASTE DIVERSION GOAL
AND SB THIRTEEN EIGHTY THREE.
SPECIFICALLY EIGHTY MILLION IS
PROPOSED FOR CAR CYCLE TO
INVESTING GRANDSON DUSTIN
ORGANIC WASTE INFRASTRUCTURE.
EDIBLE FOOD RECOVERY COMPOSTING
OPPORTUNITIES AND DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES AND FEASIBILITY
GRANTS FOR RECYCLING AND RE USE
TECHNOLOGY. ADDITIONALLY FIFTY
MILLION GENERAL FUND AS
PROPOSED BY THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE OF BUSINESS AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT. TO PROVIDE LOW
INTEREST LOAN TO DECLINE A
CATALYST FUND TO ATTRACT
RECYCLING AND REUSE BUSINESSES
TO CALIFORNIA. I CONCLUDE THAT
MY PORTION OF THE PRESENTATION-
AND I'LL PASS IT ON TO MY
COLLEAGUE ANDREW HALL WHO WILL
COVER THE SUSTAINABLE
AGRICULTURAL PACKAGE. GOOD
MORNING CHAIR NUMBERS THE
XANDER HALL FROM THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE AND I'LL BE
PROVIDING A BRIEF OVERVIEW OF
SUSTAINABLE AG. CALIFORNIA IS
THE LARGEST PRODUCER- LARGE
AGRICULTURAL PRODUCER IN THE
NATION AND GENERATING OVER
FIFTY BILLION DOLLARS IN
REVENUE IN TWENTY NINETEEN.
HOWEVER THE INDUSTRY IS
THREATENED BY THE EFFECTS OF
CLIMATE CHANGE INCLUDING
DECREASED WATER AVAILABILITY
INCREASED FLOODS ADDITIONAL
PASSED PRESSURES AND CHANGING
WEATHER. ADDITIONALLY THE
COVERT NINETEEN PANDEMIC HAS
CREATED CHALLENGES TO THE
AGRICULTURAL SECTOR WHICH IS
INCLUDED FOOD SUPPLY
DISRUPTIONS OVER THE PAST YEAR.
TO ADDRESS THESE CHALLENGES THE
MAYOR VERSION BUILDS ON THE TWO
HUNDRED EIGHTY FIVE MILLION
INCLUDED IN THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET. AND PROPOSES AN
ADDITIONAL SIX HUNDRED AND
FORTY ONE MILLION OVER TWO
YEARS. FOR A TOTAL OF NINE
HUNDRED TWENTY SIX MILLION
DOLLAR PACKAGE. AND STRATEGIC
INVESTMENTS SUPPORT
CALIFORNIA'S AGRICULTURAL
INDUSTRY. AS THAT ADDRESSES
THESE CONTINUE CHALLENGES.
WHILE ALSO ADVANCING THE
STATE'S CLIMATE RESILIENCE
OBJECTIVES. THE BUDGET THE
BUDGET INCLUDES SIXTY EIGHT
MILLION DOLLARS IN ONE TIME
GENERAL FUNDS FOR HEALTHY
RESILIENT AND EQUITABLE FOOD
SYSTEMS. THIS INCLUDES FUNDING
FOR PROGRAMS SUCH AS THAT
CALIFORNIA NUTRITION INCENTIVE
PROGRAM. SENIOR FARMERS MARKET
NUTRITION. BOTH THE
REFRIGERATION GRANTS. FARM TO
SCHOOL. AND FUNDING FOR A NEW
PROGRAM TO ASSIST URBAN FARMERS
THROUGH INVESTMENTS TRAINING
AND TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE. THIS
PACKAGE ALSO BUILDS ON
INVESTMENTS FOR CLIMATE SMART
AGRICULTURE FOR SUSTAINABILITY
AND RESILIENCY. AND INCLUDES
FIVE HUNDRED AND THIRTY TWO
MILLION DOLLARS IN ONE TIME
FUNDING. FROM THE GENERAL FUND
AND GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTION
FUND TO IMPROVE DROUGHT
RESILIENCY FUND ALTERNATIVES TO
AGRICULTURAL BURNING. INCREASED
POLLINATOR HABITAT ON WORKING
LANDS. AND SUPPORTS
CONSERVATION PLANNING. FURTHER
AS THE ECONOMY RECOVERS FROM
THE PANDEMIC IT IS IMPORTANT TO
SUPPORT EQUITABLE ECONOMIC
RECOVERY THAT INCLUDES RULE
COMMUNITIES SMALL AND
UNDERSERVED PRODUCERS AS WELL
AS FARMWORKERS. THIS PACKAGE
PROPOSES AN ADDITIONAL FORTY
TWO MILLION DOLLARS IN GENERAL
FUNDS TARGETED FOR NEW
INVESTMENTS TO SUPPORT ECONOMIC
RECOVERY. RESILIENCE AND HIGH
ROAD GROWTH THROUGH TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE TO UNDERSERVED
FARMERS. NEW FARMER TRAINING
AND MANAGER APPRENTICESHIPS AND
THE FRESNO MERCED FUTURE OF
FOOD INNOVATION INITIATIVE. AND
WITH THAT BRIEF SUMMARY OF OUR
KEY POLICY AREAS ARE AGENCY
SECRETARY IS DEPARTMENTS AND
FINANCER HERE TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS THAT YOU MIGHT HAVE.
THANK YOU LAMEA KICKOFF THE
QUESTION TO- BY ASKING A
QUESTION ABOUT- DFW THE-
STAFFING RESOURCES SO THAT OUR
PROPOSED OR NOT PERMANENT. OF
DAY AND IN FIVE YEARS SO ARE
YOU EXPECTING THE WORKLOAD. TO
DISAPPEAR IN FIVE YEARS OR- IS
THERE A PLAN FOR ME- MAKING GOT
THOSE ALLOCATIONS PERMANENT
SITE THANK MAKES. THE BEST
SENSE BUT I LIKE TO HEAR FROM
YOU ON THAT. THANK YOU I THANK
MERION KAPLAN WITH. THAT OF
FINANCE AND- I WOULD NOT THAT
ADAM. ALTHOUGH OUR BUDGET
FORECASTS DOES NOT OBJECT LARGE
STRUCTURAL DEFECTS THAT RISK TO
ECONOMIC FORECAST REMAINS AND
THESE RISKS TOGETHER WITH THE
ONE TIME NATURE OF PROJECTED
SURPLUS CONSTRAIN THE STATE'S
ABILITY TO EXPAND ONGOING
COMMITMENTS- OUR OUT YEAR
FORECASTS CURRENTLY ASSUMES
EXPENDITURES WILL BE AT PEACE
WITH REVENUE AND- THIS PROPOSAL
PROVIDES A SIGNIFICANT ONE TIME
INVESTMENT OVER FIVE YEARS TO
ENABLE THE DEPARTMENT TO.
ADVANCE EFFORTS TO ADDRESS THE
SPV CAPS WE DO ACKNOWLEDGE THAT
THERE WILL BE ONGOING
CONVERSATIONS REGARDING ASKING
FUND ARTS TO CONTINUE
ADDRESSING THESE GAPS- WE ARE
REQUESTING PERMANENT POSITIONS
GIVEN CHALLENGES DEPARTMENTS
CAN FACE WHEN HIRING COMMITTED
TERM STOCK FOR WORKLOADS
SPANNED SEVERAL YEARS THIS
FUNDING WILL HELP SUPPORT A
BACKLOG OF PENDING. THESE
APPLICATIONS AND FIVE YEAR I
STATUS REVIEW AND WILL HELP
ADDRESS SPECIFIC DEPARTMENT.
INFRASTRUCTURE NEEDS. I'M ALSO
IF IS NOT EXTRA. IN THE THERE
ARE OFF RAMPS SHIFT THE
POSITION TO PER OTHER WORKLOAD.
ALL RIGHT. QUESTION YES QUITE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BALLOT THANK
YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH- FIRST
I. I'D LIKE TO JUST MAKE THIS
COMMENT ABOUT SORT OF RECYCLING
OVERALL I BELIEVE WE'RE- IN THE
MIDST OF A SLOW ROLLING-
DISASTER IN TERMS OF RECYCLING
I APPRECIATE THE ENERGY BEING
PUT INTO THE FUNDING OF THE- OF
THE OF. THE ORGANICS- THAT WE
ARE IS A NEW EMPHASIS FOR US
BUT THE REGULAR OLD FASHIONED I
MIGHT SAY RECYCLING MARKET IS
REALLY STRUGGLING NOW AND IF WE
ARE GOING TO REALLY REACH OUR
CLIMATE CHANGE GOALS WE HAVE TO
BE ABLE TO CLOSE THE LOOP AND
WE HAVE TO BE ABLE TO- HAVE
RECYCLING BE- A SIGNIFICANT
PART OF THE SUCCESS OF
CALIFORNIA. SO I APPRECIATE
THAT THERE IS- FUNDING IN THERE
I PARTICULARLY- I APPRECIATE
THE FIFTY MILLION DOLLAR LOAN
FOR INNOVATIVE- IDEAS FIFTEEN
MILLION DOLLARS- YOU GRANTS OF
FOUR COMPANIES TO COME AND
DEVELOP NEW IDEAS AND LOCATE
HERE. BUT I BELIEVE WE REALLY
DO HAVE A RECYCLING CRISIS THAT
IS JUST IT'S NOT SEXY RIGHT
NOW- FOR- FROM A POLITICAL
STANDPOINT N TERMS OF
EVERYBODY ADDRESSING IT AND I
HOPE WE JUST KEEP THAT IN MIND
IT IS A- HUGE PART OF THE
SOLUTION THAT WE HAVE TO HAVE
OUT THERE- THE SECOND THING IS-
ALONG THE LINES OF. RECYCLING
THERE IS- I BELIEVE ONE POINT
THREE OR ONE POINT FOUR MILLION
FOR- DRAFT- GILL NET IT'S A
PROGRAM STEP BY UP OF SOME OF
THE PERMITS FOR THAT. AND THEN
WE ALSO HAVE- SOME COMPANIES
THAT ARE NOW ABLE TO RECYCLE
THOSE MILE LONG DRIFT NETS THAT
ARE OUT THERE. DOES DOES STAFF
KNOW WHAT THIS BOY TIME. WHAT
THE AMOUNT IS THAT WE NEED TO
BUY UP. OF THESE CREDITS ARE
THERE THESE PERMITS THAT ARE
OUT THERE. IN OTHER WORDS ONE
POINT THREE BILLION IS THAT.
WHAT PERCENTAGE OF THE PERMITS
WOULD THAT POTENTIALLY COVER TO
DOES ANYBODY KNOW THAT AT THIS
POINT TIME. YES IF I MIGHT YEAR.
YES OF COURSE. GOOD MORNING
CHUCK BONHAM DIRECTOR OF THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF FISH
AND WILDLIFE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WITH THE- PROPOSED REQUESTED
BONDS OF ONE POINT THREE
MILLION THE DEPARTMENT BELIEVES
THAT WILL ALLOW US TO. I UP THE
REMAINING TWENTY PARTICIPANTS
IN THE FISHERY. SO COMPLETE THE
EFFORT WELL THAT'S GREAT THAT
THAT IS THAT THAT'S A CELEBRATE
HURRY SURE OF THAT- IT WITH
THIS WITH THIS FUNDING AND
BEING ABLE TO DO THAT AND
PARTICULARLY WITH THE FACT THAT
WERE ABLE TO RECYCLE- THOSE
FISHNETS ALSO ON THE COAST NOW
WE HAVE COMPANIES THAT ARE THAT
ARE READY TO DO THAT SO
CONGRATULATIONS LET'S HOPE WE
CAN MAKE SURE THIS- THIS
FUNDING STAGE FORWARD AND-
PLEASE I'D LIKE TO BE INFORMED
IF THERE'S ANYTHING ELSE WE
NEED TO DO BECAUSE- TO NAIL
SOMETHING ALL THE WAY DOWN- AND
BRING THIS IS A- THESE MY ALONG
THE- YEAH. FISHNET OF PROGRAMS
AN EDWARD BE A VERY BETTER. AND
THEN- FINE IN A- IT'S BEEN A
LONG TIME FOR OF MIND TRY TO
MAKE WE HAVE OF OAK SPACE- FOR
THE PUBLIC TO BE ABLE TO
BENEFIT FROM AND WE HAVE
FUNDING IN THERE FOR STATE
PARKS DO WE SEE THIS FUNDING-
BE GOING BEYOND A STATE PARK
PURCHASES OF OPEN SPACE TO. TWO
OTHER PURCHASES. IT'S AN IN
HOUSE BUYING THE LAND TURNING
IT OVER TO A- OPEN SPACE
CONSERVATION ORGANIZATION
DISTRICT AND THEN RELIEVING THE
STATE OF THE ON GOING COST THIS
IN ANOTHER LEADER YEARS WE
ALWAYS HAVE THE CHALLENGE OF
TRYING TO MANAGE OF THE LAND IN
OUR STATE PARKS. SO IS THAT THE
POSSIBILITY WITH SOME OF THIS
FUNDING THANK YOU. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER SO MUCH FOR THAT
QUESTION- THIS IS A CHRISTIAN
BUDGET WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE I WOULD GLADLY LIKE TO
TURN OVER TO YOU- AT. THE
NATURAL RESOURCE AGENCY FOR
THAT QUESTION. THANK YOU YEAH I
THINK BRING SO MUCH ASSEMBLY WE
AGREE THAT. EXPANDING EQUITABLE
ACCESS INVOLVES ARE RESTORING
EXPANDING OUR STATE PARK SYSTEM
BUT ALSO SUPPORTING LOCAL AND
REGIONAL PARK SYSTEMS. AND SO
AS PART OF OUR PROPOSAL ARE WE
INCLUDE A HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS INTO AN EXISTING GRANT
PROGRAM THAT WAS ESTABLISHED BY
PROPOSITION SIXTY EIGHT. THAT
IS ACTUALLY A GRANT PROGRAM TO
LOCAL COMMUNITIES THAT FUNDS
THE ACQUISITION AND THE
REFURBISHMENT OF LOCAL PARKS
AND OPEN SPACE. WE THINK IT'S
REALLY CRITICAL AS WE'RE
ADDRESSING THIS INEQUITY AND
PROVIDING GREEN SPACE AND PARKS
POOR COMMUNITIES NOT JUST THINK
ABOUT OUR OWN STATE PARK SYSTEM
BUT TO SUPPORT LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS- WHO OFTEN NO BASS.
WHERE GOOD OPPORTUNITIES ARE TO
EXPAND PARKS IN THEIR
COMMUNITIES. THANK YOU THAT'S A
THAT'S THAT'S GOOD NEWS THAT'S
A HELPFUL PIECE OF INFORMATION
I DID NOT HAVE THANK YOU. I
WILL THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
THE PRESENTATION WILL MOVE ON
TO OUR NEXT PANEL. WHAT I'M
SORRY BUT NOT YET AGAIN
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BUT I DON'T
HAVE THE CLAIM HAVE ONE OTHER
THING IT SHOULD PARTIALLY TO
TRY TO HELP OF SAN MEMBER FOR
WHOSE NOT HERE BUT- DO WE HAVE
RECEIVED THREE- THAT ARE.
COMMUNICATION FROM THE MUSEUMS
AND MUSEUMS HAVE SUFFERED
TREMENDOUSLY DURING COVE AND-
WITH BEING SHUT DOWN AND
MUSEUMS BEING THE NATURE THAT
THEY ARE AND THEY CERTAINLY-
FALL UNDER OUR NATURAL RESOURCE
PROTECTION MANY OF OUR MUSEUM
CERTAINLY- SUPPORT THAT EFFORT.
AND SURE I JUST WANT TO RAISE
MY VOICE TO- SUPPORT THE IDEA
OF RECOGNIZING THAT MUSEUMS ARE
PROBABLY THE ONE AREA THAT'S
BEEN LEFT OUT- WE HAVE
BUSINESSES ASSISTANCE WE HAVE
WORKER ASSISTANCE BUT- MUSEUMS
HAVE BEEN LEFT OUT IN TERMS OF
TRYING TO HELP THEM ADJUST TO
THE COVERT IMPACT THAT THEY'VE
HAD. SO THERE IS- A REQUEST OUT
THERE FOR TWO HUNDRED FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS- TO THE
CALIFORNIA CULTURAL AND
HISTORICAL AND DALMATA- TO BE
DISTRIBUTED. SO THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. ALL RIGHT WITH THE WILL-
MOVE ON TO. OUR NEXT PANEL. ONE
TRANSPORTATION DIGITAL- THOSE
THESE ARE IDEA FOR AND BROUGH.
AND. TO WELL LAST A I THINK-
MISTER WELLS TO KICK THIS ONE
OFF. JERRY GREENER ARE I'M
STEVE WELLS I'M FROM THAT PART
OF FINE. AND I'M HERE TO THE
TRANSCRIPT PORTION OF THE MAIN
PROPOSAL- THE MEMORIES PROPOSAL.
BECAUSE THE SICK. INVESTMENT IN
NEW TRANSFER IF. AND MAKE. OF
EXISTING INFRASTRUCTURE CLOSING
OVER ELEVEN ALL OF STATE
INVESTMENT SYSTEM PROPELLED
EQUABLE RECOVERY AND POSITION
THE STAGE BRAZIL TO PURSUE
SIGNIFICANT POTENTIAL FEDERAL
INVESTMENTS THESE INVESTMENTS
WILL CREATE QUALITY JOBS
XCELERATED NEW TRANSPORTATION
OPTIONS SUPPORT CLEAN
TRANSPORTATION PROJECTS TO
COMPLETE TO ACHIEVE OUR CLIMATE
GOALS AND PROVIDE FOR A BETTER
BETTER CONNECTIVITY THROUGHOUT
THE STATE- CALTRANS CONTINUES.
PRESS THE BACKLOG OF ORDERS-
USING THE SUBSTANTIAL INCREASE
IN TRANSPORTATION REVENUES
PROVIDED THROUGHOUT THE ONE
ALTHOUGH REDUCE TRAVEL DURING
COVERT NINETEEN PANDEMIC HAS
MARGINALLY LOWER FORECASTED
FUEL EXCISE TAX REVENUE
CALTRANS HAVE BEEN ABLE TO TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF REDUCE TRAFFIC AND
UNANTICIPATED DID SAVINGS TO
ACCELERATE PROJECTS AND
CONTINUES TO MOVE FORWARD WITH
NUMEROUS TRANSPORTATION
PROJECTS USING AVAILABLE
FUNDING. CALIFORNIA. PRETTY
SIGNIFICANT INFORMATION
INFRASTRUCTURE IN JULY COULD
ALTER REALLY WANTED COULD
REPLACE ATLAS'S QUESTION I MEAN
THAT LAST SENTENCE PLEASE THERE
WAS A DISRUPTION IN THE MATRIX
OR SOMETHING- AND-
INDECIPHERABLE. I'M SORRY ABOUT
THAT ALL GET CALTRANS CONTINUES
TO ADDRESS THE BACKLOG OF
MAINTENANCE AND HIGHER REPAIRS
USING SINCE THE SUBSTANTIAL
INCREASE IN TRANSPORTATION
REVENUES PROVIDED THROUGH SB
ONE. ALTHOUGH REDUCE TRAVELED
FOR. NINETEEN PANDEMIC HAPPENED
PERSONALLY LOWERED FORECAST
WITH ACRONYMS CALTRANS BEEN
ABLE TO TAKE ADVANTAGE OF
REDUCE TRAFFIC I ANTICIPATED
BID SAVINGS TO ACCELERATE
PROJECTS AND CONTINUES TO MOVE
FORWARD WITH NUMEROUS
TRANSPORTATION PROJECTS USING
AVAILABLE FUNDING. CALIFORNIA
IS MAKING SIGNIFICANT
INVESTMENTS IN SUSTAINABLE
TRANSPORTATION INFRASTRUCTURE
IN JULY TWO THOUSAND TWENTY ONE
THE TRANSPORTATION AGENCY WILL
RELEASE THE CLIMATE AT. ACTION
PLAN FOR TRANSPORTATION OR CAP
DIE IN THIS PLANT IS A PRODUCT
OF A COLLABORATIVE VERTICALLY
THE ROBUST ENGAGEMENT PROCESS
AND IS MEANT TO BE A UNIVERSAL
FRAMEWORK FOR ALIGNING STATE
TRANSPORTATION INVESTMENTS WITH
CLIMATE GOALS AND PUBLIC HEALTH
CONCERNS WHILE PRIORITIZING
EQUITY. THE FRAMEWORK INCLUDES
GUIDING PRINCIPLES AND
STRATEGIES TO ADVANCE
CALIFORNIA TOWARDS A MORE
SUSTAINABLE TRANSPORTATION
SYSTEM- CHRIS PART OF OUR- ALL
THE PROPOSED INFRASTRUCTURE
ACTIVE INVESTORS HOLD ONE
BILLION DOLLARS TRANSPORTATION
SYSTEM OF PEOPLE ACTIVITIES THE
PACKAGE INCLUDES. ONE BILLION
DOLLARS IN GENERAL FUND TO
DELIVER CRITICAL- CRITICAL-
PROJECTS RELATED TO- THE TWENTY
TWENTY TWENTY EIGHT OLYMPIC
GAMES OF THESE PROJECTS WILL
ARE DESIGNED TO BE DELIVERED IN
TIME FOR THE TWENTY TWENTY
OLYMPIC GAMES AND WILL FLOW
THROUGH THE CURRENT TRANSIT AND
INTERCITY RAIL CAPITAL. BUT
THIS ONE REALLY DOES NOT FIND-
IS BUDGETED FOR HIGH PRIORITY
TRANSIT AND RAIL PROJECTS
STATEWIDE THAT IMPROVE
CONNECTIVITY BETWEEN STATE
REGIONAL AND LOCAL SERVICES
THESE FUNDS WILL ALSO THROW
FLOW THROUGH THE T. R. C. P.
PROGRAM. UGH THE PRODUCT PAT
THE PACKAGE ALSO INCLUDES FIVE
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS FOR
ACTIVE TRANSPORTATION PROJECTS
THAT INCREASED WALKING AND
BIKING INCREASED SAFETY AND
MOBILITY OF NON MOTORIZED
USERS. ADVANCE REGIONAL. HOUSE
GAS REDUCTION IN ITS PUBLIC
HEALTH IN ANY TYPE OF USER YOU
ACTUALLY THOSE IN DISADVANTAGED
OF THESE. THESE FUNDS WILL BE
USED ON PROJECTS THAT AREN'T
READY TO BE PROCESSED AND
RECEIVED HIGH SCORES-
ADDITIONALLY FIVE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS IN GENERAL
FUND- HAS BEEN A POOR- IS NOT
APPROPRIATED. TO SUPPORT HIGH
PRIORITY GRADE SEPARATIONS AND
GRADE CROSSING IMPROVEMENTS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE. B. THE
TRANSPORTATION PACKAGE FOUR
POINT TWO BILLION DAHLE
POSITION ONE A HIGH SPEED RAIL
CONSTRUCTION SLOWLY WALL GRANTS
AND WORK FOR SERVICE WORK
SERVICE BETWEEN MERCED AND
BAKERSFIELD AND ADVANCING
PLANNING A PROJECT DESIGNED FOR
THE ENTIRE PROJECT ALONG WITH
LEVERAGING OF THE STATE FOR
POTENTIAL FUTURE FEDERAL FUNDS-
THE PROPOSAL ALSO INCLUDES A
SUPPORT STAFF NECESSARY TO
ADDRESS THE EXPANDED PROJECT
WORKLOAD. THE PROPOSAL INCLUDES.
TWO BILLION DOLLARS FOR
STABILIZATION AND LOCAL ROADS
AND BRIDGES TWO BILLION DOLLARS
INCLUDES ONE POINT ONE BILLION
DOLLARS IN SPECIAL FUNDS AND-
JUST UNDER A BILLION DOLLARS IN
FEDERAL FUNDS. FORT ADVANCEMENT
OF PRIORITY STATE HIGHWAY
OPERATIONS AND PROTECTION
PROGRAM SHOP PROJECTS. INTO
REGIONAL TRANSPORTATION
IMPROVEMENT PROGRAM I CHIPPED
PROJECTS AND LOCAL ROAD AND
BRIDGE INVESTMENTS. ALSO
RESERVE MENTAL WELLNESS. I WORK
CONTINUING TO HAVE PART OF THAT
YOU NEED TO HAVE SOME PROBLEMS
WITH THE AUDIO AND IT'S BEEN
SUGGESTED THAT- AS MUCH AS WERE
ENJOYING THE VIDEO- THAT YOU
TURN OFF YOUR VIDEO AND GO TO
AUDIO ONLY WE THINK THAT MIGHT
HELP. ALL RIGHT NO PROBLEM. ONE
OF THOSE UP PANDEMIC THINGS.
YEAH WHAT WHAT WHAT WHAT CAN
YOU DO- SO WE. IT MUCH FOR THE
R. C. T. SPLIT EQUALLY BETWEEN
THE LOS ANGELES OLYMPICS-
PREPAREDNESS TIME AND PRIORITY
PROJECTS PROP THROUGHOUT THE
STATE. THIS FIVE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS IN GENERAL FUND
FOR ACTIVE TRANSPORTATION
PROJECTS FOR OUR SAFETY AND
MOBILITY OF NON MOTORIZED USERS
YEAH FIVE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS IN IN HIGH PARTY GRADE
SEPARATIONS AND GRADE CROSSING
IMPROVEMENTS- THERE'S ALSO FOUR
POINT TWO BILLION. BUT THE
PROBLEM IS MY- I COULD REAL
CONSTRUCTION IN THE CENTRAL
VALLEY IN ADVANCE SIR- VANCE
FOR SERVICE. WIENER SAID AND
BAKERSFIELD WHILE ALSO IF PLAN
ACROSS DESIGNED THE ENTIRE
PROJECT AND ALONG WITH A
LEVERAGING- THE STATE FOR
POTENTIAL FUTURE FEDERAL FUNDS.
THERE'S ALSO BILLION DOLLARS
FOR STATE HIGHWAY
REHABILITATION LOCAL ROADS AND
BRIDGES- THAT FUNDING INCLUDES
ONE POINT ONE BILLION AND
SPECIAL FUNDS AND JUST UNDER A
BILLION DAHLE. WHAT ABOUT FUNDS
TO SUPPORT OF THE STATE HIGHWAY
OPERATIONS AND PROTECTION
PROGRAM SHOP PROJECTS AND INTER
REGIONAL TRANSPORTATION
IMPROVEMENT PROGRAM PROJECTS
ALONG WITH LOCAL ROAD AND
BRIDGE INVESTMENTS. THERE'S
ALSO A FOUR HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS FOR ZERO MISSION RAIL
AND TRANSIT EQUIPMENT
PURCHASES. AND INFRASTRUCTURE-
THIS DESPITE THIS AMOUNT
INCLUDES A HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS IN GENERAL FUND- TWENTY
NINE DOLLARS AND A PUBLIC
TRANSIT TRANSPORTATION ACCOUNT.
AND ABOUT THIRTY DOLLARS A BILL
WILL BE USED TO DEMONSTRATE
PURCHASE OR LEASE STATE OF THE
ART CLEAN BUS AND RAIL
TECHNOLOGY FOR INFRASTRUCTURE
THAT ELIMINATES FALSE WILL FUEL
EMISSIONS AND INCREASES
INTERCITY RAIL AND INTERCITY
BUS FREQUENCIES. UP FINALLY THE
ELEVEN BILLION DOLLAR PROPOSAL
ALSO INCLUDES ONE POINT FOUR
BILLION FOR ZERO EMISSION BUSES
AND TRUCKS- THE BIRD DOES THESE
WILL DEMONSTRATE- IN PURCHASE
OF WHEAT AND LEASE. GREEN THE
TRUCKS ABOUT THESE FUNDS ARE
BUDGETED OUTSIDE OF THE
TRANSPORTATION BUDGET AND ARE
INCLUDED DESCRIBED HAVE BEEN
INCLUDED GOING TO THRIVE IN
EARLIER CLIMATE RESILIENCE-
RESILIENCE PROPOSALS- SECONDLY-
THE- THE WE HAVE PROPOSED- THE
NEW CLEAN CALIFORNIA
INITIATIVE- THE PROPOSAL
PROVIDES ONE POINT FIVE BILLION
DOLLARS GENERAL FUND FOR THREE
YEARS TO PROMOTE PARTNERSHIPS
WITH LOCAL GOVERNMENTS. IN A
STATE WIDE BEAUTIFICATION
EFFORT FUNDS WILL BE EXPENDED
TO CLEAN UP GARBAGE STATEWIDE
UNIFIED IN THE STATE'S
TRANSPORTATION NETWORK EDUCATE
THE PUBLIC ABOUT THE HARMS OF
LITTER AND CREATE LONG LASTING
LETTER TO CHART DETERRENCE
RESOURCES WILL BE A COMPUTER BY
THE STATE HIGHWAYS AND LOCAL
ROADS WITH REGIONAL ART AND
OTHER PROJECTS THAT SERVICE
COMMUNITY GATEWAYS- THE ONE
POINT FIVE BILLION IS IT IS
ROUGHLY BROKEN DOWN. FOUR
HUNDRED EIGHTEEN MILLION
DOLLARS FOR LITERA PAVEMENT ON
THE STATE HIGHWAY SYSTEM FOUR
HUNDRED THIRTY MILLION DOLLARS
FOR STATE BEAUTIFICATION
PROJECTS INCLUDING ART
INSTALLATIONS AND GREEN
BEAUTIFICATION PROJECTS FOUR
HUNDRED FORTY FOUR MILLION FOR
LITTER ABATEMENT UNIFICATION
PROPER FOR LOCAL LITTER
ABATEMENT UNIFICATION PROJECTS
INCLUDING PROJECTS ON LOCAL
STREETS TRIBAL LANDS PARKS
PATHWAYS AND. IT RAIL AND
TRANSIT CENTERS. THERE'S
SEVENTY FIVE DOLLARS. FOR ART
GRANTS ON THE STATE AND THE
LOCAL SYSTEMS AND THERE'S FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS FRONT ANTI
LITTER EDUCATION CAMPAIGN AND
OF SCHOOL BASED OUTREACH
PROGRAM. ADDITIONALLY THERE'S
EIGHTY THREE MILLION DOLLARS
FOR PROJECT DESIGN CONSTRUCTION
WILL SUPPORT AN ADMINISTRATOR.
AND WITH THAT I WILL TURN IT
OVER TO MY COLLEAGUE MATT SAITO
TO DISCUSS THE DIGITAL
TRANSPORTATION TRANSFORMATION
AT THE M. B. GOOD MORNING MR
CHAIRMAN VERS MATTHIESSEN DON'T
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AND-
IT'S- JUST WHAT THE- TO TALK
ABOUT. THE PERMANENT- GOALS.
THE DMV YOU CAN. AND TO INTO
ADDITIONAL ON OR- IN A SEPARATE
THE ENVY SERVICE TO EVERY.
ANYWHERE DANBY'S INCREASES
ONLINE PRESENCE BOB KARP I'M
MORE EFFICIENT IN THIS OFFICE
IS THE PROCESS IMPROVEMENTS AND
SUBSTANTIALLY REDUCE ITS CARBON
FOOTPRINT. ASIT PROCESSES
MILLIONS OF TRANSACTIONS EVERY
WEEK THERE ARE CHANNELS THAT
CONTINUES TO COLLECT REVENUE
FOR THE STATE REDUCES TRAVEL
MILES AND SAVES PAPER. EFFORTS
INCLUDE EXPANDED KIOSK
DEPLOYMENT LAUNCHING A
REDESIGNED RESPONSIVE WEBSITE
ADDING PEOPLE YOU TO ACCEPT
CREDIT CARDS OF FIELD OFFICES
AND IMPROVING EMPLOYEE TRAINING
TO FOCUS ON CUSTOMERS THERE MAY
REVISION. INCLUDES PROPOSALS TO
CONTINUE THESE IMPROVEMENT
EFFORTS AMID CHANGING
CONDITIONS INCLUDE LOOTING THE
ONGOING PANDEMIC IN CHANGING
FEDERAL REQUIREMENTS. THE MAYOR
IS AN AWESOME WHICH RESOURCES
FOR NEW MOBILE IDENTITY
PROGRAM- BUT TO START OFF- THE
MAYOR VISION PROPOSED TO SHIFT
FOUR HUNDRED NINE MILLION
DOLLARS IN COST FOR REAL ID
PROCESSING FROM THE MOTOR
VEHICLE ACCOUNT AS WAS PROPOSED
OF THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET TO THE
GENERAL FUND. EVEN THOUGH THE
FEDERAL REAL ID ENFORCEMENT
DATE WAS EXTENDED FROM THIS
OCTOBER TO MAY TWENTY TWENTY
THREE THE NUMBER OF RELIGIOSITY
IF HE'S EXPECTED TO HAVE TO
PROCESS HAS NOT CHANGED. AS
TRAVEL WAS RESTRICTED DURING
THE PANDEMIC APPLICATIONS FOR
REAL LADIES DROP BELOW PREVIOUS
ESTIMATES. HOWEVER AS THE
COUNTY REOPENS THE ENVY INTO
SPACE RETURN TO INCREASE RELY
THE WORKLOAD EPERIENCED PRIOR
TO THE PANDEMIC. DMV HAS
PROVIDED TEN POINT THREE
MILLION UNIQUE REALLY D. SO FAR
AND USED TO PROCESS SOME TWO
MILLION MORE. TO PROVIDE THE
ENVY WITH. THE FLEXIBILITY TO
ADJUST ITS WORK FORCE
EXPENDITURES. TO CHANGES IN THE
DEMAND OF REALIZE HE'S BEEN A
REVISION PROPOSES AN EXTENDED
ENCUMBRANCE LIQUIDATION PERIOD
FOUR YEARS. BOB WHAT KIND OF
GOES ALONG WITH THE REAL ID ACT
PASSED BY THE FEDS IS- A STATE
THE STATE PROGRAM WHICH
REQUIRES CALIFORNIA TO SEND.
ITS DRIVER DATA TO FEDERAL
DATABASE- AND ALSO RECEIVE DATA
FROM OTHER STATES SO THE MAY
REVISION INCLUDES THIRTY ONE
POINT TWO MILLION TO BEGIN AT
NINETY PROJECT TO. KIND OF
BUILD THIS DATABASE I WILL TALK.
TO THE FEDS AND- OUR COMPLIANCE
REQUIRED. BY OCTOBER TWENTY
TWENTY TWO. ADDITIONALLY-
DURING THE PANDEMIC CAN BE
TRANSFORMATIVE ITS SYSTEMS AND
PROCESSES INCLUDING
OPERATIONALIZE IN A VIRTUAL
FIELD OFFICE AND ENABLING NEW
AND EXPANDED ONLINE SERVICES
FOR WEB AND MOBILE DEVICES.
ALMOST 95% OF ALL DMV
TRANSACTIONS ARE NOW DONE
THROUGH ONE OF THE NBA'S
VIRTUAL CHANNELS RATHER THAN
FIELD OFFICE WHICH CREATES
ADDITIONAL CAPACITY AND REDUCE
WAIT TIME. IN THE FIELD OFFICES
TO HANDLE TRANSACTIONS THAT
REQUIRE AN IN PERSON VISIT LIKE
GETTING A REALIZE. TO
ACCELERATE THE MODERNIZATION
DMV THE MARRIAGE INCLUDES FIFTY
FOUR MILLION ONE TIME. NBA TO
BEGIN THE DIGITAL EXPERIENCE
PLATFORM PROJECT WHICH IS A
FIVE YEAR TOTAL THREE HUNDRED
AND EIGHT MILLION DOLLAR
COMPREHENSIVE REPLACEMENT OF
ALL OF THE EMPLOYEES. BY
NINETEEN SEVENTIES ERA IT
SYSTEMS- SO BE INSTEAD AND
LIMITATIONS OF ITS CURRENT
SYSTEM PRESENT OBSTACLES TO DM
VIS ABILITY TO SUPPORT CHANGING
BUSINESS NEEDS- AND ADAPTING
TO. CHANGES IN CUSTOMER DEMAND
OR ON CHANGES IN LAW- THAT ARE
REQUIRED OF US- THIS UPGRADE
WILL BRING DMV INTO THE TWENTY
FIRST CENTURY BY PROVIDING A
MODERN CUSTOMER EXPERIENCE THAT
WILL REDUCE FIELD OFFICE
OUTAGES ALLOW STREAMLINED
ONLINE SERVICES AND ENABLE DMV
TO ADAPT AND MORE NIMBLY. THAT
ONE EMBLEY TO FUTURE NEEDS- THE
PROJECT WILL COMMENCE IN
PHASES- THE FIRST PHASE WILL
COST APPROXIMATELY ONE FISCAL
YEAR THE SECOND WILL BEGIN IN
JANUARY- AND THEREFORE THE
MAYOR HASN'T PROPOSES FUNDING
FOR YOUR SELECTION WILL
COMPLETE TWO OF THE PHASES-
FURTHERMORE. THE HE CONTINUES
TO IMPROVE ITS SERVICES TO
BETTER MEET THE NEEDS OF ITS
CUSTOMERS THIS IS. AN
ACCOMPLISHMENT. IMPROVEMENT IN
THE BOX THROUGH WEB AND
RUSSIANS AND IMPROVE CUP
ALLERGY AND TELEPHONE INTERACT
PROVIDING THESE OPTIONS DANTE
IS BRINGING ITS SERVICES TO
REPORT OUR WHEN IT'S CONVENIENT
ANSWER WHETHER. EVER MEANS US
TO CONTINUE TO SPUR THE MAYOR
INCLUDES A HUNDRED I DON'T FUND
FOR A RANGE OF MODERNIZATION
EFFORTS THIS INCLUDES A MOBILE
DRIVER'S LICENSE PROGRAM. I
THINK TEN MILLION OF THE
HUNDRED AND THREE IS FOR THIS
PROGRAM- IT WILL ALLOW DMV TO.
SORT OF- BEGIN THE DEVELOPMENT
OF THE SOFTWARE THAT WILL ALLOW
YOU TO- PACKED. ON YOUR PHONE
USE IT JUST LIKE WHEN YOU'RE
JUST A LICENSE YOU'D STILL BE
REQUIRED TO HAVE YOUR PHYSICAL
LICENSE BUT THE ENVY WILL
CONTINUE TO- LOOK AT WAYS THAT
THE MOBILE ONE CAN BE USED FOR
VARIOUS GOVERNMENT SERVICES-
SEVERAL STATES HAVE IMPLEMENTED
THE SUCCESSFULLY SO FAR. AND WE-
I THINK HEALTH SHOULD BE ONE OF
THEM WELL- FURTHER IS FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS FOR ADDITIONAL
EXPLORATION PROJECTS THAT WILL
ENHANCE THE OVERALL CUSTOMER
EXPERIENCE OF THE DMV
CUSTOMERS- THESE INCLUDE SHIFT
TO AUTOMATION SUCH AS
CONTACTLESS RELATE THE
PROCESSING OPERATIONAL
EFFICIENCIES SISTERS
CONTROLLING AND PROCESS
ANALYTICS SOFTWARE TO HELP MAKE
ITS- STAFFING MORE EFFICIENT.
AND CONVERSION FROM PAPER TO
DIGITAL- THIRDLY APPROXIMATELY
FORTY MILLION DOLLARS FOR
OFFICE UPGRADES AND RE
CONFIGURATIONS THAT WILL RESULT
IN MORE EFFICIENT SPACE
ALLOCATION THAT WILL DRIVE
LOWER FACILITY NEEDS ONGOING-
IN BEES WILL. DRIVE DANTE INTO
A MODERN CUSTOMER ORIENTED
ORGANISATION AND TOWARD A
SMALLER OFFICE FOOTPRINT IN THE
FUTURE AND FINALLY THERE'S
THREE MILLION DOLLARS FOR A-
STATEWIDE TRACKING AND YOU
LEARNING- FOR ALL DMV EMPLOYEES
TO PROVIDE A CONSISTENT
EXPERIENCE. ACROSS ALL THE
OFFICES- AND FINALLY THERE IS
SOME. RESOURCES FOR THE HEAVY
DUTY VEHICLE INSPECTIONS AND
MAINTENANCE PROGRAM THAT'S SB
TWO TEN FOR THE- TRUCKS MARKING-
BMPS BUILDING AND I. T. SYSTEM
FOR THAT. THERE'S ALSO- A FIVE
POINT NINE MILLION FOR AB
EIGHTY FIVE WHICH REQUIRE DMV
TO BEGIN BECAUSE- ACTING SALES
ON HIS CARDIO. AND FINALLY
THERE IS NOT A COUPLE OUT
PROJECTS INCLUDING TEN MILLION
IN DEFERRED MAINTENANCE. WITH
THAT I WILL- TAKE ANY QUESTIONS
AND HANDED OVER TO MY TEAM BE
CALLING FROM READY TO. THANK
YOU. I'M SORRY TERM LOAN THIS
IS STEVE GOING FROM THE PART OF
WHAT IT WAS I WAS ASSUMING THAT
YOU HAVE A QUESTION I FEAR WITH
MY STAFF TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MIGHT HAVE- I DO
HAVE QUESTIONS BUT I THOUGHT-
WE HAD ONE MORE PRESENTATION.
THAT WE HAVE ALL THAT FOR THAT
ONE PROGRAM SHOULD BE ON ON-
BROADBAND. THAT'S CORRECT AYMAN
NOW BEEN DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
I'M HAPPY TO BRING TO YOU
DEMONSTRATION PROPOSAL BY TO
DEVELOP EQUITABLE ACCESS TO
HIGH SPEED BROADBAND. THE
GOVERNOR'S GOAL IS TO EXPAND
ACCESS AND IN DOING SO ADDRESS
THE STRUCTURAL ISSUES
AFFORDABILITY IN CALIFORNIA WE
HAVE BOTH AN ACCESS AND
AFFORDABILITY ISSUE AND IF
WE'RE GOING TO OVERCOME THE
STRUCTURAL CHANGES. OF A
CHEATING BROADBAND FOR ALL WE
MUST INVEST IN THE MIDDLE MILE
AND MAKE THAT OPEN ACCESS FOR
ENTITIES LIKE LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
TRIBES NONPROFITS. WHAT THE
PANDEMIC HAS MADE CLEAR IS FAST
AND RELIABLE AND AFFORDABLE
BROADBAND ACCESS TO ALL
CALIFORNIANS IS CRITICAL TO
SUPPORT THE LOCAL LEARNING HOW
IT WORKS TELEHEALTH. IS A
CORNERSTONE ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT. DESPITE THIS
LONGSTANDING INEQUITIES IN
INTERNET ACCESS AFFORDABILITY
AND QUALITY PROCESS. THE
PROPOSAL BEFORE YOU WOULD HELP
COMMUNITIES ACROSS THE STATE
TRACK ECONOMIC RECOVERY AND
DEVELOPMENT BY FUNDING STOPS
FOR BROADBAND INFRASTRUCTURE
PROJECTS FOR HIGH SPEED
BROADBAND IS ABSENT OR
INSUFFICIENT. INCREASING
ECONOMIC EXPANSION AND ENABLING
DISTANCE LEARNING TELEWORK AND
TELEMEDICINE. SPECIFICALLY
RELIABLE FAST NON
DISCRIMINATORY ACCESS ENABLES
CONNECTION TO COMMUNITIES WHERE
BEARS TO CONNECTIVE ITTY HAVE
SEVERAL LAYERS THE PRIMARY ONE
BEING A LACK OF MIDDLE MILE
PREVENTING A LAST MILE PROVIDER
CONSERVING THE COMMUNITY. OFTEN
THIS IS BECAUSE THE MIDDLE
MILEAGES OR NONEXISTENT- TO
EXPENSIVE TO BUILD O TO LEASE.
AT A HIGH LEVEL BROADBAND
NETWORKS ARE GROUPED INTO THREE
CATEGORIES BACKGROUND OR LONG
HAUL WHICH ARE THE
TRANSCONTINENTAL CABLES THAT
RUN ALONG EACH STATE HIGHWAYS
AND ROADWAYS MIDDLE MILE WHICH
IS THE HIGH CAPACITY
INFRASTRUCTURE IN CONNECTION
BETWEEN COMMUNITIES. AT CONNECT.
THESE NOTES TO THE WIDER
INTERNET. Là MILE WHICH AT THE
CABLES AND OR TENNIS HOUSE AND
BUILD TO CALL MIDDLE THOUGH.
NEARLY ALL MIDDLE MILE NETWORK
TO OPERATION TODAY ARE SINGLE
PAYER. MEANING THERE AN OP BY.
RIDER THE LACK OF AVAILABLE
MIDDLE MILE BROADBAND
INFRASTRUCTURE IS A MAJOR ISSUE
IN CONNECTING CALIFORNIA'S
UNSERVED AND UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES. OPEN ACCESS MIDDLE
MILE CAN PROVIDE AFFORDABLE
SERVICE FOR ANCHOR INSTITUTIONS
AND REDUCE THE PRICE OF
BROADBAND INTERNET SERVICE BY
ENABLING COMPETITIVE LAST MILE
NETWORKS. LAST MILE
INFRASTRUCTURE RELIES ON MIDDLE
MILE TO PROVIDE SERVICE TO
RESIDENTS LARGE AND SMALL
BUSINESSES SCHOOLS GOVERNMENT
OFFICES PUBLIC SAFETY AGENCIES
AND LIBRARIES. AND WHY IS THIS
IMPORTANT. HAS APPROXIMATELY
83% OF CALIFORNIANS ARE USING
BROADBAND AT ALL SPEEDS BUT
ONLY JUST OVER HALF OF
CALIFORNIANS 52% ARE USING
BROADBAND AND HIGH A HUNDRED
MEGABITS PER SECOND BENCHMARK.
SERVICE BELOW A HUNDRED
MEGABITS PER SECOND ISN'T
ENOUGH FOR HOUSEHOLDS THAT ARE
JUGGLING DEMANDS OF DISTANCE
LEARNING TELEWORK ONLINE HEALTH
CARE AS WELL AS ACCESSING
GOVERNMENT SERVICES. RURAL
COMMUNITIES ARE HIT THE HARDEST
HIT WITH 51% OF RURAL
HOUSEHOLDS WITHOUT ACCESS TO
BROADBAND SERVICE THAT A
HUNDRED. AND ALMOST HALF OF
HOUSEHOLDS WITHOUT ACCESS AND
SERVICE OF A HUNDRED DOWN THREE
HUNDRED THOUSAND PLUS ARE
LOCATED ALSO IN ARABIC AREAS
AND TRIBAL LANDS ARE ALSO
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTED
WITH 28% OF HOMES LACK OF THIS.
ESSENTIAL BROADBAND
INFRASTRUCTURE. THIS LARGEST P.
OFF REDUCED PRO WILL INCOME HOW.
THAT SUBSCRIBE SHIP WITH A SLIM
WITH ALL FORMED AT THAT SIX.
THESE PER ARE NOT MEETING THE
NEEDS OF ESTIMATED TWO POINT
THREE MILLION HOUSEHOLDS
FALLING BELOW CALIFORNIA'S
POVERTY LEVEL. CALIFORNIANS
ALADDIN SUBSIDIES TO PRIVATE
COMPANIES TO BRING BROADBAND
SERVICE TO ANSWER COMMUNITIES
ABOUT COURAGE IS NO LONGER
EFFECTIVE COMMUNITIES THAT ARE
STOLEN CERVANTES CHRISTIAN
POPULATION DENSITY. HOUSEHOLD
INCOME OR TOO EXPENSIVE FOR
SERVICE BRIGHTEST REACH TO BE
PROFITABLE. SO INACTIVE NEVER
CAN PUBLIC SENT SECTOR
EXISTENCE THESE IMPORTANT HIGH
COST COMMUNITIES ARE UNABLE TO
GET CONNECTED TO THE INTERNET.
AND AT THE SAME TIME PARTS OF
URBAN COMMUNITIES LACK ACCESS
TO HIGH QUALITY BROADBAND AND
WHEN THEY ARE LUCKY ENOUGH TO
HAVE BROADBAND THEY ONLY HAVE
ONE CHOICE. THE ME REVISION
PROPOSALS AIM TO DO THE
FOLLOWING ALLOCATE FOUR MILLION
DOLLARS CONTRACT AND STATE
OWNED OPEN ACCESS MIDDLE MILE
NETWORK USING A COMBINATION OF
STATE LOCAL AND I REALLY AREN'T
ANY RIGHTS OF WAY. THE MIDDLE
MILE NETWORK WILL EXPAND ACCESS
AND CAPACITY FOR NEW AND
EXISTING LAST MILE NETWORKS AND
PROVIDERS ACROSS THE STATE NO
BRINGING NEW PROVIDERS AND
OFTEN MORE OFTEN OFFER MORE
OPTIONS TO ALL. CUSTOMERS AND
LOWER SERVICE COSTS. IT MAY
REGIONAL FROM ADDITIONAL LAST
MY FUNDING CONNECT THE MIDDLE
AND THE NUMBER OF HASSLE THAT
ACTS TO BROAD. WILL SERVE LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS ABILITY TO RAISE
MONEY TO DEPLOY PUBLICLY ON
LAST MILE NETWORKS WITH PUBLIC
PRIVATE PARTNERSHIPS. WILL
PROVIDE TECHNICAL SUPPORT TO
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO GET THEIR
COMMUNITIES CONNECTED. WE'LL
MAKE SIGNIFICANT ONE TIME
FUNDING AVAILABLE TO EXPEDIT
UPGRADES IN AREAS SERVED BY
SMALL INDEPENDENT TELEPHONE
CORPORATION CERVANTES CARRIES A
LAST RESORT. THESE INVESTMENTS
WILL BE FOUNDATIONAL AND WE
WANT USES INVESTMENTS ONCE
FILLED BUILD FOR THE
FUTURE. AND OPEN ACCESS MIDDLE
MILE NETWORK WILL PROVIDE THE
BACKGROUND LAST MONTH THE
BRIGHTEST SECOND. LARGE AND
SMALL BUSINESSES SCHOOLS
GOVERNMENT OFFICES PUBLIC
SAFETY AGENCIES AND LIBRARIES.
THANK YOU AGAIN FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT THIS
PROPOSAL AND WITH ME TODAY
REPRESENTATIVES FROM THE PUBLIC
UTILITIES COMMISSIONS AND
REBATES FROM THE PUBLIC
UTILITIES COMMISSION WE'RE
AVAILABLE TO ANSWER QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU- DOES- LA- HAVE
ANYTHING TO ADD ON THIS A- VERY
COMPLEX- WELL ABOVE FOR A
PROPOSAL SENATOR. A COVERING A
GOOD DEAL OF GROUND. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR BRIAN BROWN WHAT-
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE I
THINK GIVEN HOW ABLY PLANTS
WITH ABLE TO COVER THE DETAILS
OF THE VARIOUS PROPOSAL I THINK
I'LL KEEP MY COMMENTS. ARE
PRETTY HIGH LEVEL AND- REALLY
JUST MAKE TWO POINT ONE ANDOVERALL A POINT ON THE
ARCHITECTURE OF TRANSPORTATION
FUNDING IN THE NAY REVISED AND
THEN I'LL JUST TOUCH ON A FEW
OF THE KEY PROPOSALS AND OUR
INITIAL COMMENTS- SO WITH
RESPECT TO THE OVERALL FUNDING
FOR TRANSPORTATION JUST WANT TO
NOTE. FOR CONTEXT THAT THE
VISION INCLUDES A TEN BILLION
DOLLAR INCREASE IN TOTAL
FUNDING FOR TRANSPORTATION
AGENCIES RELATIVE TO THE
JANUARY PROPOSAL SO THIS IS A
SUBSTANTIAL INCREASE OVER 40%
RELATIVE TO JANUARY. OF THAT
TOTAL FOUR BILLION IS FROM THE
GENERAL FUND- FOR BILLION IN
BOND AT THE WORDY AND A BILLION
DOLLARS FROM FEDERAL FUNDS SO
IT'S JUST A LOT OF ADDITIONAL
FUNDING TO DO A LOT OF NEW
ACTIVITIES- SO WITH RESPECT TO
A FEW OF THE MOST SIGNIFICANT
PROPOSALS AND IT'S BEEN A
REVISION A FEW BECAUSE COMMENT.
FIRST ON THE TWO POINT NINE
BILLION DOLLARS TRANSPORTATION
INFRASTRUCTURE PACKAGE DO YOU
WANT TO JUST HAS A VERY LARGE
PACKAGE THERE ARE A LOT OF
COMPONENT. TO THAT IS-
DEPARTMENT FINANCE TO DESCRIBE-
GENERALLY WE THINK THE KEY
QUESTIONS IN REVIEWING THIS
PACKAGE- IT JUST FOR THE
LEGISLATURE TO DETERMINE
WHETHER THE INCREASE FUNDING
SUCH AS THE FIVE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS FOR ACTIVE
TRANSPORTATION AND THE ONE
BILLION DOLLARS GENERAL FUND
FOR RAIL PROJECTS. IN LOS
ANGELES WHAT IT DOES ALIGN WITH
YOUR BROADER BUDGETARY
PRIORITIES- WITH RESPECT TO THE
CLEAN CALIFORNIA PROGRM ONE
POINT FIVE BILLION OVER THREE
YEARS IN THE GENERAL FUND- TO
DO BEAUTIFICATION AND ART
PROJECTS ON- STATE HIGHWAYS AND
LOCAL STREETS AND ROADS AGAIN
IT'S A VERY SIMILAR ISSUE JUST
REALLY QUESTIONED WHETHER.
THOSE ARE PRIORITIES FOR THE
LEGISLATURE OR WHETHER YOU HAVE
OTHER HIGHER GENERAL FUND
PRIORITIES EITHER IN THE
TRANSPORTATION SECTOR- FOR
OTHER ACTIVITIES SUCH AS
MAINTENANCE OR- I AM ADAPTATION
PROJECT OR OTHER THINGS. OR YOU
IN OTHER PARTS OF. THE BUDGET.
TURNING TO THE DEAL PRO. THAT
HEARD ABOUT. REALLY TWO POINTS
TO MAKE ONE IS THERE ARE A
COUPLE OF THE FOR. THAT AS RELY.
AND IF YOU LOOK CLOUD THAT
THINK ARE REALLY REASONABLE TO
ADDRESS. THE- NEED TO SIR IN
THE BETTER MEET WORKLOAD DEMAND
BUT WE HAVE SOME TECH
RECOMMENDATION THAT WILL GO
INTO THE MID IN THE MOMENT BUT
WE I HAVE MY COLLEAGUES HERE
CONTAINS QUESTIONS BUT WE DO
THINK THERE COUPLE TACKLE
TECHNICAL RECOMMENDATIONS YOU
COULD ADOPT. TO INCREASE SOME
OPPORTUNITIES FOR LEGISLATIVE
OVERSIGHT ACCOUNTABILITY ON
THOSE ON THOSE PROGRAMS- AND
THEN ALSO WITH RESPECT TO THE-
DMV'S DIGITAL ACCELERATION
PROPOSAL WE DO HAVE SOME
CONCERNS THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION BUDGET REQUESTED
NOT INCLUDE- ENOUGH- SUFFICIENT
INFORMATION OR JUSTIFICATION
FOR. WHAT TYPES OF ACTIVITIES
BE UNDERTAKEN OR JUSTIFICATION
FOR THE AMOUNT OF FUNDING
REQUESTED TO SUPPORT THOSE
ACTIVITIES WILL CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH ADMINISTRATION TO ASK
THEM QUESTIONS AND GET MORE
INFORMATION THEY'VE THEY'VE
BEEN PROVIDING THAT WILL
CONTINUE TO REVIEW THAT AND
OBVIOUSLY WE'LL SHARE IT WITH
YOUR STAFF- WE DO THINK THOUGH
THAT THESE ARE PROBABLY. LESS
IMMEDIATE PRIORITY SO IF IN THE
COURSE OF THE CANAL IN JUNE
FIFTEENTH IF YOU DON'T FEEL
LIKE YOU HAVE SUFFICIENT
INFORMATION FROM. THE
DEPARTMENT WE DO THINK THIS IS
ONE THAT PROBABLY COULD BE
REJECTED AND IN THIS CASE YOU
CAN COME BACK NEXT YEAR AND
NEXT YEAR'S BUDGET CYCLE WITH A
NEW PROPOSAL AND MORE
INFORMATION- TURNING TO HIGH
SPEED RAIL THIS THE FOUR
BILLION DOLLARS IN FEDERAL
FUNDADOR DE. I'M SORRY AND-
PROPOSITION WHEN THEY BONTA
FORTY- YOU MAY RECALL THAT OUR
OFFICE- RELEASED A REPORT
REVIEWING THE- AUTHORITIES
BUSINESS PLAN. ABOUT A MONTH
AND A HALF AGO- OUR COMMENTS
REMAIN LARGELY THE SAME WHICH
IS AS SOME DECISIONS THAT YOU
HAVE NOW- THIS IS SORT OF AN
IMPORTANT DECISION POINT FOR
YOU RIGHT NOW- WITH RESPECT TO
THE- THE PLAN- IN THE APPROACH
THAT THE AUTHORITY IS TAKING.
AND ULTIMATELY WHETHER TO
APPROVE ALL OR SOME OF THIS-
BONTA FORTY IN THIS BUDGET
CYCLE REALLY- IN LARGE PART
DEPEND ON THAT LEGISLATORS
COMMITMENT TO COMPLETING
ELECTRIFIED. MERCED TO
BAKERSFIELD SEGMENT AS PER. IN
THE LAST TURNING TO THE PROPOSE
THAT YOU HEARD ABOUT- WE'RE
JUST BE TO DIG INTO THIS- VERY
LARGE PROPOSED THERE'S STILL A
OF HIM FOR WE'RE TRYING TO
TOGETHER OF AND- QUESTION OR
POINTS TO MAKE ONE WE'RE
LOOKING AT THE QUESTION OF- WHY
THE MINISTRATION OF PROPOSING
TO COMMIT GENERAL FUND IN
TWENTY TWENTY TO TWENTY THREE-
THIS PUTTING IN PART BECAUSE IF
THEY'RE IN THERE COULD
POTENTIALLY BE ADDITIONAL
FEDERAL FUNDS AVAILABLE- NEXT
THE NEXT YEAR- THAT MIGHT
NEGATE THE NEED FOR ADDITIONAL
GENERAL FUND. A SECOND- WE ARE-
WE DO HAVE QUESTIONS ABOUT THE
COST ESTIMATES FOR THIS
PROPOSAL WE NOTE THAT THERE
SIGNIFICANTLY HIGHER THAN WHAT
WAS IDENTIFIED IN THE TWENTY
TWENTY BROADBAND ACTION PLAN SO
WE'RE LOOKING AT THAT QUESTION
IN IN THIRD- JUST KNOW THAT IT-
WELL WE THINK THAT THERE IS A
REASON TO FOCUS ON
INFRASTRUCTURE AND THE
ADMINISTRATION AND DOING- WE DO
KNOW THAT THERE IS NOT
ATTENTION PAID IN THE PROPOSAL
TO OTHER ISSUES SUCH AS
AFFORDABILITY INTO THEIR THEIR-
I THINK THAT WE THINK ARE
IMPORTANT FOR THE LEGISLATURE.
TO CONSIDER SO I WILL I WILL
STOP THEIR JUST NOT THAT I HAVE
MY COLLEAGUES ON THE LINE TO
YOU MAY BE ABLE TO ANSWER SOME
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS IF YOU
WANT TO GET. INTO SOME OF THE
DETAILS THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
WE STILL HAVE THE PUBLIC TO
HEAR AND- IT'LL TAKE SOME FOR
QUESTIONS NOW BUT- OR RUNNING
SHORT ON TIME- LET'S SET THAT
THIS IS JUST SO MUCH. OF TO- I
TRY IT IN A GREAT TO AND ASK
QUESTIONS ABOUT A RELATIVELY
SHORT PERIOD OF TIME BUT LET'S-
LET'S DO OUR BEST AND I'D LIKE
TO START WITH THE BROADBAND
PROPOSAL- I APPRECIATE- THAT
THERE IS A LITTLE MORE DETAIL
ON HOW- WE'RE GOING TO GET FROM
THE MIDDLE MILE TO THE TO THE
LAST MILE- BUT- CAN SOMEBODY-
IDENTIFY WHERE THAT INFORMATION
IS AVAILABLE. I HEARD KIND OF
AN OUTLINE OF- OF WHAT'S
INTENDED. BUT THAT'S NOT AS FAR
AS I KNOW THAT'S IN THE- MAY
REVISED DOCUMENT. THAT'S
CORRECT THE FIND AT THIS IS A
MAN OPENED- THE FINANCE LETTER
RELEASED THE BROADBAND PROPOSAL
WITH THE ASSOCIATED CONTROL
SECTION THAT. HOUSES THE
ADMINISTRATION'S- TOTAL BUDGET
PROPOSAL BACK V. EIGHT
BROADBAND B. C. P. AND G. L.
ARE FORTHCOMING- EXPECTED TO BE
RELEASED SHORTLY- HOW SHORTLY
WE DON'T HAVE A HECK OF A LOT
OF TIME EVERYTHING IS SHORTLEAF.
THE BUDGET IS OUR FINAL IS
SHORTLY SO CAN YOU. BE A LITTLE
MORE SPECIFIC. I'M I AM TO BACK
TO WITH THIS BUT TIME BY RIGHT
NOW I DON'T KNOW THAT. OKAY-
LET'S- MOVE TO- DEPARTMENT OF
MOTOR VEHICLES- I WAS- AND I
THINK DIRECTOR GARDEN- CAR HOPE
DIRECTOR GORDON IS SAID- STILL
HERE TO ANSWER THESE QUESTIONS-
I WAS TAKEN ABACK. BY THE
REFERENCE TO NINETEEN SEVENTIES
ERA IT- AND- THAT SOUNDS LIKE
SOMETHING THAT- WE NEED TO
ADDRESS- WITH- WITH- WITH ALL
DUE. SPEED IF AT ALL POSSIBLE
AND TO US- SO I ASSUME AS PART
OF THIS MODERNIZATION- THAT'S
BEING DISCUSSED THE UPGRADING
OF THAT I. T. WILL TAKE PLACE
HOW LONG WILL THAT TO. A WILL
THAT TAKE. SENATE TEST GORDON
MOTOR VEHICLES THANK YOU FOR
HAVING ME WE DO HAVE THAT
SYSTEM THAT HAVE BEEN IN PLACE
SINCE THE LATE SIXTIES AND THE
EARLY SEVENTIES IN THE ASSEMBLY
LANGUAGE CALLING WHICH IS JUST
TO. KEEP YOU FOR A SECOND AND
IT'S HARD TO FIND CAL TO BE
ABLE TO SUPPORT THOSE SARPI
RIGHT NOW WITH THE DIGITAL
TRANSFORMATION PLATFORM SO
CALLED THE X. P. IS OVER THE
NEXT THREE TO FIVE YEARS IS TO
ROLL OUT IN THREE MAJOR PHASES.
IS NOT TO MENTION ARE FINANCE
STARTING WITH IRAQ LICENSE.
MOVING INTO OUR VIEW
REGISTRATION WHICH IS THE SURE
THE REVENUE FOR STATE ABOUT TO
SEVEN BILLION DOLLAR COLLECTED.
AND THEN FIND OUT. INDIAN THAT
AT THE DRY LICENSE AND I THINK
IN THE END I IF YOU AT IT FROM
WE STARTED TO THE- IT'S
PROBABLY WOULD BE VERY CLOSE TO
FIVE YEARS TRANSFER. ALL OF
THESE SYSTEMS- MAY PROGRAM.
THAT WERE BUILT USING A AND
DOWN IN YOUR YOUR AREA WHERE
THEY GREW BUILT OVER DIFFERENT.
WHAT TO NOW. STREAMLINED THIS
PROCESS RHIANNA THOSE AND GET
THEM ON A COMMON SO THE LOW FOR
AND WERE TO GET UP A FIVE YEAR
JOURNEY IN THE. THAT SOUNDS
LIKE A LONG TIME THE AGE OF- OF
THE AND- I'M GLAD WILL BE A TO
WHERE ON IT AND- WE WE'VE SEEN
A TO WERE DECAYING AND FOR HAS
LED TO PROBLEM IN OUR IN OUR
WITH OUR ACOSTA AROUND THE
STATE AND SO I WOULD CAN THIS A
CRITICAL ACT- GOD. A DIRECTOR
YOU AND I HAVE US. ABOUT MODERN-
THE BUILT ENVIRONMENT TO THE
BUILT STRUCTURES UGH- THAT THE
DMV HAS AROUND THE STATE- AND-
I'M- FOR PURPOSES OF THE
BUDGET- WHAT. HELLO JUST TOOK
TO BRIEFLY REVIEW- YOU HAVE
SPOKEN ABOUT THE FACT THAT- OF
SOME OF YOUR FACILITIES- WERE
ALSO I THINK BUILT IN THE
SEVENTIES AND DRUG- THE NEEDS
HAVE CHANGED SINCE THEN AND
YOU'RE ACTUALLY TALKING UGH- IN
THESE BCPS ABOUT- UPGRADING AND
CHANGING THE WAY WHICH YOU
INTERACT WITH- YOUR CUSTOMER
BASE AND THAT UNDOUBTEDLY WILL
CHANGE THE- OF THE NEEDS- AND
HOPEFULLY THE SIZE OF THE
FACILITIES- THAT YOU HAVE. AND
I PROPOSED TO YOU THAT- WE
SHOULD BE LOOKING AT SOME OF
THESE OF FACILITIES WHICH ARE
LOCATED TYPICALLY ARE NOT LARGE
BLACKTOP BUT- OF A PARKING
AREAS WITH RELATIVELY SMALL
BUILDINGS WE SHOULD BE LOOKING
AT SOME OF THAT PROPERTY OPFER
HOUSING AS THE GOVERNOR HAS- OF
LONG DISCUSSED SO- OTHER THAN
SORT OF DAYLIGHTING THAT ISSUE-
IT IS THERE ARE A BUDGET
ALLOCATION THAT WOULD BE
HELPFUL IN PURSUING- SOME FIRST
STEPS IN AND- LOOKING. AT THAT
ISSUE. NOT A GOOD QUESTION CHEN
I'LL AT IN THE FINAL AND I
DON'T THINK WE HAVE A SPECIFIC
OUT FOR SOME OF SITE CONSOLE.
AND REAP A WE JUST THAT COUPLE
WEEK BACK WITH OFFICE I DON'T
BELIEVE THAT IS SPECIFICALLY
CALLED OUT WE DO MORE BROADLY
IN THE- IN THESE. AFTER
CONSOLIDATION PROBABLY FOR HEAD
LOCATION AS WE ARE SPREAD
ACROSS SACRAMENTO AND WE CAN
CONSOLIDATE WE CAN SAVE MONEY
AND WE CAN ACTUALLY WORK BETTER
AS A TEAM AS WE CONSOLIDATE OUR
SITES. WE DO SEE A CHANGE IN
OUR FOOTPRINT AS AS WE
DISCUSSED WITH YOU AND YOUR
STAFF IN THE FIELD OFFICE AS WE
MOVE MORE THINGS ONLINE
MORTGAGE YOUR DIGITIZED MORE
THINGS ARE MOVED TO THE MOBILE
PHONE. YEAH THAT'S GOING TO
CREATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
RETHINK OUR FOOTPRINT A MATTER
OF FACT WE HAVE AN INITIATIVE
WITH OUT PLANNING DESIGNER EACH
OKAY TO HELP US RETHINK HOW WE
DEAL DELIVER SERVICES AND AS WE
DO THAT I HAVE SEEN WITH OTHER
BUSINESSES. AMAZON TO PICK
PROBABLY A CONTROVERSIAL TOPIC
BUT IT ALLOWS US TO YOU FREE UP
ASSETS THAT ARE OUT. IN THE
FIELD OR READ YOUR REVIEWS
THURMOND AND AWAY THAT MIGHT BE
ABLE TO SUPPORT THINGS THAT
YOU'VE MENTIONED ABOUT YOUR
ATTY NOT AS IN RESIDENTS HERE.
MIXED USE PROPERTIES FOR BOTH
YOUR RESIDENTS RESIDENTS OVER
OVER BUSINESS AND SO ON BUT I
DON'T THINK WE HAVE A SPECIFIC
BUDGET REQUIREMENT I'LL I'M AND
I AM LOOKING AT DO YOU F. MATT.
I DON'T BELIEVE THE TWENTY THE
PROPOSAL TODAY FOR THAT
SPECIFIC. THERE IS HOWEVER ALSO
AS YOU MAY THERE ARE STEPS.
BASICALLY STEPS WE WOULD NEED
TAKE- TO LEAD. CONSOLIDATION
FUTURE AND IN IN THE MANNER OF
HIS- IN ONE HOW AND THREE-
GENERAL FUND PROPOS IS A-
TWENTY MILLION TO DO UPGRADES
TO IN THESE HEADQUARTERS IN
SACRAMENTO- AND THOSE ARE KIND
OF REQUIRED- BEFORE WE START
BRINGING PEOPLE BACK- FROM
ELSEWHERE- INTO HEADQUARTERS-
WHICH WILL ALLOW US TO- TO-
CLOSE SOME OFFICES- IN THE
FUTURE. WELL I APPRECIATE THAT
AND I JUST REALLY WANT TO PUT
THIS OUT THERE THAT WE'VE LONG
DISCUSS TO. PRIORITIZING USING
UNDER UTILIZED OR UNDERUTILIZED
A SURPLUS- A STATE LAND FOR
HOUSING PURPOSES- THIS IS NOT A
NEW DISCUSSION- AND YET WE'VE
SEEN PRECIOUS LITTLE OF FOLK-
THAT TRANSITION ACTUALLY TAKE
PLACE AND TOOK SO THIS IS
BUDGET SUB THREE IT'S NOT- ARE
OVERSIGHT IS AN OVER HOUSING
BUT- THERE ARE PLACES WHERE WE
OUGHT TO BE ABLE TO IDENTIFY-
THIS KIND OF UNDER UTILIZED
RESOURCE. SO THAT WE CAN
ADDRESS THIS MOST PRESSING
ISSUE- THAT IS AT A CRISIS
LEVEL TODAY- AND ACCELERATE OUR
OUR- OUR OUR REVIEW AND TO
HOPEFULLY MOVEMENT TOWARD
UTILIZING THOSE THOSE THOSE
PROPERTIES AND I DON'T MEAN TO
PICK ON A DMV HERE- I THINK- TO
THE DIRECTOR GARDENS CREDIT
HE'S BEEN WILLING TO- ENGAGE IN
THE DISCUSSION AROUND TO AROUND
THIS BUT I THINK EVERY
DEPARTMENT SHOULD BE. DOING
EXACTLY. THAT- OUR THERE OTHER
SEN HELLO JUST MOVED ON THE
ROAD HERE WILL US- THANK MISTER
BENNETT THANK YOU FOR MUCH
TERRIBLE- NUMBER ONE- LOVE
REALLY PLEASED SEE. DENTIST
INVEST AND ACTIVE. J. BUSES AND
TRY- IN AS I SAY SHE BEFORE AT
LIKE TO AND- JUST ONE OF THE
CITY. WHERE WE I BELIEVE NEED
TO HAVE THE INFRASTRUCTURE- TO
BE THERE TO INCENTIVIZE PEOPLE
TO ACTUALLY ADOPT THESE
VEHICLES LIKE CENTER AND- WILL
HAVE WEEK THIS IS ONE TIME WE
NEED TO PUT THAT FIRST. IN
OTHER WORDS COMMAND ECONOMIES
HAVE BEEN ABLE TO MAKE QUICK
TRANSITIONS BECAUSE THEY- MAKE
THOSE KIND OF INVESTMENTS AND I
THINK THAT HOPEFULLY WE WILL.
BE AHEAD OF THE CURVE RATHER
THAN BEHIND THE CURVE IN TERMS
OF RECHARGING STATIONS ALL
ACROSS THE BOARD- BUT I
APPRECIATE THAT- HERE- FOR THIS
HAVE BUSES AND TRUCKS AND LIKE
TO SEE MORE OF THAT. AND FOR
VEHICLES THE SECOND THING IS-
IN TERMS OF THE DMV- TECHNOLOGY
ADJUSTMENTS- THAT YOU HAVE
COMING UP- WE HAVE SUCH A LONG
HISTORY OF COST OVERRUNS AND
DELAYS- IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA WHEN WE TRY TO
IMPLEMENT- THE PSYCHES
PROJECTS. I'D LIKE TO STRONGLY
ENCOURAGE- THE DEPARTMENT TO
WORK WITH THE I. T.
PROFESSIONALS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND NOT EXCLUSIVELY
RELY ON OUTSIDE CONSULTANTS WHO
DON'T HAVE. THE SAME KIND OF
COMMITMENT TO LONG TERM SUCCESS
OF THE STATE AS A HAS PEOPLE
INSIDE DO THERE'S TRADITIONALLY
AND BUREAUCRACIES TENSION
BETWEEN THE I. T. DEPARTMENT
AND THE DEPARTMENT TRYING TO DO
THE IMPLEMENTATION I THINK WE
HAVE TO BRING THAT TO AN END
AND I HOPE THAT- THE DMV WILL.
WELL TAKE A- TAKE ADVANTAGE OF
SOME OF THE OF BEEN BROUGHT IN
TO I. T. HAD TRY TO MAKE SURE
THAT THEY HAVE A SMOOTH
TRANSITION BUT I WILL BE
WATCHING THAT WOULD CLOSELY- TO
MAKE SURE PROFESSIONALLY
HANDLED NUMBER THREE- I DON'T
WANT TO GO INTO THE DETAILS BUT
I WOULD LIKE ALEJO TO KEEP
CONTINUE TO LOOK AT- THE
BROADBAND INVESTMENT THE MIDDLE
MILE INVESTMENT IN PARTICULAR-
I THINK OVERALL THAT IF YOU
HAVE TO SAY THAT IF PEOPLE
WORK- CONNECTED TO ELECTRICITY
NOW- THEY WOULD REALLY BE AT
RISK FOR SURVIVAL IN MODERN
AMERICA. AND CERTAINLY NOW WE
ARE MAKING THE TRANSITION TO IF
YOU'RE NOT CONNECTED TO- HIGH
SPEED ACCESS YOU ALSO ARE AT
RISK IN MODERN AMERICA AND SO I
JUST WANNA MAKE SURE THAT THE
EFFORTS THAT WE MAKE WITH THE
MIDDLE MILE INVESTMENT IN THE-
THE SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF MONEY
THAT THE GOVERNOR HAS THERE
THAT WE HAVE. THAT ALEJO.
ACCESS- HELPFUL- FOR US TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE'RE ALL IN
AGREEMENT IN TERMS OF WHAT THE
BEST INVESTING. AND THEN- THE
FINAL SAY IS JUST THING- IN THE
BEAUTIFICATION PROGRAM- I AM
JUST CURIOUS BUT IT'S BEEN
RAISED- MANY TIMES BY THE
NUMBER OF- CONSTITUENTS. THAT
WE HAVE A CRISIS WITH THE
WESTERN MONARCH BUTTERFLIES- IN
THAT WE'VE- COMPLETELY. THE
COMPLETELY LOST THEIR THEIR
MILK WEED AND- IS IT POSSIBLE
FOR CALTRANS- AND SOME OF THIS
BEAUTIFICATION FUNDING TO GO
FOR THE PLANNING OF THE MILK WE
TO TRY TO HELP US PRESERVE- THE
MONARCH BUTTERFLIES- AS A ONE
OF THE-ANCILLARY BENEFITS OF
THE INVESTMENTS OF. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY THANK YOU MISTER
SMITH. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
EIGHT OF THE ELEVEN DOLLAR FOR
TRANS. HE SAYS ONE BILLION IN.
FOR THE TWENTY TWENTY EIGHT
OLYMPICS. IS THAT ALL GOING TO
LA CITY- L. A. COUNTY AND YOU
HAVE A BREAKDOWN OF WHAT THIS
ONE BILLION DOLLARS IS GOING TO
BE USED FOR. AND I GUESS
EVERYBODY CAN ANSWER. THERE
SHUFFLING THE DECK. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER ON THIS IS CHAD ADDISON
FROM CAL STA I CAN I CAN
ADDRESS THAT THE BILLION
DOLLARS THAT IS PROPOSED ON IN
SUPPORT OF THE- OUR DELIVER
BEFORE THE L. A. OLYMPICS. IS
SUPPOSED TO GO THROUGH THE
TRANSIT NURSING RAIL CAPITAL
PROGRAM WE WOULD DEVELOP
GUIDELINES FOR THAT PROGRAM
INTO A CALL FOR PROJECTS LATER
THIS YEAR AND I WORK FUNDING
FOR PROJECTS BY APRIL TWENTY
TWENTY TWO. ON THE L. A. METRO
TO EIGHT BY TWO WEST THERE TO
WORK. WHERE ARE AMONG THOSE
THAT WOULD BE. THAT OTHER
AGENCIES THROUGHOUT THE REGION
WOULD BE THAT THERE ARE TWO
MAIN PROJECTS THAT SUPPORT THE
L. A. X. ALSO. YEAH BECAUSE A
LIVE PICTURE SIX AND A HALF
YEAR AWAY DO PROPOSE A- MAYBE.
TO TWENTY FOR YOU'RE GONNA
ANOTHER. OR TWO BILLION TO
FINISH THESE PROJECTS WANT TO
GET STARTED. YEAH THE FUNDING
HERE IS MEANT TO BE HELPFUL AND-
FINISHING A NUMBER OF PROJECTS
AROUND THE REGION THAT ARE.
VERY USEFUL BOTH FOR THE
OLYMPICS AND ALSO BEYOND THESE
ARE TRANSPORTATION PROJECTS
THAT ARE. THAT ARE ALREADY ON
ON THE BOOKS AS NEEDING NEEDING
ENOUGH. FUNDING TO GET
COMPLETED A PRIOR TO TWENTY
TWENTY EIGHT AND WILL STRICTLY
BE FOR TRANSPORTATION. FOR THE
OLYMPICS AND NOT STRUCTURES FOR
THE OLYMPIC GAMES. NOT
STRUCTURES ARE TRêN AND RAIL.
SUPPORTING THE OLYMPICS AND IN
REGARDS TO THE SOME OF THE- NO
CLEAN. EMISSIONS I KNOW ON MY
DISTRICT A TRASH TRUCK IS ABOUT
A MILLION DOLLARS IN THE
PROPOSAL EIGHTY SEVEN MILLION
DOLLARS FOR TRUCK WE'RE GOING
TO GET EIGHTY SEVEN TRASH
TRUCKS IN THE WHOLE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND WE DON'T HAVE
THE INFRASTRUCTURE TO KEEP
THESE OF VEHICLES CHARGED UP.
IN MY SAME COMMENTS WOULD BE
FOR THE BUSES THE TRANSIT BUSES
THERE OVER A MILLION DOLLARS
WE'LL GET A HUNDRED OF THEM IN
THE STATE BUT WE'RE GONNA NEED
TWICE AS MANY BOSSES IN TRASH
TRUCKS TO RUN THE SPROUT THAT
THEY CURRENTLY DO RIGHT NOW.
AND WE DON'T HAVE THE
INFRASTRUCTURE TO BE ABLE TO
CHARGE HIM HALFWAY BETWEEN
THEIR ROUTE OF THE SCHOOL BUS
OF THE TRANSIT BUS OR THE TRASH
PICK UP IN THE COMMUNITY SO I
THINK WE NEED TO REALLY MAKE
THE INVESTMENT FOR THESE
CHARGING STATIONS AND COME UP
WITH THE TECHNOLOGY TWO QUICK
CHARGING TO CHARGE HIM QUICKLY.
BECAUSE OTHERWISE THEY HAVE TO
STOP HALFWAY IN CHARGE FOR SIX
OR EIGHT OR TWELVE HOURS TO
FINISH THE ROUTE IS GOING TO BE
VERY DIFFICULT. AND THEN I HAVE.
WITH THE- FUNDING FOR THE
CALIFORNIA LETTER YES WE GOT TO
CLEAN UP THE LITTER CALIFORNIA.
BUT SEVENTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS FOR ARTWORK I THINK WE
COULD USE A LOT MORE. OF
THERE'S A LOT MORE NEEDED
CALIFORNIA. IN MORE PARK WORK
SO. SEE IF WE CAN FIGURE THAT
OUT AS WE MOVE THROUGH THIS.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU ASSEMBLY
MEMBER RIVAS DID YOU HAVE
QUESTIONS COMMENTS OKAY- MS
FRIEDMAN. THANK YOU I DO HAVE
SEVERAL QUESTIONS- FIRST IS- A
COUPLE OF QUESTIONS ABOUT HIGH
SPEED RAIL SO IF YOU CAN MAYBE
QUEUE UP WHOEVER WOULD BE
PASSED HAVE CANCER- SO THE
REQUEST IS FOR FOUR POINT TWO
BILLION DOLLARS IN PROPOSITION
ONE A FUNDING. FOR HIGH SPEED
RAIL BUT LOOKING AT THE AMOUNT
THAT THEY HAVE BEEN SPENDING
CURRENTLY A YEAR TO YEAR. IT
APPEARS THAT THEY WOULD ONLY
NEED THAT AMOUNT OF MONEY IF
THEY WERE GOING TO DRASTICALLY
INCREASE THEIR BUDGET FOR THE
NEXT YEAR OR TWO. SO I'M
WONDERING WHAT CHANGES YOU'RE
ANTICIPATING IN THE NEXT COUPLE
OF YEARS. TO JUSTIFY THIS KIND
OF AN INCREASE OVER WHAT
THEY'RE CURRENTLY SPENDING ON
CONSTRUCTION. WHAT THIS IS
RANDY KATZ WITH THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE. YES SO IN- SILICON
EXPENDITURES WE TYPICALLY LOOK
AT ENCUMBRANCE EVEN THOUGH WE
KNOW THAT OUT EXPENDITURES MAY
TAKE A COUPLE OF YEARS SO THE
FOUR POINT TWO BILLION REQUEST
FOR HIGH SPEED RAIL TIES TO THE
BUSINESS PLAN AND TO THE
FUNDING PLAN PUBLISHED BACK IN
FEBRUARY WHEN THEY INDICATED DE
MERCED TO BAKERSFIELD
UNDERTAKERS SEGMENT WOULD COST
THIRTEEN POINT EIGHT BILLION SO
JUST CONSISTENT WITH CAPITAL
OUTLAY FUNDING AND ALSO
NECESSARY IN ORDER TO ENSURE
YOU CAN AWARD MULTI YEAR
CONTRACTS. THAT WE MAKE SURE
THAT WE HAVE ALL OF THE
AUTHORITY IN IN PLACE EVEN IF
EXPENDITURES TAKE A COUPLE
YEARS THANK YOU SO THIS IS NOT
TO CONTINUE THE CONSTRUCTION AS
THERE ARE PROCEEDING THEY THEY
DON'T NEED FOUR POINT- TWO
BILLION DOLLARS IN THE NEXT ONE
OR EVEN TWO YEARS- GIVEN WHAT
THEY ALSO RECEIVE FROM
GREENHOUSE GAS FUNDING THIS IS
ANTICIPATING FURTHER
CONSTRUCTION- OVER. SEVERAL
YEARS. YES YES IT WOULD BE THE
SEVENTY NECESSARY IN ORDER TO
COMPLETE- THE CENTRAL VALLEY
SEGMENT MADERA TO BAKERSFIELD
RIGHT SO WITH A LESSER
APPROPRIATION THEY COULD STILL
CONTINUE CONSTRUCTION EXACTLY
AS THEY'RE PROCEEDING RIGHT NOW.
THERE YES BUT THERE WOULD BE
SOME RISK AND THERE COULD BE
SOME CHALLENGES IN THEIR
ABILITY TO ON BOARD- DINNER
CONSTRUCTION PACKAGE FOR THE
REAL WORK AND ELECTRIFICATION.
OKAY AND WHAT MONTH DO YOU
FORECAST THAT CASH ON HIM FROM
PROP ONE A. M. CAP IN TRADE IN
FEDERAL FUNDS WILL RUN OUT FOR
THE PROJECT. SO I WOULD HAVE TO
DEFER TO MY COLLEAGUES FROM
FROM HIGH SPEED RAIL. OKAY DO
YOU HAVE AN ESTIMATED CASH FLOW
FOR THEM FOR THE NEXT BUDGET
FOR THIS BUDGET YEAR. AGAIN I
DON'T HAVE TO DEFER TO HIGH
SPEED RAIL. OKAY I WANT TO
SWITCH OVER I DON'T KNOW WHO'S
THE RIGHT PERSON TO THIS ASKING
ABOUT THE TRANSIT AND RAIL
PROJECT CONNECTIVE ITTY OF
BUDGET ITEM- WHICH I'M VERY
HAPPY TO SEE A BY THE WAY I'M
WONDERING AGAIN HOW THE PROJECT
FOR THIS WILL BE SELECTED. YES
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FRIEDMAN THIS
IS CHAD ADDISON CALLIS TA- THE
PROJECTS THE PROJECTS ELECTION
IS PROPOSED TO GO THROUGH A
TRANSIT INTERCITY RAIL CAPITAL
PROGRAM. A PROCESS THAT HAS A
SET OF GUIDELINES RELEASED THIS
SUMMER ALL FOR PROJECTS. I
LATER THIS YEAR AND AWARDS IN.
APRIL OF TWENTY TWENTY TWO-
THAT THERE IS THAT THERE IS A
REGULAR CAP AND TRADE IN SB ONE
FUNDING THAT GOES INTO THE R.
C. P. WE ARE PROPOSING GENERAL
FUND MONEY BE ADDED TO THAT. SO
THAT WE CAN DO THE YEAH I. THE
CONTROVERSY PROJECTS THROUGHOUT
THE STATE. AND I'M AN AWARD TOO
MANY PROJECTS THAT ARE READY TO
GET GOING AND DELIVER DELIVER
CONSTRUCTION AND THE CARE. SO
IT'S THE SAME PROJECTS ALREADY
IN CUBA YOU KNOW YOU'RE ABLE TO
ACCELERATE THEM. YES IT'S WELL
EXCEL. AND THERE'S A MUCH
LARGER AMOUNT OF MONEY
AVAILABLE- ON THE NATURAL WE
WOULD HAVE HAD ABOUT FIVE OR
SIX HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS FOR
THE NEXT ROUND. HE I'M IN THIS
MONEY ADDS TO THAT IS AVAILABLE
VERY QUICKLY AS OPPOSED TO
NEEDING THE WEIGHT OF THE OUTER
YEAR OF OUR- OF OUR FUNDING. SO
WE NORMALLY DO NOT CHANGING THE
PRIORITIZATION IT'S
ACCELERATING. ITS ACCELERATING
US THAT'S THAT'S GREAT. I'M AND
I'M SORRY THAT I AM JUMPING
AROUND A LITTLE I KNOW THAT'S
HARD ON YOUR END. BUT I WANTED
TO ASK A QUESTION ABOUT THE
ZERO EMISSION CLEAN TRUCKS.
PROGRAM AT W. AS WELL. THAT I
CAN HANDLE OKAY ME SEE IF I
HAVE AN- TRAIN. WEST RIGHT NOW
I DO NOT SO- WHO ARE THE CLEAN
TRUCK. AND CLEAN BECAUSE PERSON
IS. AND I GUESS ALL IT WHILE
THEY'RE QUEUING UP WHICH WAS A
YOU KNOW GIVEN- WHEN IT COMES
TO THE HEAVY DUTY SECTOR A
PARTICULARLY- D. A LECTOR
VEHICLES ARE ARE ACTUALLY KIND
OF HARD TO FIND AN EXTREMELY
EXPENSIVE AS MY COLLEAGUE
BROUGHT UP BUT I'M WONDERING IF
THERE'S MONEY. SET ASIDE IN THE
BUDGET FOR NEAR ZERO OR NATURAL
GAS VEHICLES IN THIS IN THIS
PARTICULAR SECTOR IN MY HEAVY
DUTY. AND MEDIUM DUTY SECTOR.
GOOD MORNING DAILY MENON PART
OF FINANCE- THE TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE ASSOCIATED WITH THIS
HAS NOT. YET BEEN RELEASED BUT-
WE WILL GET BACK TO WHEN WE- TO
RELEASE THAT AND THEN- CONFIRM-
WHETHER THE CURRENT PORTFOLIO
APPROACH WOULD BE MAINTAINED.
OKAY SO MY SUGGESTION WOULD BE
TO TAKE A CLOSE LOOK
PARTICULARLY THE HEAVY DUTY
SECTOR- ARE A NON ATTAINMENT
AIR QUALITY DISTRICTS- NEED
SOME VERY SHORT TERM RELIEF-
FROM THE AIR QUALITY IMPACTS
OF. A DRAYAGE TRUCKS AND OTHER
HEAVY DUTY VEHICLES AND THEY
FEEL THAT IT'S GOING TO BE
DIFFICULT TO ATTAIN THAT RIGHT
NOW WITH THE ZERO EMISSION%
VEHICLES ALTHOUGH THAT IS THE
GOAL- BUT THAT GETTING SOME OF
THOSE DIESEL TRUCKS WALKED OUT
WITH NATURAL GAS IS SOMETHING
THAT THEY COULD DO PRETTY
QUICKLY FOR. NOT A TREMENDOUS
AMOUNT OF MONEY WOULD PROVIDE A
LOT OF AIR QUALITY RELIEF- IN A
SECTOR WHERE. WHEN THOSE TRUCKS
GOING TO GET WORSE WALKED OUT
THEY'RE BASICALLY GOING TO
DIESEL- MOST OF THEM BECAUSE
IT'S STILL SO THERE SO STILL
SUCH A- A DELTA BETWEEN THE
COST OF THE ELECTRIC VEHICLE
THE AVAILABILITY AND THEN THE
INCENTIVES. SO JUST SOMETHING
TO THINK ABOUT- AND- I ALSO
HAVE A QUESTION ABOUT THE
GARBAGE PROGRAM SO I'M SORRY I
MAKING YOU GUYS. I THINK SWITCH
AROUND I DON'T KNOW IF THAT'S
SOMEBODY ELSE. MEANWHILE THE
WALLS OKAY. AND HI I'M I'M ON
THE HUNT FOR THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF TRANSPORTATION
I'M HERE TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS BOND THANK YOU
CALIFORNIA ALSO HAPPY TO SEE
THE ONE POINT FIVE BILLION
GENERAL FUND- FOR THE LITTER
PROGRAM UNIFICATION PROGRAM FOR
THE STATE- I'M WONDERING HOW
THE FUNDING IS GONNA BE AWARDED
AND WHETHER THERE ARE ANY KIND
OF EVIDENCE BASED PRACTICES TO
DETERMINE THE TYPES OF PROJECTS
THAT KIND OF. THAT THAT HELP
THE MOST. WE WOULD BE LOOKING
TO OUR EXISTING GRANT PROGRAMS
AND PROCESSES- COMMUNITY
ENGAGEMENT WILL BE A HUGE
ASPECT.OF THIS ENTIRE
PROPOSAL. I'M WE WOULD
CERTAINLY BE RELYING ON OUR
THAT PRACTICES IN OUR
PARTNERSHIPS WITH EXTERNAL
AGENCIES LOCAL COMMUNITIES. TO
ENSURE THAT THE COLLECTION OF
PROJECT IS SOMETHING THAT IS
EQUITABLE AND THEY'RE ALSO
FOCUSED ON UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES. MAKING SURE THAT
THAT THE BEAUTIFICATION
PROJECTS THAT ARE IMPLEMENTED
ARE IN AREAS OF THE STATE-
BETTER DIVERSE AND FAR REACHING
AND ALSO- YOU KNOW REALLY ARE
ARE DEALT WITH THE COMMUNITY
THAN MINE. SO CONTACT AND YOU
KNOW OUR IS ONE ELEMENT OF THE
PROPOSAL BUT REALY THE FOCUS
IS ON TAKING AN EXISTING THING.
AND TRANSFORMING IT INTO
SOMETHING THAT REALLY THE
COMMUNITY CAN TAKE PRIDE IN
WHAT WE FIND AT CALTRANS IS
WHEN YOU HAVE A ROADSIDE. I
THANK YOU THAT. PEOPLE QUITE
FRANKLY DON'T SEE AS A PART OF
THEIR OWN COMMUNITY. THEY TREAT
IT AS SCH AND SO THE CONCEPT
HERE IS TO REALLY TRANSFORM
THIS ISSUE. TAKE EXISTING PARTS
OF OUR INFRASTRUCTURE AND
TRANSFORM THEM INTO- PLACES
THAT QUITE FRANKLY BECOME PART
OF THE COMMUNITIES THAT WE
SERVE. SO IT IS A THEY'RE GOING
TO BE NEW STATE OR LOCAL
PROGRAMS CREATED OR IS THIS IS
IT ANTICIPATED. THAT THIS WILL
GO THROUGH EXISTING PROGRAMS.
WILL BE. A- WE ALL PREPARED TO
DEVELOP AND YOU WILL GREAT
PROGRAM YOU HARD THIS PRODUCT.
AND THAT WE HAVE LEARNED ON
OTHER FOR. WHICH WOULD BE. A
FIRST A LOCAL PROGRAM OF ITS
KIND BUT AGAIN WE WOULD NOT BE
STARTING FROM SCRATCH WOULD BE
USING SOME OF THE EXISTING.
PRINCIPLES AND PRACTICES THAT
WE HAVE. TO IDENTIFY AND
DISTRIBUTE DOLLARS TO OUR LOCAL
PARTNERS- FOR BEAUTIFICATION
PROJECT OR LITTER ABATEMENT
PROJECT. I'M ON THE STATE
SYSTEM WE WOULD BE USING OUR
EXISTING PROCESSES BUT WE WOULD
BE ABLE TO STREAMLINE. OUR THE
PROJECT DELIVERY SO WE'RE NOT
TALKING ABOUT YOUR STANDARD
STANDARD TRANSPORTATION PROJECT
THAT COULD TAKE YEARS TO
DEVELOP AND IMPLEMENT- WE'RE
LOOKING AT. ALL OF THE PROJECT
BEING ALIVE AND IN PLACE WITHIN
THE NEXT TWO TO THREE YEARS. SO
THERE'S SOMETHING ABOUT THIS
PROGRAM THAT REMINDS ME A
LITTLE OF THE WPA FOR ONE OF
OUR LAST BIG ECONOMIC
RECOVERIES IN THIS COUNTRY AND-
I THINK WE COULD ALL USE A
LITTLE BIT OF ART RIGHT NOW IN
OUR LIVES- SO I. VERY MUCH
COMMAND OF THE VISION OF THIS
PROGRAM I YOU KNOW IN MY
DISTRICT ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT'S GOTTEN THE MOST INTEREST
IN THIS PARTICULAR. OUT ITEM
HAS TO DO WITH THE INTERACTION
WITH THE GROWING PROBLEM OF
HOMELESS ENCAMPMENTS. AND THE
DIFFICULTY. THAT MY LOCAL ARM
CITIES HAVE. A LOT OF TIMES IN
MAINTAINING. AND JUST FRANKLY
DEALING WITH HOMELESS
ENCAMPMENTS ARE ON CALTRANS
PROPERTY BECAUSE OF THE MIX OF
AGENCIES. AND THE INABILITY FOR
LOCAL CITIES OUT LA SANITATION
DISTRICT FOR INSTANCE TO ACCESS
CALTRANS PROPERTY TO DO CLEAN
UPS- IMPACTS ON NEIGHBORHOODS A
LOT OF THESE ARE IN URBAN
CONTEXTS IN MY DISTRICT. WITH
THE RIGHT AND NEIGHBORHOODS.
AND SO THAT CITIES DON'T HAVE
ACCESS TO THE PROPERTY THE SAME
WAY THAT THEY WOULD IF IT WAS
JUST ON A REGULAR CITY STREET.
SO I'M WONDERING HOW YOU SEE
THE INTERACTION BETWEEN THE
HOMELESS ENCAMPMENT ISSUE WITH
THIS PROGRAM. AND. WHETHER I'M-
SORRY WHAT THERE'S ANY. BETWEEN
THE OR IF THIS IS COMPLETELY
SILO TO WEIGH IN. SORT OF GUY
HOW HOW. IF YOU HAVE AN AREA
THAT'S BEEN AN ENCAMPMENT IN.
THE CITY'S SORT OF CLEAN IT UP
AND TRY TO HOPEFULLY MOVE
PEOPLE INTO SERVICES. HOW WOULD
THIS INTERACTION WITH ANY
EFFORTS TO SORT OF RESTORE
RECLAIM THAT AREA. OVER THE
PAST YEAR TRANSPARENCY TAKEN A
READ A RADICAL SHIFT IN THE WAY
THAT WE ADDRESS HOMELESSNESS ON
THE STATE TRANSPORTATION SYSTEM
THAT THAT'S PRIMARILY BEEN
DRIVEN BY THE COBIT NINETEEN
PANDEMIC AND CAN'T CALTRAIN
FOLLOWING CDC GUIDELINES. AND
REALLY STOPPING THE MOVEMENT OF
PEOPLE I'M WHERE THERE'S NOT A
PARTICULAR NEED ONE EVERY DAY I
THINK YOU CONCERNS THAT'S BEEN
IDENTIFIED NOT IS WHEN WE WORK
WITH OUR LOCAL GOVERNMENT
PARTNERS TO TRY TO IDENTIFY
FAVORITE PLACES FOR PEOPLE TO
RELOCATE YOU. BUT REALLY WHAT
THEY- WHAT THIS YEAR HAS TAUGHT
US IS THAT YOU KNOW MOVING
PEOPLE AROUND AS A SINGLE
ENTITY AT CALTRANS OR AT ANY
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS WILL TELL YOU
I'M IF YOU'RE NOT DOING THIS
WORK IN A COORDINATED MANNER
WITH THE EXPERTS ON
HOMELESSNESS YOU'RE REALLY NOT
FAULTING THE COURT OKAY BECAUSE
I. JUST JUST MAYBE FOCUS IS A
LITTLE MORE SO HOW DOES THIS
PROGRAM IS ANY OF THIS FUNDING
HOW DOES THAT INTERACT WITH
CITIES EFFORTS. TO MOVE PEOPLE
OFF- CALTRANS PROPERTY CLEAN UP
THOSE AREAS MAYBE SECURITY
AREAS WHAT IS THE INTERNETIS
THERE ANY INTERACTION BETWEEN
THIS PROGRAM AND THIS FUNDING
WILL THIS HELP BY CITIES.
MAINTAIN OR DEAL WITH OR
DISCOURAGE PEOPLE FROM CAMP
MAKING IN. A CALTRANS RIGHT
AWAY. THIS IS NOT YOU NOT.
DRIVE THE REMOVE PEOPLE
CRANKING UP NORTH IN THE AIR OF
THE WHERE WE ARE PART. WITH
LOCAL. AND TO CONDUCT ME LOW
PEOPLE WE CERTAINLY CAN BE AND
I'LL- WHERE WE HAVE AN EXISTING
AREA WHERE PEOPLE ARE TAKING
SHELTER ON CALTRAIN PROPERTY.
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS ARE ABLE TO
YOU THE OTHER INITIATIVES
WITHIN THE ME REVISED OR
THROUGH A PROJECT HOME HE- TO
SUCCESSFULLY RELOCATE PEOPLE
INTO SHELTER HOUSING. THEN WE
CAN IT TAKE NOT LANDS WHERE
PEOPLE WERE SHELTERING BEFORE
AND TRANSFORM IT INTO INTO. A
PLACE THAT REALLY BECOMES A
PART OF THE COMMUNITY SO THERE
CERTAINLY COULD BE. AND THAT
TIME CONGRUENT THERE IF PEOPLE
ARE YOU KNOW ARE ARE WE LOCATED
IN TO SHELTER HOUSING I JUST
DON'T WANT THERE TO BE ANY
THOUGHT OR BELIEVED FACT. THIS
PROPOSAL WOULD ANYWAY BE YOU
KNOW FORCING PEOPLE WORK FOR
ANYTHING HOMELESSNESS OUT OF
TOWN TRANSPLANT WITHOUT
ALTERNATIVE PLACE RIGHT NOW
I'LL I UNDERSTAND I THINK THAT
THERE WOULD BE YEAH I
UNDERSTAND THAT THAT CONCERN
AND YOU KNOW CERTAINLY. CITY
LOS ANGELES AND OTHERS DON'T
WANT TO BE DOING THAT EITHER
AND THEY REALLY DO WANT TO BE
ABLE TO OFFER PEOPLE SERVICES.
I GUESS YOU KNOW JUST
FUNDAMENTALLY I WAS WONDERING
IF THERE'S ANY. ABILITY FOR
THIS FUNDING TO HELP THE
CITY'S- WITH WITH MAINTENANCE
FOR THESE THESE PARCELS OR ANY
JUST TO GIVE THEM ANY RELIEF.
AND SOUNDS LIKE NOT REALLY
EXCEPT AFTER THE FACT AFTER
THEY DO OFFER SERVICES AND THEY
DO CLEAN UP SOME OF THESE AREAS
THAT THERE'S- MAYBE SOME SORT
OF RESTORATION MONEY TO HELP.
YOU MAKE THOSE AREAS A LITTLE
BIT BETTER AND SOMETHING B. C.
FOR AN AND MORE- INGRAINED INTO
THE COMMUNITY SO I THINK THAT'S
WHAT I'M HEARING FROM YOU. BUT
I AGREE I DON'T WANT ANYONE TO
TAKE ARE YOU OF THESE EFFORTS
AS SORT OF. YOU KNOW M. AND BY
THE WAY FROM THE CITY SIDE
MOVING PEOPLE OFF OF CALTRANS
PROPERTY JUST SO THAT THEY CAN
MOVED ON THE BLOCK IS NOT
pOPTIMAL EITHER I MEAN. YOU KNOW
THE- AND EVERYBODY HAS THE GOAL
OF ACTUALLY GETTING PEOPLE
HOUSED. SO THE CITIES ARE
TRYING TO DO THAT I KNOW
CALTRANS IS NOT TRYING TO DO
THAT- ABOUT WHEN MY CITY SAW
THIS PARTICULAR ALLOCATION.
THEY. ALSO SAID- IS THIS
SOMETHING WE CAN USE TO HELP US
WITH THIS. YOU WANT TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THE IS FINDING AN
THE BUDGET THE PROPOSED THAT WE
HELP WITH- HAD A BIG ADDING
FIFTEEN CABINET WHILE WE'RE ON
BE LOCATION SOLUTION. AND THE
IRON INCREASING THE FUNDING FOR
TRASH SHOULD BE AND UP IN AREAS
YOU KNOW NEAR AN ACTIVE CAN'T
SAY THERE IS FINDING AMERICORPS
THAT IN PARTICULAR OKAY THAT IS
GOOD TO KNOW AND SOMETHING THAT
I THINK THE CITIES WILL BE
HAPPY TO HEAR AS WELL. AND THEN
MY LAST QUESTIONS ARE ABOUT THE
CLIMATE- THE ONE POINT THREE
BILLION DOLLARS- FOR THE IMPACT
OF CLIMATE CHANGE AND MY
QUESTION IS I DON'T. KNOW IF
IT'S FOR YOU OR SOMEONE ELSE
BUT I WILL ASK IT. YOU WE KNOW
THAT CLIMATE CHANGE
INCREASINGLY IT IS IMPACTING
AND THREATENING OUR
INFRASTRUCTURE AND WE HAVE SOME
CRITICAL TRANSPORTATION
INFRASTRUCTURE. THAT IS VERY
MUCH UNDER THREAT FROM CLIMATE
CHANGE PARTICULARLY SOME RAIL
LINES THAT ARE ALONG. YOU KNOW
CLIFFS DOWN IN THE SAN DIEGO
AREA. AND I'M WONDERING HOW.
THE ADMINISTRATION IS GOING TO
PRIORITIZE SOME OF THE
INVESTMENTS THE TRANSPORTATION
INVESTMENTS. THAT ARE. MAYBE
TODAY NOT UNDER IMMINENT THREAT
BUT CERTAINLY WE KNOW. THAT
WITH CLIMATE CHANGE THEY ARE
EXTREMELY HIGH RISK AND- THAT
IT'S BETTER TO START THE
PROCESS OF MOVING THEM
SOMEWHERE SAFE FOR. NOW RATHER
THAN WAIT FOR. YOU KNOW. A HUGE
EVENTS TO REALLY- I PUT THEM IN
IMMINENT PERIL SO I'M WONDERING
HOW YOU PRIORITIZE THAT WITHIN
THIS IF YOU ARE THINKING ABOUT
PRIORITIZING THAT WITHIN THIS
BUDGET. AND I WANT TO
ACKNOWLEDGE I'M NOT THE RIGHT
PERSON. QUESTION SO I WILL
DEFER TO IT. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
FRIEDMAN THIS IS I CHAD
ANDERSON AGAIN FROM CAL STA-
SOME OF THE PROJECTS HAT YOU
REFERRED TO ARE ARE IN THE
TRANSIT AND RAIL CATEGORY AND-
AND WE CERTAINLY ARE
PRIORITIZING. PROJECTS THAT
THAT THAT THAT MAKE INVESTMENTS
TO SPRINT AND RAIL CORRIDORS-
WHERE WHERE THEY ARE. BOTH
WHERE THEY ARE NOW BUT ALSO
CONSIDERING THOSE RELOCATIONS
WE HAD A SUCCESSFUL- SET OF
INVESTMENTS THAT WE PUT
TOGETHER WITH ON THE DEL MAR
BLESSED PROJECT IN PARTICULAR-
OVER THIS LAST OVER THIS LAST
GUY YEAR. AND HAVE BEEN
SUCCESSFUL BOTH IN GETTING AND
I TRADE QUARTER FUNDING AS WELL
AS A FEDERAL AND STATE YOU KNOW
OTHER STATE FUNDING INTO THAT
PROJECT. WHILE ALSO HELPING TO
FUND THE STUDY TO RELOCATE THE
RAILROAD. I REQUEST UNESCO'S
YOU KIND OF GO DOWN THE LIST IS
THERE SOME METRIC WE'RE LOOKING
AT IT SOME WAY OF EVALUATING
RISK. THE IMPORTANCE OF THE
PARTICULAR TRANSPORTATION YOU
KNOW INFRASTRUCTURE- YOU KNOW
KIND OF HOW HOW IS THAT DOES.
YES THE MOTHERS THERE'S TWO
WAYS THAT IT'S DONE. ONE IS THE
GUIDELINES OF OUR TRANSACTIONS
REAL CAPITAL PROGRAM WHICH LOOK
AT YOU KNOW PROJECTS LIKE THESE
AND SAY HEY LOOK AT RESILIENCE
IS ONE OF THE CRITERIA. ON THAT
SECONDARY CRITERIA. I'M WE ALSO
HAVE THE- IN THE STATE RAIL
PLAN WEEK INCLUDE PROJECTS THAT
ARE TIED TO THAT RESILIENCE SO
IN THE STATE RAIL PLAN WE HAVE
THAT. IN BEING IN THAT PLAN AS
PART OF UP IN PRIORITIZE FOR
INVESTMENT IN. TRANSIT RAIL
CAPITAL PROGRAM. AND SO- WE DO
HAVE THE MECHANISMS BY WHICH TO
RECOGNIZE THE YEAH. B. R.
OPPORTUNITIES TO IT TOO TO MAKE
INVESTMENTS THAT ARE THAT ARE
YOU KNOW. LOOKING FORWARD TO
THE FUTURE AND PUTTING THEM
WHERE THEY NEED TO BE. MADE
RESILIENCY ALL. THANKS AND HAVE
A COMMENT LASTLY HAVE BEEN
SHOULD QUESTIONS WHICH IS THAT
I. AM REALLY HAPPY TO SEE THE
INVESTMENTS IN THIS BUDGET AND
CLIMATE RESILIENCY AND
TRANSPORTATION INFRASTRUCTURE-
IN BEAUTIFICATION THERE'S SO
MANY THINGS TO LIKE IN THIS
BUDGET AND I THINK IT YOU KNOW
WHAT THE BOTTOM. LINE FOR ME IS
THAT IT'S A VERY VISIONARY
BUDGET THAT ALSO DOESN'T MAKES
A REAL DOWN PAYMENT. ON THE
FUTURE OF CALIFORNIA I MEAN NOT
ONLY IS IT A RECOVERY BUDGET
THAT'S CREATING JOBS. AND
MOVING SHOVEL READY PROJECTS
THAT COMMUNITIES HAVE WANTED
FOR DECADES IN SOME CASES THAT
THEY PRIORITIZE THAT THEY PUT
ON A LIST THAT THEY'VE DONE THE
INITIAL WORK THEY'VE DONE THE
ER'S THE READY TO GO.
EXHILARATING THOSE AND GETTING
PEOPLE TO WORK BUT GIVING
PEOPLE REAL MOBILITY OPTIONS
REDUCING CONGESTION REDUCING
OUR IMPACT ON CLIMATE CHANGE
MAKING US MORE RESILIENT MAKING.
US SAFER. IN THIS BUDGET.
PRIORITIZES THE THAT HAVE MANY
CALL BENEFITS. BUT I THINK THAT
IT'S- MOVING THE DAY FOR- IN A
POSITIVE WAY IN REDUCING FUTURE
COSTS. OF DEFERRING ALL OF THIS
INFRASTRUCTURE WORK. SO I THINK
IT'S REALLY EXCITING AND- YOU
KNOW I KNOW THAT WE'RE
CONTINUING TO HAVE DISCUSSIONS
ON THERE ARE QUESTIONS BUT- BUT
I DO THINK IT'S AN EXCITING
TIME FOR CALIFORNIA. AND I'M
YOU KNOW JUST HAPPY TO BE A
PART OF IT. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. FRIEDMAN AND CHERRY BLOOM
IF I COULD JUMP IN THIS IS A
BRIAN ANNIS I'M THE CHIEF
FINANCIAL OFFICER FOR HIGH
SPEED RAIL I. APOLOGIZE I WAS
ANSWERING THE ASSEMBLYMEMBER'S
QUESTIONS BUT SET MY AUDIO WAS
WAS OFF AND IT WAS. MORE THAN
JUST AN AND YET SO I HAD TO RE
LOCK AGAIN. BUT IF I IF I COULD
RESPOND TO HER QUESTIONS-
FOLLOWING UP ON MY- COLLEAGUES
FROM FINANCE IN THAT
CALIFORNIA'S. TRANSPORTATION
AGENCY. ALAMEDA OUR DEALERSHIP
YOU IF- IF YOU COULD BE AS
CONCISE AS POSSIBLE WOULD
APPRECIATE IT- WE STILL HAVE-
MISERY THIS TASK WHAT QUESTIONS
OR MAKE COMMENTS. AND I'M
PRETTY SURE A WHOLE BUNCH OF
PEOPLE- WHO STILL WANT TO MAKE
PUBLIC COMMENT. AT HER TO HAVE
TO HIDE NOW. AT THE TO BRIEF
JUST CAN'T MENTION THAT WE DO
EXPECT TO. RUN OUT OF OUR
CURRENT CASH RESOURCES IN EARLY
CALENDAR YEAR TWENTY TWENTY
TWO. AND THAT'S BECAUSE WE DO
CONTINUE TO SEE RAMP UP IN OUR
MONTHLY EXPENDITURES. ARE WE DO
HAVE ABOUT TWO THIRDS OF OUR
STRUCTURES THAT ARE NOW UNDER
CONSTRUCTION OR- ALREADY
FINISHED CONSTRUCTION. AND WE
HAVE THAT FINAL THIRD THERE
WILL BE CLEARING. THROUGH RIGHT
AWAY YOU TELL ME THE LOCATION.
OTHER MAJOR ITSELF HAS THOSE
STACK UP. ARE WE WILL BE SEEING
ADDITIONAL SPENDING AGAIN THAT
THE PROP ONE A. IS NEEDED. TO
MEET THAT CASH FLOW IN THE
BUDGET YEAR I ONCE WE START
ACCESSING. OUR PROP ONE A. I.
WE DO EXPECT JUST SPEND IT
WITHIN ABOUT TWENTY FOUR MONTHS
OR SO. ALSO THAT IS THE SHORT
TERM EXPENDITURE SO THANK YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO JUMP IN
AND I APOLOGIZE. FOR MY HIGHER
AUDIO ISSUES. THANK YOU FOR THE
COMMENTS- ASSEMBLY MEMBER
RIVAS. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR-
I HAD A QUESTION ABOUT THE
CLEAN CALIFORNIA INITIATIVE YOU
KNOW THERE WAS A REPRESENTATIVE.
PREVIOUS. TO THE- CALIFORNIA
YES I'M I'M HERE YOU ARE THERE
ARE. QUESTIONS I JUST WANNA GO
AHEAD YEAH I'M LIKE A SOME
MEMBER FOR I ALSO VERY X. TO
SEE THIS. OF US WIDE BE TO
EFFORTS- ESPECIALLY IN OUR OUR
STATE HIGH IN THE FREEWAY ARE
YOU KNOW THIS IS WHY OF THE BIG
ISSUES AND DISTRICT- EXISTING
LETTER AND LACK OF CONSISTENT
TRASH COLLECTION ON OUR
HIGHWAYS- SO MY CONSTITUENTS
WERE VERY HAPPY TO SEE THIS-
ANNOUNCEMENT AS I WAS I'M I
HAVE A QUESTION ON HOW THE
FUNDING IS ALLOCATED- YOU KNOW
PART OF THE ONE POINT FIVE
BILLION- YOU HAVE FOUR HUNDRED
EIGHTEEN MILLION FOR LITERA
BATEMAN ACTIVITIES AND
STRENGTHENING TRASH COLLECTION.
DOES ALL OF THAT FUNDING GO TO
CALTRANS AND IF SO HOW IS THAT
ALLOCATED IS IT DOES GO TO
THEIR DISTRICT OFFICES AND
THEN- THE TEAMS THERE DECIDE
WHAT PART OF THEIR DISTRICT HAS.
THE MOST NEED OR HOW DOES THAT
WORK. SURE SO. HAPPY TO ANSWER
THAT QUESTION I AND MY NAME IS
WENDY HARTLEY CALTRANS AND- SO
THAT PROPOSAL REALLY OUTLINED
AN OVERALL WHAT YOU SEE IN THE
PROPOSAL CASH TRANSACTION I
SPEND OVER A HUNDRED MILLION
ANNUALLY ON TRASH. EVERY YEAR
WE CONTINUE TO INCREASE OUR
TRASH COLLECTION AND IT'S NOT
UNCOMMON FOR US TO YOUR
COMMENT. AND THAT IT SEEMS AS
IF WE'RE NOT COLLECTING TRASH
AND BUT THE REALITY IS. I
OFTENTIMES OUR CREWS ARE
WORKING IN AREAS WHERE THEY'RE
GETTING HIT WITH TRASH AND
THEY'RE PICKING IT UP. I'M IN
WITHIN SEVENTY TWO HOURS THAT
CAN LOOK AT THE CALTRANS WOULD
NEVER OUT THE LOCATION AND SO-
IT'S A COMBINATION HOUSE
REINFORCES BUT ALSO GROUP THAT
WE WORK VERY PROMINENTLY WITH
KNOWN AS EMPLOYMENT SOCIAL
ENTERPRISES. EITHER GREAT
GROUPS THAT WE WORK WITH AND
THROUGH THIS PROPOSAL WE WOULD
BE CREATING A GREAT DEAL OF
JOBS FOR PEOPLE WHO WORK FOR
EMPLOYMENT SOCIAL ENTERPRISES
WHO. ARE BASICALLY ARE BETTER
CREWS WILL COME OUT ON TO
CALTRAIN SYSTEM THAT WE
CONTRACT WITH THEM BUT THESE
ARE FOLKS WHO COME WHO ARE
OVERCOMING BARRIERS TO WORK.
PEOPLE WHO ARE EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS- REENTERING
SOCIETY FROM INCARCERATION
ACCEPT JOBS AND SO THEY WORK
THROUGH THESE GROUPS WILL ALSO
HELP PROVIDE ACCESS TO TRAINING
AND HOUSING- AND TOOL SO THAT
THEY CAN GET ON TO A BETTER
CHAPTER OF THEIR LIFE. ALSO
THROUGH THAT PROGRAM THERE'S AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR THOSE FOLKS TO
GROW INTO POSITIONS WITH
CALTRANS. THEY WERE INTRODUCING
NEW WELFARE YOUR MATE AND
COMPLICATIONS WITHIN THE
DEPARTMENT. SO THAT WE CAN HAVE
DEDICATED THE WEATHER ABATEMENT
CREWS IN EACH OF OUR TWELVE
DISTRICTS ACROSS THE STATE.
CURRENTLY WE'RE REDIRECTING
EXISTING MAINTENANCE CREWS TO
PICK UP TRASH WHILE THEY'RE
TRYING TO ADDRESS OTHER
SPEAKING AND MAINTENANCE NEEDS
ON THE TRANSPORTATION SYSTEM.
SO THROUGH THIS PROPOSAL
CALTRANS WOULD BE DEVELOPING
DEDICATED LETTER CRUZ. THAT
WOULD BE WORKING WITHIN THE
DISTRICT BUT WOULD BE WORKING
AND ALL OF OUR SIGNIFICANT
TRASH GENERATING AREAS. AND
ACROSS EVERY THERE THERE WOULD
NOT BE A ROUTE A STATE ROUTER
IN YOUR STATE THAT AT THE LAST
OUT OF THE EQUATION WHEN IT
COMES TO LITTER ABATEMENT. AND
SO WE WOULD BE WORKING OUR OUR
REGIONAL OFFICES WOULD BE
WORKING TO IDENTIFY THE
GREATEST. NEEDS BEST A
FREQUENCY OF TRASH WHY ACROSS
THE STATE WHAT A- AND THAT
WOULD BE THROUGH THE COUNT.
FORCE BUT ALL THROUGH THAT THE
CON. THAT WITHOUT EMPLOYMENT
BUT ENTERPRISE. SO WE ALREADY
THESE ARE X. CON. CONTRACTORS
RIGHT YOU ALREADY THESE PER.
SET UP. OR WILL THERE BE A OP.
FOR NEW. OF THE SOCIAL
ENTERPRISE- TO JOIN THIS
PROGRAM. WE ARE ALREADY WORKING
WITH A HANDFUL BUT WE'RE REALLY
EXCITED TO BE ABLE TO EXPAND
OUR PARTNERSHIPS AND WORK WITH
MORE MORE GROUPS FOR EXAMPLE
WITH THE CONSERVATION CORPS I
CENTERS FOR EMPLOYMENT
OPPORTUNITY ANOTHER SO WE'RE
ALREADY WORKING WITH THEM AND
I'M HAPPY BUT THAT'S WOULD
GREATLY AND INCREASE OUR OUR
WORK IN THE STATE. OKAY GREAT-
OUT. I HAVE SIMILAR CONCERNS ON
YOU KNOW THE HOMELESS
ENCAMPMENTS THAT ARE- ON THE
HIGHWAYS- I KNOW IN MY DISTRICT
SOMETIMES WE HAVE SOME THAT ARE
ABANDONED RIGHT LIKE- MAYBE THE
PERSON EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS FOUND HOME OR OR
WAS PLACED IN PERMANENT
SUPPORTIVE HOUSING BUT THEN-
ITEMS REMAIN BEHIND AND I KNOW
I'VE BEEN TOLD THAT THAT
REQUIRES OR COULD POTENTIALLY
REQUIRE HAZARDOUS WASTE CREW-
AND SO I WASN'T SURE IF THE- IF
THAT'S A SEPARATE. PROGRAM OR
IN SEPARATE LINE ITEM IN YOUR
BUDGET I KNOW IN A PREVIOUS
BUDGET SUB THREE HEARING WE DID
HEAR FROM CALTRANS WHERE THEY
WERE REQUESTING I THINK IT WAS
TWENTY MILLION DOLLARS FOR HAS
YOU KNOW CONTRACTORS- THAT
SPECIALIZE IN HAZARDOUS WASTE
THAT MAYBE YOUR CREWS DON'T
HAVE THE TRAINING YOU KNOW TO
CLEAN. OUT AND SO DOES THIS
FOUR HUNDRED AND EIGHTEEN IS
THIS FOR EIGHTEEN MILLION
SEPARATE JUST FOR LETTER OR
DOES THIS ALSO IS ALL LUMPED IN
AND INCLUDES THE HAZARDOUS
WASTE. NINE NINE NUMBER
HAZARDOUS WASTE SO THAT WE CAN
INCREASE CLEANING I'M NOT
ENCAMPMENTS BY PEOPLE EITHER
BEEN RELOCATED SUCCESSFULLY OR
OUT IN ADVANCE I MEAN CAN'T.
DESCRIBE BUT IT'S NOT PART OF
THE FOUR HUNDRED AND EIGHTEEN
MILLION. IT OR THAT. IT IS A
PART OF THAT HORRENDOUS OKAY
THAT'S THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR
ANSWERING MY QUESTIONS. I KNOW
I'M I'M EXCITED ABOUT THIS
PROGRAM AND LOOKING FORWARD. TO
SEEING THE RESULTS OF IT AND
THE IMPLEMENTATION- SO THANK
YOU FOR YOUR ANSWERS AND FOR
CLARIFIED SOME THINGS FOR ME-
THE ONLY OTHER COMMENTS I HAD
WERE ON THE HIGH SPEED RAIL.
I'M NOT REALLY ANY QUESTIONS
JUST WANTED TO EXPRESS. YOU
KNOW SOME COMMENTS THAT YOU
KNOW I SUPPORT THE CONCEPT OF A
HIGH SPEED RAIL IN CALIFORNIA
BUT I THINK OUR CURRENT
APPROACH. IS NOT WORKING. I
THINK WE SHOULD CONSIDER YOU
KNOW HAVING SERIOUS DISCUSSIONS
ABOUT WHAT STEPS WE COULD TAKE.
UP TO MAKE SURE WE'RE MOVING
FORWARD IN A WAY THAT MAKES
FISCAL SENSE- YEAH I REMAIN
CONCERNED THAT. THE MATH
DOESN'T ADD UP FOR THE HSR
PROJECT- I HOPE THAT WERE ABLE
TO GET FEDERAL ASSISTANCE NO
SIGNIFICANT. FEDERAL
ASSISTANCE- IF ESPECIALLY IF
OUR COUNTRY WANTS. THIS PROJECT
TO BE A MODEL NATIONWIDE FOR
WHAT CAN BE DONE WITH HIGH
SPEED RAIL- BUT I THINK RIGHT
NOW WE HAVE TO BALANCE- YOU
KNOW AS LEGISLATORS HOW MUCH
ARE CONSTITUENTS WILL BE ON THE
HOOK. FOR INCLUDING- INCLUDING
THOSE THAT LIVE IN LESS
AFFLUENT COMMITTEE COMMITTEES
FOR YOU KNOW HOW MUCH ARE WE
CAN BE ON THE HOOK FOR THIS
PROJECT- THERE ARE OTHER
APPROACHES THAT HAVE BEEN
PRESENTED THAT CAN INCREASE
WELL RIDERSHIP AND I HOPE THAT.
THOSE WILL BE PART OF THE
DISCUSSION AS WE MOVE. INTO
THIS. THE REMAINING BUDGET
DISCUSSIONS. IN THE NEXT FEW
WEEKS THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH- I AM GOING TO. MAKE A
COUPLE OF COMMENTS ABOUT
BROADBAND JUST TO RETURN TO
THAT TOPIC VERY BRIEFLY- WE
REALLY DON'T HAVE TIME TO HAVE
A FULLER. A DISCUSSION OF MY
QUESTIONS SO I'LL ASK- WHOEVER
IT IS THAT- NEEDS TO RESPOND TO
THEM TO PLEASE DO SO WITH ME
OFFLINE- BUT- ONE QUESTION I
HAVE IS- WE KNOW THAT- MILLIONS
OF CALIFORNIA'S. STILL DO NOT
HAVE ACCESS TO BROADBAND- AND
THE AND THE REASON IS THEY
CAN'T AFFORD THE SERVICE AND SO
I UNDERSTAND THAT THIS IS
INTENDED TO BRING. A CABLE TO
PEOPLE'S HOMES ULTIMATELY BUT
WHAT ARE WE DOING TO NARROW
THAT- ISSUE OF AFFORDABILITY.
AND DUG OUT THE OTHER QUESTION
I HAVE HAS TO DO WITH
TECHNOLOGY- IT SEEMS THAT WE
ARE RELYING ON A CABLE AND
ASSUMING THAT- THE PUBLIC WILL
CONNECT TO THE CABLE AT THE END
OF THE DAY AND WILL ACCESS-
HIGH SPEED DATA- BROADBAND. IN
IN DOING SO. BUT I'M NOT SO
SURE THAT'S WHERE THE PUBLIC IS
TODAY- I THINK I LIKE IT A LOT
OF PEOPLE- ACCESS THE INTERNET
AND UTILIZED BROADBAND OR
UTILIZED THEIR- OTHER PERSONAL
DEVICES- UGH UGH FOR ACCESSING
THE INFORMATION AND THE THING
SO THAT WE ALL TAKE FOR GRANTED
TODAY AND SO. I WOULD BE
INTERESTED IN KNOWING WHAT DATA
IS OUT THERE SUPPORTING THE
INVESTMENT OF BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS- I'M NOT SAYING WE ARE
BUT I'M HOPING THAT WE'RE NOT
INVESTING IN WHAT ULTIMATELY
WILL BE AN OBSOLETE TECHNOLOGY
BY THE TIME WE ACTUALLY FINISH
BUILDING CUT- THE SYSTEMS OUT
OF WE NEED TO KNOW THAT THE
CUSTOME BASE WILL BE THERE FOR
THE SERVICES SO IF I COULD GET
SOME- FEEDBACK ON THAT CONCERN
I WOULD APPRECIATE IT. AND I
WANT TO SAY I APPRECIATE VERY
MUCH THE PATIENCE OF THOSE WHO
HAVE BEEN WAITING TO GIVE THEIR
PUBLIC- COMMENT FOR- ARE
PERHAPS HOURS NOW AND- WE WILL
NOW- OF A MOVE TO THAT. IF
THERE IS ANY MEMBER OF THE
PUBLIC IN THE ROOM WHO WISHES
TO SPEAK UP PLEASE STEP FORWARD
MAINTAINING SOCIAL DISTANCE I'M
SUPPOSED TO ASK YOU UP ONCE AT
ONE TIME BUT- I DON'T THINK
IT'S OKAY JUST. MAINTAINA
LITTLE DISTANCE THERE AND WE'RE
ALL GOOD- PLEASE PERCENT. GOOD
AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR
COMMITTEE MEMBERS JONATHAN CLAY
ON THE BEHALF OF THE CITY OF
ENCINITAS TWO QUICK ITEMS. ONE
WANNA URGE THE COMMITTEE TO
REJECT THE ADMINISTRATION'S
PROPOSAL ON SUSPENDING BEACH
SAND REPLENISHMENT THIS IS PART
OF- BOATING AND WATERWAYS
UNDER- STATE PARKS- BEECH ST
REPLENISHMENT. IS THE BEST WAY
TO ADDRESS CLIMATE CHANGE AND
SEA LEVEL RISE VERSUS MORE
TRADITIONAL INFRASTRUCTURE LIKE
SEA WALLS- THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT PICKED UP 65% OF
THESE PROJECTS THE COST OF
THESE PROJECTS. BUT THERE HAS
TO BE A COST SHARE THAT GOES
ALONG WITH THAT SPECIFIC CAR
PROJECT AND INTERMEDIUS- WE'VE
BEEN WORKING ON THIS PROJECT
SINCE TWO THOUSAND. THE STATE
IS INVESTD ABOUT TWO POINT
SEVEN MILLION DOLLARS AND ALL
THE ENVIRONMENTAL STUDIES AND
WE'VE NOW APPLIED FOR A PROJECT
AND JUST. SEEMS KIND OF-
INOPPORTUNE TIME TO BE
SUSPENDING THIS PROGRAM- ALSO
THE BEACHES THAT ARE GOING TO
BENEFIT FROM THIS ARE ACTUALLY
STATE BEACHES SO WE WOULD URGE
YOU TO NOT- SUPPORT
ADMINISTRATIONS PROPOSAL. AND
THEN SECONDARILY ON THE
TRANSPORTATION SIDE WOULD URGE
THE COMMITTEE TO CONSIDER MAYBE
PUTTING MORE MONEY TOWARDS THE
ACTIVE TENSE. ACTIVE
TRANSPORTATION PLAN- TO FULLY
FUND ALL THE PROJECTS THAT HAVE
BEEN SELECTED BY THE CTC THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU. I
NEGLECTED TO SAY THAT WERE
ALLOWING. ONE MINUTE FOR PUBLIC
COMMENT. WHAT TO READ THAT THE
MATH WELL I WOULD PREFER IF YOU
WORRY MASS PLEASE. I'M HERE.
HELLO MY NAME'S LARA THE HAND
STATE DIRECTOR AT ENVIRONMENT
CALIFORNIA THANK YOU TERM
EMPLOYMENT COMMITTEE MEMBERS
AND I'M HERE TODAY TO STAND IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED INVESTMENT
IN CLEAN TRANSPORTATION AND
CLEAN TRANSPORTATION
INFRASTRUCTURE AT THE THREE
POINT TWO BILLION DOLLAR A
PROPOSAL IS A REALLY IMPORTANT
STEP FORWARD SO WE HAVE TO MAKE
NAY AS- TO INVEST IN CLEAN AIR
AND TACKLE THE CLIMATE CRISIS
OUR BIGGEST SOURCE OF GLOBAL
WARMING STILL IT'S FROM
TRANSPORTATION SOURCES. WE'RE
REALLY EXCITED ABOUT THE
INVESTMENT IN CLEAN ELECTRIC
SCHOOL BUSES AND OTHER ASPECTS
AND BUT WE WOULD LIKE TO ASK I
RESPECTFULLY THE LEGISLATURE TO
INCREASE THE INVESTMENT IN THE
MOST EFFECTIVE PROGRAMS LIKE
CLEAN CARS FOR ALL WHICH TAKE
THE DIRTY IF YOU'RE CLOSED OFF
THE ROAD AND REPLACE THEM WITH
CLEAN CARS AND HELP REDUCE
REDUCE AIR POLLUTION THE MOST
IMPACTED PARTS OF THE STATE.
AND SO THAT WE'RE CALLING FOR
FIVE HUNDRED MILLION DOLLAR
ALLOCATION FOR THE GREEN CARD
FOR ALL AND OTHER EQUITY
PROGRAM- AND WE ALSO URGE YOU
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE AUTHORIZED
AB EIGHT AND VEHICLE
REGISTRATION FEES THAT WE CAN
ENSURE WE HAVE THAT STABLE
FUNDING SOURCE AND THAT 50% OF
THE INVESTMENTS GO INTO THE
MOST NEEDY COMMUNITIES WHERE WE
NEED PUBLIC INVESTMENTS THE
MOST THANK YOU SO MUCH. YOU'RE
WELCOME THANK YOU VERY MUCH- I
THINK THAT'S THE LAST SPEAKER
FROM HERE IN THE ROOM SO WE'LL
MOVE TO THE TELEPHONES- AGAIN
THE PUBLIC TOLL FREE NUMBER IS.
877-692-8957 AND THE PUBLIC
ACCESS CODE IS. ONE THREE ONE
FIVE FOUR TWO ZERO TWO OPERATOR
ARE YOU THERE. YES I'M HERE
GREAT- YOU CAN GO AHEAD AND ASK
PEOPLE- TO PROVIDE THEIR PUBLIC
COMMENTS- RENDON REMINDING
EVERYONE THAT- WE'RE ALLOWING
ONE MOMENT WILL HAVE ONE MINUTE
FOR- COMMENTS. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO ASK A
QUESTION PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO ON YOUR TOUCH TONE PHONE
YOU MAY REMOVE SYSTEM QUEUE AT
ANY TIME BY PRESSING ONE ZERO
AGAIN. IF USING A SPEAKERPHONE
PLEASE PICK UP THE HAS SUPPORT
PRESS THE NUMBERS. AND WE'LL
START WITH LINE TWENTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MISTER
CHAIRMAN A MEMBER THIS IS BILL
MCGOVERN WITH THE COALITION FOR
CLEAN AIR AND I AGREE WITH
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FRIEDMAN THIS
IS AN EXCITING BUDGET PROPOSAL-
WE WILL GET SO MUCH BENEFIT
FROM THE THOUSAND CLEAN TRUCKS.
THOUSAND TRANSIT BUSES AND
THOUSAND SCHOOL BUSES IN THIS
PLANT SO WE URGE YOU TO SUPPORT
ALL OF THOSE MEDIUM AND HEAVY
DUTY APPLICATIONS WE ALSO OF
SUPPORT FIVE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS FOR THE TRANSPORTATION
EQUITY PROJECTS THAT BRING
CLEAN MOBILITY TO OUR
DISADVANTAGED AND LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES. AND WE AGREED WITH
THE ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL
TO LIMIT THE CLEAN VEHICLE
REBATE PROJECT TO LOW AND
MODERATE INCOME CUSTOMERS AND
THAT'S NOT JUST THOSE THAT ARE
AT OR BELOW THE POVERTY LINE IT
ACTUALLY GOES UP TO FOUR
HUNDRED PERCENT. OF FEDERAL
POVERTY LEVEL- IN THE
TRANSPORTATION BUDGET- WE ALSO
SUPPORT THE PROPOSED
INVESTMENTS IN TRANSIT AND
INTERCITY RAIL. AND IN THE
ACTIVE TRANSPORTATION PROGRAM-
WE THINK WE ACTUALLY COULD GO
UP TO A BILLION DOLLARS TO MEET
THE DEMAND IN ACTIVE
TRANSPORTATION. AND FINALLY AT
DEPARTMENT OF MOTOR VEHICLES WE
SUPPORT THE IMPLEMENTATION OF
THE TRUCKS MARC CHECK HEAVY
DUTY INSPECTION AND MAINTENANCE
PROGRAM WHICH WILL REDUCE TOXIC
DIESEL EXHAUST IN OUR
COMMUNITIES THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. IN MEXICO
LINE TWENTY FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE THIS IS MARGO PARKED
AT THE WESTERN STATES PETROLEUM
ASSOCIATION I'M HERE THIS
AFTERNOON TO COMMENT ON THE
BUDGET TRAILER BILL WHICH I
THINK YOU WILL BE IN GREATER
DETAIL. AT SOME POINT IN THE
NEXT COMING WEEKS BUT THIS
PARTICULAR AND BUDGET TRAILER
BILL FROM THE ADMINISTRATION
ALLOWS THE OFFICE THE BILL
PREVENTION RESPONSE TO INCREASE
AT PER BARREL FEE DEREGULATION
AND THE INDUSTRY IS CERTAINLY
PROUD TO FIND SUPPORT THE
IMPORTANT WORK IS DONE BY OFFER
ABOUT BELIEVE THAT FIFTIETH
ALREADY- IT BETTER LAST AT THE
HANDS OF THE LEGISLATURE
INSTEAD OF THE DEPARTMENT THAT
WE LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUING
THE CONVERSATION- AND UPCOMING
HEARING. THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. NEXT TO A LINE
TWENTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN BLAME
MY NAME IS KIM BOMAR AND I'M
WITH THE SAN FRANCISCO
CONSERVATION CORPS AS THEIR
DIRECTOR OF EVALUATION AND
PLANNING AND WE DID HAVE A
LOCAL COURT MEMBER ONE OF OUR
YOUTH HE WAS ON THE LINE BUT
BECAUSE THE MEETING HAD LAW WE
HAD TO GO TO ANOTHER. OUR
COMMITMENT THAT WE WILL BE
SUBMITTING WRITTEN TESTIMONY
BUT WE DO WANT TO SPEAK WITH
MORE CONCERNED WITH THE BUDGET
REVISION DOES NOT SUPPORT THE
FOURTEEN LOCAL CONSERVATION
CORES- AND THE SAN FRANCISCO
KOR'S IMPAIRING USED TO HELP
OUR COMMUNITY PREPARE FOR
CLIMATE CHANGE AND DROUGHT ONE
MOMENT NEGATIVE IMPACTS ON A
LOT OF ARE YOU FOR WORKING ON.
REMOVING INVASIVE PLANTS
REPLACING EVERY PLAN MADE OF
PLANTS BECAUSE THEY KNOW THAT
THIS WORKS LONG TERM- THEY WANT
TO BE CLIMATE LEADERS AND THEY
WANT TO HELP OTHER LOCAL
COMMUNITY AND THEY ASK THAT
THEY DON'T BE- THEY AND THOSE
LIKE THEM DON'T BE LEFT BEHIND
THE MAJORITY OF OUR CORE
MEMBERS ARE. ALL LOW INCOME
INCOME AND DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES AND WE APPRECIATE
THE SUPPORT AND HELP THERE'S
DIRECT FUNDING FOR THE FOURTEEN
LOCAL CONSERVATION CORPS WHICH
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
THAT WAS A PERFECT ONE MINUTE
AND I AM GOING TO ASK EVERYONE
TO PLEASE. HOLD YOUR COMMENTS
TO ONE MINUTE I AM GOING TO
STOP YOU WENT- THE TIMER
REACHES SAYS SIXTY SECONDS
UNFORTUNATELY WE HAVE OVER
SIXTY PEOPLE WAITING. TO GET
PUBLIC COMMENTS AS OF THIS
MOMENT. AND YOU'D LIKE TO SPEAK
FOR LESS THAN. SECONDS THAT'S.
TOO I WILL GO TO ONE THIRTY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI GOOD
MORNING I'M WILL PAIR IT WITH
THE AMERICAN LUNG ASSOCIATION
LONG ASSOCIATION SUPPORTS THE
TRANSPORTATION PACKAGES FOCUS
ON TRANSIT AND ACTIVE
TRANSPORTATION TO REDUCE
HARMFUL POLLUTANTS. AND BECOME
MILES TRAVELED IN SUPPORT OF
OUR CLEAN AIR AND CLIMATE
STANDARDS. WE AGREED THAT THE
EIGHTY P. PROGRAM COULD BE
POSTED. TWO BILLION DOLLARS TO
ADVANCE THESE EFFORTS. WE ALSO
SUPPORT THE INVESTMENT IN DIEM
BE IMPLEMENTATION OF THE SENATE
BILL TWO TEN HEAVY DUTY TRUCKS-
SMOG CHECK PROGRAM. THIS IS ONE
OF THE MOST IMPACTFUL CLEANER
PROGRAMS ON THE BOOKS AND NEEDS
TO BE ACCELERATED. WITHIN THE
CLIMATE PACKAGE WE'RE VERY
SUPPORTIVE OF THE ONE POINT
FOUR BILLION. ZERO MISSION
GRADE SCHOOL AND TRANSIT BUSES.
OTHER THREE HUNDRED FIFTEEN
MILLION FOR THE CLEAN TRUCK AND
BUS PROGRAM. FIVE MILLION
PRETTY EASY INFRASTRUCTURE
INVESTMENTS AND WE SUPPORT. THE
RE AUTHORIZATION OF THE EIGHTY
EIGHT IN AB ONE EIGHTEEN
CLEANER FUNDING PROGRAMS. LIKE
HOME WHERE THIS YEAR. WE
BELIEVE THAT THE EQUITY BASED
THEIR PROGRAMS COULD INCREASE
TO FIVE HUNDRED MILLION. TO
ENSURE THE CONTINUED SUCCESS OF
KEEP PROGRAMS LIKE CLEAN CARS
FOR ALL. WE ALSO SUPPORT THE
THREE HUNDRED TWENTY FIVE
MILLION FOR EIGHTY SIX ONE
SEVEN. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PROTECTION PROGRAMS. I'M SORRY
HALF AND GIVE UP YES.
APPRECIATE THAT THANK YOU. NEXT
TO ADELINE SIXTEEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU CHAIR BLOOMING
COMMITTEE MEMBER STEVEN MAYER
SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF SOME
RELIANCE ON REGARDING ISSUE FOR.
THIS ISSUE THE INVESTMENT IN A
REVISED PROPOSAL ESPECIALLY THE
SUPPORTER STATE PARKS THE
HUNDRED EIGHTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS FOR DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE WILL ENSURE THAT
OUR PARKS ARE READY TO GREET
THE PUBLIC BETTER THAN EVER
BEFORE. AND A TWO HUNDRED
SEVENTEEN MILLION DOLLARS FOR
FIRE RESTORATION IS CRUCIAL FOR
FIRE DEVASTATED PARTS SUCH AS
BIG BASIN REDWOODS STATE PARK
AMONG THE MANY OTHER STATE
PARKS DAMAGED BY WILDFIRES IN
THE PAST YEAR. ALL THE DEMANDS
ARE GREAT BECAUSE FUNDING IS A
GOOD START TO FUNDING THE WORK
NEEDED TO RESTORE THE NATURAL
LANDSCAPE AND PARK AMENITIES TO
THE FORMER GLORY. AND ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA HABITAT
CONSERVATION PLANNING COALITION
REGARDING ISSUE THREE WE
APPRECIATE THE SIGNIFICANT
INVESTMENTS AND- THE
LEGISLATURE AND THE GOVERNOR'S
FUNDING PLANS FOR NATIONAL
ANTHEM TO DROP OFF. PACKAGES
AND WE URGE THE COMMITTEE TO
ALSO INVEST IN NATURAL
COMMUNITY CONSERVATION PLANTS
AND HABITAT CONSERVATION PLANS
WHICH STREAMLINED
INFRASTRUCTURE DEVELOPMENT IN
EXCHANGE FOR PROTECTING
CRITICAL HABITAT ACROSS THE
STATE. THIS SHULD INCLUDE TWO
HUNDRED BILLION DOLLARS TO THE
WILDLIFE CONSERVATION BOARD TO
CONSERVE NATURAL LANDS WITH ONE
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS
SPECIFICALLY TARGETED TO NINETY
CITIES THANK YOU. THANK YOU
THANK YOU TIME HAS EXPIRED
THANK YOU. THANKS TO A LINE.
NINE PLEASE GO A- I DON'T. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR BLUE AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
MATTHEW COULD STEAL I AM TWENTY
FIVE YEARS OLD AND I AM- CORE
MEMBER WITH THE ORANGE COUNTY
CONSERVATION CORPS IN ANAHEIM
CALIFORNIA. ALTHOUGH THE MAYOR
BY THE GROUP SUPPORT FOR
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT IT DOES
NOT INCLUDE ANY DIRECT-
INVESTMENTS TO THE- TO SUPPORT
TWELVE POINT CAN LOCAL
CONSERVATION CHORDS. LOCAL CORE
PROGRAMS AND POWER YOUNG PEOPLE
LIKE ME THE PART OF THE STATE
TO WORK TO PRIVATE BUYERS
PREPARE FOR DROUGHT HELP OUR
COMMUNITY PREPARE FOR CLIMATE
CHANGE AND MINIMIZE THE
NEGATIVE IMPACTS. I WAS SO
PROUD TO WORK ON EMERGENCY
RELIEF AND RESPONSE SERVICES
FOR MY COMMUNITY DURING THE
DARKEST DAYS OF THE PANDEMIC.
CURRENTLY I'M WORKING ON A PROP
SIXTY EIGHT PROJECT REMOVING
INVASIVE SPECIES FOR HABITAT
RESTORATION. I WANT TO BE A
CLIMATE LEADER AND I WANT TO
HELP MY COMMUNITY. PLEASE DON'T
LEAVE ME AND OTHERS LIKE ME
BEHIND AND INCLUDE DIRECT
FUNDING TO THE LOCAL
CONSERVATION CHORDS MEASURES
BUDGET THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. NATIONAL ALLIANCE FORTY
ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS DEALING
JAFFA BEHALF THE ELECTRIC
VEHICLE CHARGING ASSOCIATION WE
APPRECIATE AND SUPPORT THE
ADMINISTRATION TO START
PROPOSAL TO INCLUDE ONE POINT
EIGHT BILLION DOLLARS PER YEAR
MAKING VEHICLE TECHNOLOGY MORE
SPECIFICALLY WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT THE FIVE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS FOR CLEAN
TRANSPORTATION INFRASTRUCTURE
OPPOSED THE MAY REVISION
ADDITIONALLY WANT TO EMPHASIZE
THE NEED TO ACT NOW AND THE
QUEEN ON THE EIGHTY EIGHT AB
ONE EIGHTEEN RE AUTHORIZATION.
AND SUPPORT THE ADMINISTRATION
PROPOSES THREE AUTHORIZED
EXTEND THE PROGRAM SPENT THAT
FOR ANOTHER TEN YEARS THE QUEEN
TRANSPORTATION PROGRAM IS THE
FLAGSHIP INCENTIVE PROGRAM
THAT'S BEEN CRITICAL TO HELP
EACH YEAR- MISSION VEHICLE
INFRASTRUCTURE MARKET DEVELOP
AND DEPLOY NEW TECHNOLOGY IN
SUPPORT OF THE STATE'S CLIMATE
GOALS. THE INDUSTRY IN THE
STABLE LONG TERM MARKET SIGNAL
FROM THE STATE TO CONTINUE
INVESTING IN AT THE POINTY
TECHNOLOGIES WAITING THREE
AUTHORIZED THE FUNDING UNTIL
LACK MINIX ONLY HAVE A CHILLING
EFFECT ON THE MARKET GROWTH IN
BATMAN THE STATE WHICH WILL
ONLY UNDERMINE THAT STATE GOALS
FINALLY WE APPRECIATE THE
ADMINISTRATION INCLUDING STEVE
EUROPEAN EQUITY FUNDING I WOULD
LIKE TO ENSURE THAT LIGHT DUTY
VEHICLE FUNDING BE MAINTAINED
THROUGHOUT THE BUDGET
DISCUSSION. WE THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME AND LOOK FORWARD TO
DISCUSSIONS. OF THE NETWORK
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. YES GOOD
FOR FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS BRANDON TO
LIKE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA AIR POLLUTION
CONTROL OFFICERS ASSOCIATION
SIGNIFICANT INCENTIVE FUNDING
IS CRITICAL FOR MEETING HELP
BASED ATTAINMENT STANDARDS
CELEBRATING YOUR TERM EMISSIONS
REDUCTIONS IN IMPROVING PUBLIC
HEALTH MORE QUICKLY WE SUPPORT
THE EXTENSION OF AB A CLEANER
PROGRAM FUNDING WHICH INCLUDES
A CALL MORE PROGRAM IN EIGHTY
NINE TWENTY THREE LOCAL
INCENTIVES PROGRAM. AND URGING
APPROVAL THIS YEAR TO ALLOW FOR
PROGRAMS TO CONTINUE SEAMLESSLY
BETTER INFORMED STATE
IMPLEMENTATION PLAN DEVELOPMENT
AND BUSINESS AND MARKET
CERTAINTY WE APPRECIATE THAT
THE MAY REVISION PROVIDES TWO
HUNDRED SIXTY FIVE MILLION FOR
THE EIGHTY SIX SEVENTEEN
COMMUNITY ARE PROTECTION
PROGRAM INCENTIVES AND TURNING
THIRTY MILLION FOR THE PHARMA
PROGRAM IN TWENTY ONE TWENTY
TWO AND. HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION
IN TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE
HOWEVER. GIVEN THE BUDGET
SURPLUS IN THE INTERIM MEETING
URGE YOU INCREASE THE SPENDING
LEVELS- LAST WEEK PUSHING
RETENTION OF THAT FIFTY MILLION
FOR AND DISTRICT AB SIX
SEVENTEEN IMPLEMENTATION FROM
THE GOVERNOR'S JANUARY BUDGET.
UNFORTUNATELY THE AMOUNT DOES
NOT COVER CURRENT COSTS ARE
ACCOUNT FOR NEW COMMUNITIES
ADDED TO THE STATE MANDATED
PROGRAM AND I DID WANT TO
MENTION SUPPORT FOR THE SENATE
FUNDING FOR THE RESIDENTIAL
WOOD SMOKE REDUCTION PROGRAM
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. FOR NEXT
TO A LINE THIRTY FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THE NEW HAMPSHIRE BLOOM
RECALL MONSTER NOT A WITH THE
TRUST FOR PUBLIC LAND MY
COMMENTS ARE ON THE EXTREME
HEAT PORTION OF THE PROJECT- I
THINK THE NUMBER ONE ARE
CLIMATE DRIVEN THREAT TO OUR
RESIDENTS AND OUR RESIDENTS ARE
IMMEDIATE PERIL WE SUPPORT. THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL FOR TWO
HUNDRED MILLION FOR URBAN
GREENING WE ASK THAT YOUR
COMMITTEE- INCREASE THE AMOUNT
OF FUNDING TO URBAN FORESTRY AT
TWO HUNDRED MILLION AND TO
INCREASE THE AB THIRTY ONE
LOCAL PARK TO MATCH AB FIFTEEN
HUNDRED AND AT FOUR HUNDRED
MILLION. ALL OF THESE ARE
EXTREME HEAT PROGRAMS THEY'RE
ALL EXISTING PROGRAMS THEY'VE
ALL BEEN OVERSUBSCRIBED EIGHT
EIGHT CONTENT ALL THERE ARE
PROJECTS PROJECTS THAT ARE
READY TO GO NOW- THEIR MULTI
BENEFIT WE ARE BANNED BONTA
PENDANT HISTORICALLY THIS IS A
ONE TIME OPPORTUNITY TO CATCH
UP ON THE DEATHLY- INJUSTICE
AND OUR OUR HI DENSELY
POPULATED LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES. AND PREPARE THEM
FOR EXTREME HEAT THAT AS
SECRETARY CORPORATE THAT. THANK
YOU HERE AND GETTING WORSE.
ZERO ONE FIFTY PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI GOOD AFTERNOON NATALIE NOT
GOING TO HAVE TO SAVE THE
REDWOODS LEAGUE WE ARE PLEASED
TO SEE THE NAY REVISED PROPOSAL
AND IN PARTICULAR THE
INVESTMENT FOR THE QUARTER
STATE PARKING POOREST THE FIRST
ONE I CALLED THE HUNDRED EIGHTY
FIVE MILLION TO ADDRESS
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE IN THE
TWENTY SEVENTEEN MILLION FOR
FIRE RESTORATION OF A JUMPSTART
MATH OF WORK WE NEED TO DO TO
RESTORE PROPERTY. AT THE BIG
BASIN REDWOODS STATE PARK AND
MANY OTHERS ADDITIONALLY WE
WOULD ENCOURAGE GIVEN THE
DEPARTMENT FLEXIBILITY
DISCRETION A TARGET FUNDING FOR
MUCH NEEDED ACQUISITIONS AND
SUPPORT HEALTHY PARK SYSTEMS
AND ON BEHALF OF MY INTERESTS
AND COULD COUNTY IN THAT
CONNECTOR WHICH OPEN SPACE
DISTRICT WANT TO THE COURT NAY
REBEKAH PRESSON INVESTMENT IN
NATURAL RESOURCES IF WE WANT TO
CALL UP FOR THE TWO HUNDRED
THIRTY MILLION FOR THE BY THE
COURT OCEAN FISH PACKAGE
PROGRAM. THIS IS A CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT FUNDING A DEPUTY TOOK
PROGRAM CURRENTLY OF THE LOW
AND THE NEED TO CURRENTLY HI
GOOD APPALACHIAN COURAGE AN
INCREASE FUNDING TO CLOSE THE.
CONSERVANCY THANK YOU. NEXT TO
A LINE FIFTEEN. PLEASE GO AHEAD.
NUMBER SHE NEEDS HELP FINDING
COMMENT ON BEHALF OF NUMBER OF.
ON BEHALF OF THE DEFENSE I'D
LIKE TO SUPPORT THE INVESTMENT
PROPOSED IN THE NAY REVISION
FOR DROP AND RESILIENCY AND
MORE SPECIFICALLY THE FIVE
HUNDRED MILLION PROPOSED FOR
THE MULTI BENEFIT ME AND
REPUBLICAN PROGRAM AT YOUR FEET
WHICH WILL HELP ENSURE
SUCCESSFUL IMPLEMENTATION OF
SIGNAL WHILE SUPPORTING FARMERS
INCLUDING MULTIPLE CONNECTICUT.
ON BEHALF OF THE PARK NOW
COALITION MEMBERS INCLUDING
LATINO OUTDOORS AN ASSAULT I
WANTED EXPRESSED APPRECIATION
FOR THE PRIORITIZE ATION ABOUT
HER ACCENT IF THE TYPICALLY THE
PROPOSED FORTY MILLION FOR THE
OUTER EQUITY GRANTS PROGRAM
CAN'T FOURTEEN MILLION PHOENIX
BY THE COAST PROGRAMS FOR ALL
THE SUPPORT OF THE OF THE ONE
HUNDRED TWENTY FIVE MILLION FOR
THE STATEWIDE PARKS PROGRAMS
BUT RECOGNIZING THAT THE LAST
ELICITATION OF THE PROGRAM HAD
A TOTAL OF THREE HUNDRED NINETY
FIVE MILLION. WE WANT TO
HIGHLIGHT THAT ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES ARE NEEDED TO SATISFY
THE DEMAND WHAT WE ON BEHALF OF
ITS WILL INDEPENDENTLY WEALTHY
SUPPORT THE TWO HUNDRED MILLION
TO OPC AND A HUNDRED AND ELEVEN
POINT FIVE MILLION TO STATE
PARKS FOR C. LEVEL RIGHT- GIVEN
THAT BUDGET SURPLUS WERE
DISAPPOINTED WITH THE ABSENCE
OF RESOURCES FOR THE COASTAL
COMMISSION AND SPECIFICALLY FOR
THE HEALTHY PC LEVEL RIGHT
ADAPTATION GRANT PROGRAM IN THE
WELL CAL GRANT PROGRAMS. AND WE
HOPE THAT THE LEGISLATURE WILL
COMPENSATE FOR THE LACK OF
INVESTMENT I ALSO REALLY THINK
WE WANT TO CHIME IN FOR RELIEF
ENTRY PEOPLE AND ALIGN THEIR
COMMENTS WITH PPL IN CASE
THEY'RE NOT ABLE TO BE HEARD.
IN THE HEARING THANK YOU THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. TO ADELINE FIFTY
SEVENTY GO AHEAD. I MEMBERS
WRITING- OKAY WE CONCERNED
ABOUT THE DEPARTMENT BACKED UP
WITH THE PEOPLE AT THE KEY TO
REFORM THE AGENCY TO BE MORE
RESPONSIVE THE DEPLORABLE G. I
LOVE MY FAMILY ACT YOUNG
CHILDREN IN EUROPE VOEPEL GOT
BETTER TO BUILD YOU THAT THEN
YOU'RE GOING TO THE DOCTOR
WELCOME. RIGHT RIGHT FRIEDMAN
ELEMENTARY SCHOOL AND IN THE
GALLERY YET. THERE ARE FIVE IS
THE BEST. YES I THINK WE NOTIFY
THE COMMUNITY ABOUT PLANTS
REMOVED BUT- BLOCK OIL BACK BUT-
ANY OTHER PARTS SIGNATURE. I DO
NOT ANSWER ALL THE PROBLEMS
THAT SUBMITTED BY. IF YOU NEED
TO GET THE LOCAL YOU KNOW BUT
IF THEY OPEN THE SCHOOL
DISTRICT CITY OF IN A AND LOCAL
HEALTH AUTHORITY OF THE PUBLIC.
ARE YOU ALL CLOSE DGFT FOR. ONE
THANK YOU OUR- AND PROCEDURE.
FOR CLEAN UP ESPECIALLY NEXT
YEAR. OTHER A EITHER REAL BIG.
OF THE TACTICS. REVOKED NOTICE
OF COLLECTION EBOOK. IT WILL
GIVE OUR COMMUNITY OLDEST CITY
PROPERTY CRIME COMMENT. IT'S
THE SHORE COME IN THEIR
DECISION. GOOD AFTERNOON SAVE
ROOM- MEMBERS DRAWN TO BROWN
SAN JOSE NOT CREATION. PLEASE
CONSIDER SUSPENDING ANY FURTHER
PROFILE NAY BOND ALLOCATIONS
AND GIVEN THE FOLLOWING PHONE
FULL CONDITIONS ARE MET NUMBER
ONE. THAT THE AUTHORITY RESTORE
OLD BOARD AND COMMITTEE
MATERIALS PRIOR TO JANUARY
TWENTY EIGHTEEN. NUMBER TWO
THAT THE AUTHORITY RESTORE ALL
ENVIRONMENTAL DOCUMENTS
INCLUDING THE PROGRAM E. IR
FILTER IN THE TEASE ANALYSIS.
NUMBER THREE THAT THE AUTHORITY
IMMEDIATELY STOP ALL PLANNING
AND DEVELOPMENT WITH EXCEPTION
OF THE FOLLOWING KALRA BILLS.
SAN FRANCISCO TO GILROY
SACRAMENTO TO BAKERSFIELD AND
BURBANK TO ANAHEIM AND FINALLY.
ALLOCATE FIVE MILLION DOLLARS
TO THE METROPOLITAN
TRANSPORTATION COMMISSION. TO
STUDY THE ALIGNMENT BETWEEN
ZERO AND FRESNO AND PREPARE A
REPORT FOR REVIEW ABOUT THE
LEGISLATURE DLA- AND THE
GENERAL PUBLIC THANK YOU. AN
ACTUAL LINE ONE HUNDRED PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIR BLOOMING COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MY NAME IS SAMANTHA YES
I'M A CORE MEMBER WITH THE
CENTER OF THE CONSERVATION
CORPS IN CHARTER SCHOOL.
ALTHOUGH THE MAY REVISE
INCLUDES SUPPORT FOR WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT IT DOES NOT INCLUDE
DIRECT INVESTMENTS TO SUPPORT
THE FOURTEEN LOCAL CONSERVATION
COLORS. MOBILE CORE PROGRAMS
EMPOWER YOUNG PEOPLE LIKE ME TO
BE PART OF THE STATE'S WORK TO
PROVIDE SAFE AND CLEAN GREEN
SPACE FOR ITS CONSTITUENTS. I
AM THE SENIOR COOLEY FOR ATP
TRAIL SAFETY GROUP BUT THE
WORKING TIRELESSLY TO COMBAT
THE IMMENSE AMOUNT OF TRASH IN
BIO HAZARDS. THAT HAVE
ACCUMULATED OTHER CITIES TRAILS
AND BIKE CORRIDORS. CAL USES
RISING IN OUR PRESENCE HAS
ALREADY BEEN NOTICED AND LAUDED
BY THE PUBLIC DIRECT FUNDING
WOULD GREATLY CONTRIBUTE TO OUR
MISSION. AND PROVIDE US WITH
THE NECESSARY TOOLS AND PPE TO
KEEP OUR CORE MEMBER STATES. I
WANT TO HELP MY COMMUNITY AND
HOME TOWN BETTER PREPARE AND
ADAPT TO THE ONGOING EFFECTS OF
CLIMATE CHANGE WE WILL BE
EXPERIENCING IN THE VERY NEAR
FUTURE. AND TO THE CORE I HAVE
BEEN ABLE TO. PLEASE DON'T
LEAVE ME AND OTHERS LIKE ME
BEHIND AND COULD DIRECT FUNDING
TO THE LOCAL CONSERVATION.
CORPS IN THIS YEAR'S BUDGET
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME. THANK
YOU. AN OVER THE LINE EIGHTY
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. I THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TODAY
MY NAME IS RYAN MCCAULEY
SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF CAME
TRAINED CALTRAIN AND SAN MATTEO
COUNTY TANSPORTATION AUTHORITY
WE STRONGLY SUPPORT THE
ADMINISTRATION SIGNIFICANT
PROPOSED INVESTMENT IN
TRANSPORTATION INVESTMENT WILL
MODERNIZE OUR RAIL NETWORK
TRANSACTION IN ZERO EMISSION
BUSES AND EXPAND ON ACTIVE
TRANSPORTATION PROGRAMS THAT
THERE'S MUCH WORK TO BE DONE IN
THE BAY AREA. WE ARE ALSO IN
SUPPORT OF THE CONTINUATION OF
HIGH SPEED RAIL IN THE VALLEY
AND EXPENDITURE PROP ONE EIGHT
FOR THIS PURPOSE. THANK YOU WE
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
THE ADMINISTRATION AND THE
LEGISLATURE AS WE DELIVER ON
THESE CRITICAL TRANSPORTATION
PRIORITIES. THANK YOU. OPERATOR.
ONE EIGHTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI THIS IS TIFFANY MARC ON
BEHALF OF THE COMMUNITY
ALLIANCE WITH FAMILY FARMERS
KEVIN TO THE ETHICALLY SUPPORTS
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL TO
INVEST NEARLY ONE BILLION IN
NEW FUNDING AIMED AT SUPPORTING
IN TRANSITIONING TO SUSTAINABLE
AGRICULTURE INCLUDING
ADDITIONAL FUNDING FOR
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE FOR
UNDERSERVED FARMERS FARM TO
SCHOOL AND CLIMATE SMART
PROGRAM. SUITE AND A M. AND P.
AS WELL AS NEW FUNDING FOR
URBAN AGRICULTURE BEGINNING
FARMERS AND FARM WORKER
TRAINING PROGRAMS AND STATEWIDE
PESTICIDE NETWORK I'LL BE HAPPY
EIGHT THOUSAND SMALL MID SIZED
FARMER. WE ALSO URGE YOU TO
MAKE INVESTMENTS IN REGIONAL
FOOD HUBS THIS IS PM MESSAGE
BEGINNING FARMERS TRAINING TOOL
LIBRARIES AND WE HOPE TO HELP
THESE URBAN TO RURAL FARMERS
ACCESS TO EQUIPMENT WITH THOSE
TOOL AVERAGE. THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU EXCELLENT SEVENTY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
DANIEL BROWN ON BEHALF OF
SIERRA CLUB CALIFORNIA THE PLAN
TO SUBMIT A DETAILED COMMENT
MATTER SHORTLY FOLLOWING THE
ADJOURNMENT OF THIS COMMITTEE
STOP FOCUS PLEASE COMMENT ON
THE GOVERNOR'S CLEAN
TRANSPORTATION PROPOSAL. WE'RE
VERY SUPPORTIVE OF THIS
PROPOSAL ESPECIALLY THE TESTING
THAT THEY CAN'T INVESTMENT AND
THERE ARE MENTIONED HEAVY DUTY
VEHICLES AND ELECTRIC VEHICLE
CHARGING INFRASTRUCTURE. I
THINK POSSIBILE TRUCKS WITH
ZERO EMISSION VEHICLES WILL
MEAN CLEANER AIR FOR
COMMUNITIES WHO HAVE BEEN OVER
BURDENED BY TOXIC AIR FOR FAR
TOO LONG. THE STATE CANNOT
AFFORD. TO SETTLE FOR HALF
MEASURES LIKE SO CALLED NEAR
ZERO VEHICLES WHEN THE MAJORITY
OF CALIFORNIANS STILL BAD AND
NON ATTAINMENT AREAS FOR TOXIC.
POLLUTANTS INVESTMENT IN
CHARGING INFRASTRUCTURE WILL
REMOVE ONE OF THE LARGEST
REMAINING BARRIERS TO
WIDESPREAD ELECTRIC VEHICLE.
ADOPTION AS LIGHT DUTY ELECTRIC
VEHICLES QUICKLY APPROACHING
PRICE PARITY WITH COMBUSTION
CARS FINALLY THE LEGISLATURE
SHOULD EXTEND AB EIGHT SEATS
WHICH WILL GUARANTEE LONG TERM
FUNDING FOR KEY CLEAN
TRANSPORTATION PROGRAM. WE LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THE
LEGISLATURE TO ADVANTAGE
PROPOSAL AND TO REFINE OTHER
PORTIONS OF THE BUDGET WE
IDENTIFY A PATTERN THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. NEXT WOULD ALIGN
NINETY PLEASE GO AHEAD. FIFTEEN
MARK ON BEHALF OF THE FED UP
WITH THE SAFETY WHICH HAS MORE
THAN TWENTY YEARS IN PART
PEOPLE ORDERED FARMERS AND
PROTECTED EARTH FROM HARMFUL
IMPACT OF INDUSTRIAL
AGRICULTURE IMPLEMENTED ORGANIC
AND REGENERATIVE FARMING
PRACTICES THAT OUR PUBLIC
ENVIRONMENTAL. WORK WITH.
SUPPORTS THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL AIMED AT SUPPORTING
TRANSITION TO SUSTAINABLE
AGRICULTURE INCLUDING INCREASED
SUPPORT FOR TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE FOR UNDERSERVED
FARMERS. FARMERS WILL PROGRAMS
HEALTHY SOIL AND NEW INVESTMENT
IN THE STATE WIDE CUSTOM. I
THEY NOTIFICATION NETWORK AND
TO IMPROVE POLLINATOR HABITAT
WE URGE CAUTION INVOLUNTARY
DIGEST THERE'S BECAUSE OF THEIR
POLLUTING NATURE AND HOW THEY
DO NOTHING TO REDUCE AIR AND
WATER POLLUTION AND
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES WHERE
THEY ARE OFTEN LOCATED. FINALLY
WE BELIEVE THE PROPOSED FUNDING
FOR ALTERNATIVE MIDWIVES COULD
BE USED INSTEAD TO SUPPORT
FARMERS PRODUCING ORGANIC
PRODUCE WHOLE GRAINS LEGUMES
AND VEGETABLES THAT ARE
HEALTHIER AND MORE NUTRITIOUS
THANK YOU SO MUCH. MEXICO ONE
FIFTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. AT
MEDICARE MEMBERS THIS IS JULIE
MALINOVSKY BALL ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA ELECTRIC
TRANSPORTATION COALITION CAL
ETT IS PLEASED TO SEE THE MAY
REVIVE- PUT SIGNIFICANTLY
HISTORICAL MORE MONEY INTO
EXPANDING ACCESSIBILITY TED BAD
AND THAT THAT THE STRUCTURE FOR
ALL CALIFORNIANS. KELLY DC DOES
THOUGH SHARE THE CHAIR THAN
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MOLLAND CONCERN
WITH THE CD R. P. PROPOSAL AND
TWO POINT. FOR ALL THOSE THAT
STRATEGY DOCUMENTS THAT THE
STATE HAS INDICATE THE NEED
RECEIVE THE RP IS CLOSER TO THE
TWO HUNDRED MILLION A YEAR
RANGE. AT A MINIMUM FOR THREE
YEARS. SECOND LEAVING OUT
MIDDLE INCOME FOR CD R. P. AT
THIS EARLY STAGE IN MARKET
DEVELOPMENT IS AN ADEQUATE
ROUGHLY A HUNDRED AND FIFTY
THOUSAND TEN MAYBE TWO HUNDRED
TWENTY THOUSAND MIDDLE CLASS
APPLICANTS. WILL BE EXCLUDED
WITH THE PROPOSED ALLEN MY
LIMITATION AND FINALLY JUST
WANNA REMIND THE COMMITTEE THAT
THAT THAT PACKAGE IS INCOMPLETE
WITHOUT THE LEGISLATURE THREE
AUTHORIZATION AT EIGHTY EIGHT
FEET. AND HER CONTENT ASSEMBLY
MEMBER SMITH YOU'RE ASKING
GENERAL FUND OR SHORT TERM AB
EIGHT FEEDS ARE LONG TERM
INVESTMENTS AND PROVIDE MARKET
CERTAINTY WE ENCOURAGE THE
LEGISLATURE THE PATH ABOUT HIS
TRAILER BILL WITH THE BUDGET
ENGINE THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. NEXT A LITTLE ONE NINETY
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS ALAN APPS
WITH THE BAY AREA AIR QUALITY
MANAGEMENT DISTRICT SPEAKING IN
SUPPORT OF THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL FOR VARIOUS ZERO
EMISSION PROGRAMS. CLEAN
TRANSPORTATION IN EQUITY
PROGRAMS AND THE RE
AUTHORIZATION OF AB EIGHT WHICH
INCLUDES THE CARL MOYER PROGRAM
ONE SHORTFALL IN THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL HOWEVER IS FUNDING TO
IMPLEMENT THE AB SIX SEVENTEEN
COMMUNITY AIR PROTECTION
PROGRAM FUNDING FOR
IMPLEMENTATION IS REMAIN FLAT
FOR YEARS WHILE COMMUNITY
SUPPORTED BY THE PROGRAM HAVE
INCREASED BY FIFTY PERCENT. AND
WILL CONTINUE TO BE ADDED WE
REQUEST THAT FUNDING FOR THIS
VITAL PROGRAM BE INCREASE CAN
BE SUPPORTED WITH MULTI YEAR
FUNDING COMMITMENTS SIMILAR TO
OTHER PROGRAMS IMPORTANT TO THE
ADMINISTRATION AND LEGISLATURE
THANK YOU. NOW GO TO LINE
NINETY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS VINCENT
WERE AT MY JOB WITH THE CLIMATE
SECTOR HERE TO TALK ABOUT
COMMUNITY RESILIENCE WERE
LARGELY SUPPORTIVE IN CONCEPT
OF THEIR ALLOCATION THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET FOR COMMUNITY
RESILIENCE. BUT WE BELIEVE THAT
MORE SPECIFICITY AROUND
UTILIZING CLEAN DISTRIBUTED
ENERGY COMPULSORILY HIS NATIVE
WE SUGGEST THAT THE ASSEMBLY
ENSURE THAT AT LEAST TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS
THESE FUNDS GO TOWARDS NAY
ENERGY RESILIENCE PLANNING FOR
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS- THESE PLANS
SHOULD FOCUS ON UTILIZING CLEAN
B. R. SUBCOMMITTEE FOR. ON THAT
AS WELL OTHER QUICK OUTAGE
EVENTS WE'D ALSO LIKE TO ALIGN
OURSELVES WITH THE COMMENT THAT
COALITION IN ARAB PART BORROW
COLLEAGUES PROVIDED REGARDING
THE GOVERNOR'S TRANSPORTATION.
PACKAGE THANK YOU FOR
CONSIDERATION. ANNEXING ALIGNED
FOUR PLEASE GO A- SHE SAID
AFTER MR CHAIRMAN NOEL CREAMERS
PLANE IN COMPUTE I WANT TO
EXPRESS OUR APPRECIATION FOR
THE ADMINISTRATION THE LAST MAN
AND CLIMATE SMART PRACTICES AND
CLIMATE RESILIENCE PRACTICES
IN. THE BUDGET. HOWEVER THERE'S
MUCH MORE INVESTMENT NEEDED FOR
FUEL PRODUCTION AND POST FIRE
RECOVERY WORK CALIFORNIA'S
WINERIES AND VINEYARDS HAVE
SEEN A SIGNIFICANT IMPACTS FROM
WILDFIRES OVER RECENT YEARS.
AND MUCH MORE WORK IS NEEDED TO
REDUCE THE RISK OF CATASTROPHIC
WILDFIRES WITH THAT IN MIND WE
SUPPORT THE WILDFIRE AND FOREST
RESILIENCE EXPENDITURE PLANS.
AND WE ALSO SUPPORT THAT THE
PRODUCTION INVESTMENT PROGRAM
AT CALIFORNIA ENERGY COMMISSION
AS WELL AS PDF EIGHT HEALTHY
SOIL AND SWEET FUNDING INCLUDED
IN THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET. THANK
YOU THANK YOU. NEXT WE GO TO
LINE TWENTY PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU CHAIRMAN WHEN THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
LYLE ABRAMS REPRESENTING
TREEPEOPLE YOU PREACH IT AND
THEY REVISED FUNDING TO URBAN
GREENING PROGRAM AND FORMALLY
COMMITTEES AT APPROPRIATE
LEVELS HE'S PROGRAMS PROVIDE
MULTI BENEFITS DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES AND SUPPORT NATURE
BASED SOLUTIONS. HOWEVER WE ARE
EXTREMELY DISAPPOINTED THAT THE
DOCTORS BEST AND PROPOSED BY
THE ADMINISTRATION. URBAN
TWENTY FOUR SHE PROGRAM IS
HIGHLY FOR SUCCESSFUL PROGRAM
IS THE PRIMARY SOURCE OF
FUNDING FOR COMMUNITY BASED
PROJECTS FOR COMBATING EXTREME
HEAT SHE PLANTING AND IS A
PRIORITY FOR NONPROFIT
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE GROUPS
INCLUDING TREAT PEOPLE. AS YOU
KNOW EXTREME HE ALLED MORE
DEATHS IN THE U. S. AND ALL
OTHER WEATHER RELATED CAUSES
COMBINED BUT HERE THE FACT YOU
MIGHT NOT KNOW SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA IS THE ONLY PLACE IN
THE NATION WORKING RELATED
DEATHS OCCUR DURING WINTER
MONTHS A COMPREHENSIVE APPROACH
TO COMBAT OUR CLIMATE CRISIS
SHOULD BEGIN WITH INTEGRATING
PRIORITY PROGRAMS LIKE HOW
PLAYERS URBAN AND COMMUNITY.
FORESTRY PROGRAM FOR THESE
REASONS WE URGE YOU TO JOIN
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CRISTINA GARCIA
THE PROPOSAL FOR URBAN GREENING
AND TAKING EQUAL FUNDING FOR
URBAN FORESTRY. AT TWO HUNDRED
MILLION THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
AND NEXT LINE ONE OF PLEASE GO
THIS IS MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE NAME IS BILL GAINES
I'M SPEAKING TODAY ON BEHALF OF
THE WILD SHEEP FOUNDATION THE
CALIFORNIA DEER ASSOCIATION
ROCKY MOUNTAIN ELK FOUNDATION
OF NINE OTHER WILDLIFE
CONSERVATION ORGANIZATIONS WE
ARE PLEASED TO SUPPORT THE
ADDITIONAL FUNDING REQUESTED
FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND
WILDLIFE AND THE MANY REVISED
BUT WE STRONGLY URGE THE
SUBCOMMITTEE TO RECOMMEND
ADMITTING THIS PROPOSED BUDGET
BY AN ADDITIONAL TWO MILLION
DOLLARS TO ALLOW FOR FULL
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE
DEPARTMENT'S WILDLIFE VEHICLE
COLLISION DATA COLLECTION
PROGRAM PURSUANT TO FISHING
GAME CODE SECTION THIRTEEN
TWENTY THREE AND TWO THOUSAND
POINT SIX. THESE ADDITIONAL
DOLLARS ARE CRITICAL TO THE
DEPARTMENT ABILITY TO
EFFICIENTLY GATHER DATA ON HOT
SPOTS FOR WILDLIFE VEHICLE
COLLISIONS IN ORDER TO IDENTIFY
THE MOST AFFECTED LOCATIONS FOR
RESTORING HABITAT CONNECTIVITY.
ACROSS CALIFORNIA'S ROADWAYS.
BUT THE PLACEMENT THE WILDLY
PROBABLY CROSSING NOT ONLY
CRITICS BUT HEALTH OF MY
OUTLINES IN A VARIETY OF OTHERS
BE. BUT ALSO TO THE IMPROVE
SAFETY OF CALIFORNIA'S PUBLIC
ON OUR ROADWAYS THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU. YES A LITTLE
LINE ONE OH SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. PICTURE MEMBERS WE'RE
GOING TO SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA RIFLE PISTOL
SOLUTION ASIAN AND OUR THIRTY
THOUSAND MEMBERS STATEWIDE
PERFECT TIMING I JUST LIKE TO
ECHO WHAT MISTER GAINES SAID WE
ARE HUGE SUPPORT OF THE
AUGMENTATION OF COMPETITION
WHILE I. HAVEN'T BEEN A GAME
WARDEN FOR TWENTY SEVEN YEARS I
KNOW THE DEPARTMENT SITUATION.
IN UNDERSTAFFED AND UNDERFUNDED
HIS ROUTINE DOING MORE WITH
LESS MONEY FOR THE WILDLIFE
OVERCROWDING THAT OUTLINED HIS
POLITICAL GROUP. PROPER
PLACEMENT OF THESE VERY
ESSENTIAL WILDLIFE CROSSINGS TO
MAKE TRAFFIC SAFER PROMOTE
HUMANS AND WILDLIFE. SO VERY
MUCH APPRECIATE THE TIME AND-
REALLY REQUESTING ADDITIONAL
SUPPORT FOR FISHING GAME
PROTECTION. TEN TWENTY THREE
AND TWO THOUSAND POINT SIX
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. NEXT IN
LINE ONE SIXTEEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MEMBERS
ONLY TO RURAL ON BEHALF OF THE
CAL TROUT TRUMPETED APPRECIATE
THE EMPHASIS ON FISH WILDLIFE
METROPOLIS IT MAY RESIDE
ACTUALLY THE NEED FOR
MONITORING WE DID NOT HOWEVER
TEETH EXTENDING CALLED OUT THE
COSTA MONITORING PROGRAM IN THE
NEGOTIATIONS WOULD LOVE TO SEE
THAT INCLUDED THE TOTAL PACKAGE
ON THAT THE NPA COMPARABLE
COMPREHENSIVE PROGRAM TO
PROVIDE COMPLETE UNDERSTANDING
OF CALIFORNIA SENATE BILL HAD.
POPULATIONS AND THE PROGRAM IS
CURRENTLY ENTIRELY UNFOUNDED
AND WITHOUT ALTERNATE FUNDING
FOR A NUMBER OF MODERATION WILL
BE ABANDONED IF YOU'RE NOT
EASILY BE RESTARTED EXACTLY
CRITICAL PROGRAM WE LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUING THE.
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT WHICH I
THINK YOU KNOW. THANK YOU. AND
NEXT LINE ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
SO CRAP ON THE SOUTH COAST
REGION D. GOOD AFTERNOON THE
SOUTH COAST FACES ENORMOUS
CHALLENGES ABUSING AIR
POLLUTION AND TOPICS TO PROTECT
PUBLIC HEALTH EXPRESS THE
INTERVENTION CAN YOU. REALLY
67% AND DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES IN THE STATE ARE IN
THE SOUTH COAST SIGNIFICANT
SUSTAINABLE INCENTIVE FUNDING
IS CRITICAL FOR MEETING HELP
PLEASE FEDERAL AIR QUALITY
STANDARDS TO FACILITATE
CRITICAL NEAR TERM EMISSION
REDUCTIONS THANK YOU TO THE
REMEMBER FRIEDMAN PROCESSING
THE NEED FOR BOTH ZERO AND NEAR
ZERO EMISSION TECHNOLOGY TO
ACHIEVE BOTH NEAR TERM AND LONG
TERM EMISSION REDUCTION. SOUTH
OF THE STATE INCLUDING FEDERAL
DEADLINES REDUCE AIR POLLUTION
AND IF NOTMET THE INTO DOLLARS
INSPECTIONS RESTRICTIONS ON
BUSINESS AND A FEDERAL TAKEOVER
COULD OCCUR SOUTH COAST URGENT
EXTENSION OF AIR QUALITY
FUNDING PREVIOUSLY REAUTHORIZED
BY EIGHTY EIGHT TEST YET
RELATES TO THE COLD WATER
PROGRAM EXTENSION NOW PROVIDES
PROGRAM STABILITY YOU CAN HELP
ENSURE PRIVATE INVESTMENT. IN
TECHNOLOGY- WE APPRECIATE
FUNDING FOR SIX A BI SEVENTY.
SINCE HOWEVER AFTER YOU
INCREASE FUNDING TO PRIOR TO
NEAR TERM A MEASURE THAT. SB
SIX IT'LL- FUNDING FOR AIR
RESEARCH THAT INCREASE FUNDING
TO COVER ACTUAL PROGRAM COSTS
THANK YOU THANK YOU. AND NEXT A
LITTLE LINE ONE OF THREE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MIGHT
BE CONFIDENT OF THE
METROPOLITAN WATER DISTRICT OF
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA AND I'LL
ALSO BE SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF
THE STATE WATER CONTRACTORS.
FIRST WE APPRECIATE THE
GOVERNOR'S NAME IF I THINK
ABOUT THE SENATE BUDGET PLAN
THAT WOULD MAKE ESSENTIAL
INVESTMENT IN CLINICAL PLANT
WATER INFRASTRUCTURE AND DROP
THE SPOT. METROPOLITAN THE
CONTRACTORS ALSO SUPPORT THE
PROPOSED SPENDING IN THE MAYBE
BY PROVISIONAL WATER CONNECTING
NATURE BASED SOLUTIONS AND
WE'LL FOLLOW UP WITH MORE CAL
COMMENT ST STE AND SPEAKING
JUST FOR METROPOLITAN WE
SUPPORT THE FUNDING IN A
REVISED FOR DRINKING WATER. AND
WASTEWATER INFRASTRUCTURE BUT
WITH RESPECTFULLY REQUEST MONTH
ANY DECIDED I COULD RECYCLE
WATER PROJECTS AND P. FIVE
GROUND WATER TREATMENT WHICH IS
A GROWING ISSUE PERCENT IN
CALIFORNIA WE ARE WORKING ON
PUTTING TOGETHER A CURRENT LIST
OF PROJECTS AND FUNDING NEEDS
AND THEY'LL COME UP WITH MORE
DETAILED COMMENTS. SHOULD I
THINK OVER THERE WELL THAT'S
RIGHT BUDGET PROPOSAL BEFORE
THE LEGISLATURE FOR
CONSIDERATION AND APPRECIATE.
THE ASSEMBLY THANK. THANK YOU.
AND NEXT WITH A LINE. ONE
EIGHTEEN GO AHEAD. SHE GET
AFTERNOON MISTER KAREN MEMBERS
JENNIFER FOR THE CALIFORNIA
CITY OF MUSEUMS AND ALSO THE
OPENING OF THE M. OAKLAND DO
AND THE CALIFORNIA ACADEMY OF
SCIENCES. ALONG WITH MORE THAN
FIVE HUNDRED STATE AND LOCAL
ORGANIZATIONS BUSINESSES AND
LOCAL GOVERNMENT AND TRIBAL
LEADERS THEY'RE REQUESTING ONE
BILLION DOLLARS TO BE SPENT
OVER FOUR YEARS TO SUPPORT
CALIFORNIA'S ARTS CULTURE AND
CREATIVITY FACTOR. THAT ATKINS
CHAMPIONED BY YOURSELF THREE
COLLEAGUE ASSEMBLYMEMBER
FRIEDMAN ALONG THE NETWORK SO
THAT MISTER NAZARIAN AND
SENATORS ALLEN AND RUBIO MUCH
THANKS TO MISTER BENNETT FOR
YOUR SUPPORT OF COMMENT EARLIER
TWO HUNDRED AND FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS FOR THE CALIFORNIA
CULTURAL HISTORICAL AND DOWNEY
CREATED IN TWO THOUSAND THREE
AND HOUSED IN A RESOURCE.
AGENCY YET CURRENTLY UNFUNDED
WOULD GO TO PROJECTS THAT LIFT
UP UNDER REPRESENTED STORY IN
CALIFORNIA HISTORY AND SERVE
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES
PLEASE HELP ARE DEEPLY IMPACTED
SECTOR RECOVER AND DEEPEN
CALIFORNIANS CONNECTION TO OUR
HISTORICAL CULTURAL AND NATURAL
RESOURCES. WE ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT THANK YOU. AND NEXT TO
GO TO LINE. ONE OH TO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU TO BLOOM AND
NUMBER OF PEOPLE INVOLVED WITH
CLEAN WATER ACTION CALLING IN
VERY STRONG SUPPORTER OF AN
AGENDA ITEM NUMBER THREE
SPECIFICALLY THE WATER
RESILIENCE TO DROUGHT PACKAGE
WE GREATLY APPRECIATE THE
PRACTICE LEADERSHIP DISPLAYED
UNDER THE MAY REVISE OF THE
FOLLOWING ITEMS ONE POINT TWO
BILLION FOR THE DRINKING WATER
WATER INFRASTRUCTURE. WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT THE FEDERAL
FUNDING FOR THE STATE THE
PROGRAM SPECIFICALLY AS IT
GIVES US OPPORTUNITY TO WORK
TOWARDS CLOSING THE DRINKING
WATER ACCESS CAPS IN CALIFORNIA
AND YOU KNOW NOW IS THE TIME
FOR TRANSFORMATIONAL
INVESTMENTS MARKET YOU WATER IN
WATER WASTEWATER INFRASTRUCTURE
FOR COMMUNITIES OUR
DISINVESTMENT FOR DECADES AND
WE THOUGHT WE WOULD SUPPORT
EVEN HIGHER LEVEL OF FUNDING.
OF THE TWENTY MILLION FOR
PEOPLE SUPPORT FOR DRINKING
WATER SYSTEMS- WE SUPPORT
FUNDING TOWARDS BECAUSE I WOULD
LIKE TO STRESS THE NEED FOR
RESORT RESEARCH FURTHER
RESEARCH FOR THE DEVELOPMENT OF
A PROACTIVE TREATMENT
TECHNIQUES- AND WHILE I. WOULD
GREATLY APPRECIATE THIS
INCLUSION THE PROBLEM. IS MUCH
LARGER THAN THIS NOW- THREE
MILLION FOR SEGMENTAL. TO
PROVIDE. SECURITY WATER QUALITY
BOROUGH LIFE. WE ARE IN
PARTICULAR YOU AND- OF THE
SENATE THAT REQUIRE NO LESS 30%
TOWARDS PROJECTS OKAY THANK YOU.
THANK VERY MUCH. NATIONAL ONE
ONE TWENTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
VERONICA AVAILABLE CREWS AND
I'M CALLING ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA FOR ACTION FUND BUT
WE WANT TO URGE THE COMMITTEE
TO SUPPORT OF THE NAY REVISED
SEVEN BILLION DOLLAR PROPOSAL
ON BROADBAND AND THE PRIORITY
OF BUILDING UP THE MIDDLE MILE
NETWORK. THE NEED FOR
SIGNIFICANT AND URGENT
INVESTMENT IN BROADBAND
INFRASTRUCTURE IS EVIDENT
ACROSS OUR COMMUNITIES AND WILL
CREATE GREATER ACCESS. TO
FEDERAL CONTROL SERVICE. SHARE
YOUR CONCERNS WITH TODAY THANK
YOU. AND NEXT TO THE LINE ONE
NINETEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN AND THE
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MONEY
WELL IN MARKETS WITH THE CENTER
FOR SUSTAINABLE ENERGY CALLING
ABOUT ISSUE THREE THAT THEIR
MISSION TRANSPORTATION PACKAGE
WOULD LIKE TO EXPRESS OUR
STRONG SUPPORT FOR THE GOVERNOR
SPENDING PROPOSAL ACROSS ALL
CLEAN TRANSPORTATION PROGRAMS
INCLUDING EQUITY AND MEDIUM AND
HEAVY DUTY PROGRAM. AND WITH
THE PART OF THE INVESTMENT THAT
COMMITTED ACROSS THE NEXT THREE
YEARS WHICH SENDS A POSITIVE
SIGNAL THAT CALIFORNIA'S
COMMITTED MEETING OR THERE ARE
MISSING ALL. FURTHERMORE WE
SUPPORT THE PROPOSED FIVE
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLAR
INVESTMENT NOT YET LINGER
STRUCTURE I MEAN CONCEDED
REPUTATION EIGHT TWENTY THIRTY
FIVE. IN PARTICULAR WE WANT A
MULTI YEAR FUNDING PROPOSAL BY
THE CLEAN VEHICLE REBATE
PROJECT. WE BELIEVE THAT PART
OF MILLION NUMBER I THINK YOU
FOR HELPING ME GET LAW AND CAN
ONLY MAKE. THAT IMPRESSION
THANK YOUNG. I HATE CUTTING
PEOPLE OFF AND- NEXT BIGGER
PLACE. ACTUALLY FORTY SIX GO
AHEAD. YEAH MR CHAIRMAN BASS A
LOT SO ON BEHALF OF WATER REUSE
CALIFORNIA IF THIS OF THE STATE
WATER. WE'RE VERY CONCERNED
ABOUT THE LACK OF SIGNIFICANT
INVESTMENT FOR WATER RECYCLING
IN THE GOVERNOR SPROUT PROPOSAL
ONE HUNDRED TWENTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS SHARED WITH GROUNDWATER
CLEANUP IS NOT A WAY TO CREATE
DROUGHT ONE MILLION CLIENTS.
THAT WATER RECYCLING CAN BRING
TO THE STATE AS YOU KNOW
THERE'S OVER A SEVEN BILLION
DOLLARS IN PROJECT WAITING AT
THE STATE BOARD IN THEIR
INTENDED USE PLAN FOR FUNDING-
THAT ARE READY TO GO AND WE
ENCOURAGED HIM- AT LEAST SEVEN
HUNDRED AND FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS IN THAT PACKAGE GOING
FORWARD AND WE COULD USE MUCH
MORE THAN THAT. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR YOUR TIME. THANK YOU.
TEN MEXICO LINE TWENTY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
TRACY BRIAN WHAT THE WORLD
COUNTY RECTANGLE CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT OF THE COMPREHENSIVE
BROADBAND PROPOSAL IN THE
GOVERNOR'S MADE REVISIONS. THE
BRIDGE THE DIGITAL DIVIDE BY
LEVERAGING FEDERAL FUNDING AND
GRANT OPPORTUNITIES FOR TRIBE
AND LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO
PROVIDE HIGH SPEED INTERNET TO
THEIR COMMUNITY. THE PLATE ON
MIDDLE MILE MARKER BY SERVICE
BY CAN IN HIGH YOU NEED FOR
LAST AS A MAJOR- BEEN SHORTER
BY THE STATE. THE OPEN AND WILL
ALSO SPUR COMPETITION AND LOWER
COSTS FOR THE END CONSUMERS.
WHAT FUNDING FOR MIDDLE WALK A
MILE IN AFFORDABLE. AND AN
ADDRESS ISSUES AROUND ON TOP
AND IT. WAY WE HAVE BEEN
ATTEMPTING TO BRIDGE THERE'S
SCHEDULE FOR TWENTY YEARS IN
THIS PROPOSAL RECOGNIZES WE
CAN'T DOING THIS THING AND
EXPECTING DIFFERENT RESULTS. WE
LOOK FORWARD TO SEEING MORE
DETAIL IN THE PROPOSAL BUT WE
ARE VERY SUPPORT OF THE SEVEN
BILLION DOLLAR INVESTMENT IN
BROADBAND IN THE CONCEPTUAL
STRUCTURE SUPPORT BY THE
GOVERNMENT. THANK YOU. AND NEXT
TO THE LINE AB PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS ALBEIT
BELIEVES SHAUN BEHALF OF THE
CAN JOAQUIN VALLEY AIR
POLLUTION CONTROL DISTRICT THE
VALUE THINKING NORMAN'S
CHALLENGES IN MEETING HEALTH
BASED AIR QUALITY ATTAINMENT
STANDARDS AND REDUCING AIR
POLLUTION AND EMISSIONS
REDUCTIONS AND
DISPROPORTIONATELY AFFECTED
COMMUNITIES IN ORDER TO MEET
OUR OBLIGATIONS AS OUTLINED IN
OUR STATE IMPLEMENTATION
PROGRAM WE STRONGLY SUPPORT THE
RE AUTHORIZATION OF THE EIGHTY
EIGHT PROGRAM. PROGRAMS WHAT
THE FUNDING PROVIDED IN THE
MARY THE FARMER WHICH PROVIDES
FOR QUALITY AND TO THE BALLOT
IN TWO SECURE ADDITIONAL
INVESTMENTS TO IT IS PROVIDED
FOR THE MADE REVISED FOR
ALTERNATIVES TO ADD FOR YOU.
AND THE AIR B. HAD DETERMINED
THAT THE NEED FOR THESE
PROGRAMS IS MUCH GREATER LASTLY
THE DISTRICT ALSO SUPPORTS
INCREASED FUNDING FOR NEAR TERM
EMISSIONS REDUCTIONS AND
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES. I
WOULD ALSO LIKE TO POINT THE
COURT ON BEHALF OF THE OFFICE
OF CALCULATOR FOR THE ONE
HUNDRED MILLION PROVIDED IN THE
NAY REVISED. FOR THE HEALTHY
SOILS PROGRAM THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. AND NEXT TO THE LINE ONE
THIRTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON HEAVILY A COASTAL
ADVOCATE I APPLAUD THE
ADMINISTRATION'S EFFORT TO
IMPROVE OUTDOOR ACCESS IN
EQUITY AND WOULD LIKE TO
ADVOCATE FOR ADDITIONAL FUNDING
TO SUPPORT THE CALIFORNIA
COASTAL COMMISSION TWELVE HILL
GRANTS PROGRAM. THIS IS AN
EXISTING GRANTS PROGRAM WITH A
LONG AND SUCCESSFUL TRACK
RECORD IN ADVANCING OUTDOOR
ACCESS AND EQUITY AS WELL AS
SUPPORTING ENVIRONMENTAL
EDUCATION AND HABITAT
ENHANCEMENT. LET'S GET OUR
CHILDREN BACK IN TOUCH WITH
NATURE NOW WELL WE HAVE THE
MONEY TO DO SO. PLEASE LET THE
COASTAL COMMISSION'S PUBLIC
EDUCATION DEPARTMENT HELP TAKE
THE LEAD ON THIS THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU. AND NEXT TO IT
ONLINE SEVENTY FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS- JEFF NEAL
WITH THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES I WANT
TO ALIGN MYSELF WITH THE
EXISTING COMMENTS MADE ABOUT MY
COLLEAGUE TRACY LINE ACTRESS
YOU RIDE THE RURAL COUNTIES BUT
MR CARE I ALSO WANTED TO
ADDRESS THE CONCERNS YOU
BROUGHT UP EARLIER. ABOUT
LAYING FIBER AND WHETHER THAT
BE AN OBSOLETE TECHNOLOGY BY
THE TIME I DID THE BILL JUST BY
MAKING THE POINT THAT
EVERYTHING WHETHER IT'S A
WIRELESS WHETHER ANY KIND OF
INTERNET IT ALL COMES BACK TO
PIPER IN THE END SO IT'S JUST
ONE MORE REASON WHY THAT STATE
OWNED OPEN ACCESS MIDDLE MILE-
IS SO IMPORTANT. BUT IT AS WELL
AS THE FACT THAT PROPRIETARY
MIDDLE OF MILE NETWORKS ARE
SOMETIMES USED AS A REASON. TO
DENY- THE DENTAL PROVIDERS WHO
WANT TO BUILD OUT TO CURRENTLY
UNSERVED AND UNDERSERVED. SO I
THANK YOU. FOR YOUR TIME AND
YOUR PATIENCE TODAY. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. NEXT WE GO TO ONE
NINETY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
ABOUT A MONTH IN ON BEHALF OF
THE SANTA ANA WATERSHED PROJECT
IT'S ALREADY REGARDING THAT
CRAP YOU DROUGHT PACKAGE- STOP
I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST FIVE
HUNDRED TEN MILLION DOLLARS FOR
THE INTEGRATED REGIONAL WATER
MANAGEMENT PROGRAM. I ARE W.
AND IS A PROVEN REGIONAL
PROGRAM THEY CAN INVEST IN
REGIONAL POLLUTION TO DROUGHT
IMPACT THROUGHOUT THE STATE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. NEXT TO
ALIGN ONE TWENTY FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS THIS IS ROSS
BARKLEY ON BEHALF OF SACRAMENTO
MAYOR DARRELL STEINBERG IN THE
CITY OF SACRAMENTO IN SUPPORT
OF THE THIRTY MILLION DOLLARS
UNDER THE NATURAL RESOURCE
PROTECTION FROM SACRAMENTO
RAILYARDS THE RECORDS THE
TRANSFORMATIVE DEVELOPMENT FOR
THE FUTURE THE CAPITAL REGION.
BURGER SUPPORT FOR THIS
PROPOSAL THANK YOU. NEXT
HEADLINE ONE TWELVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON CAITLYN
COLLIDE WITH THE CALIFORNIA
COULD KEEPER LINE MY COMMENTS
RELATE THE ITEM NUMBER THREE ON
CLIMATE CHANGE AND DROUGHT. WE
SPECIFICALLY ENCOURAGE THE
ASSEMBLY TO INCREASE STATEWIDE
INVESTMENT FOR MULTI BENEFITS
STORMWATER MANAGEMENT PROJECTS-
TO FIVE HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS
IN THE FINAL BUDGET. IN ORDER
TO IMPROVE WATER QUALITY AND
INCREASE LOCAL WATER SUPPLY. WE
ARE ALSO CONCERNED WITH THE
LACK OF FUNDING FOR WATER
RECYCLING AND ENCOURAGE THE
FINAL BUDGET TO INCLUDE SEVEN
HUNDRED AND FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS. FOR WATER RECYCLING
PROJECTS TO MITIGATE THE LONG
TERM AND IMPACT OF DROUGHT
INCREASE WILL CLIMATE RESILIENT
COST EFFECTIVE WATER SUPPLIES.
BUILDING ON THE SUCCESSES AND
ADVANCING THOSE PROJECTS THAT
ARE SHOVEL READY AND READY TO
GO THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK
YOU. NEXT TO A ONE ONE THIRTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
JAMIE MINOR ON BEHALF OF AND B.
E. SERVING CUSTOMERS THANK
CONTRA COSTA NAPA AND SOLANO IN
MARIN COUNTY AND WE'RE CALLING
IN SUPPORT OF THE GOVERNOR'S
pPROPOSAL ON INVESTMENTS TO MEET
THE STATE'S CLEAN ENERGY GOALS.
I SPECIFICALLY YOU WE SUPPORT
FUNDING FOR A LONG DURATION
BULK STORAGE AS WELL AS GREEN
HYDROGEN A BALLPARK THAT JOE
AND HELPING THE STATE
TRANSITION. AWAY FROM FOSSIL
FUELS THANKS SO MUCH. NEXT OKAY
GO TO LINE ONE TWENTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR MARK FENSTER MAKER
ON BEHALF OF SEVERAL CLIENTS
OUR FIRST FOR THE CALIFORNIA
COUNCIL OF LAND TRUSTS I WAS
VERY SUPPORTIVE THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSED FUNDING FOR NATURAL
AND WORKING LANDS CONTAIN THE
WILDFIRE AND DROUGHT PACKAGES
AS WELL AS THE FUNDING FOR THE
DEPARTMENT OF PARKS- WE DO
THESE PACKAGES IS SOMETHING OF
A BOND AS MUCH A LETTER TO THE
L. A. O. NOTED IN HER OPENING
REMARKS. WHAT WE KNOW THIS
MISSING IS PROPOSAL FOR FUNDING
TO WILDLIFE CONSERVATION BOARD
AND STATE CONSERVANCY IS FOR
DURABLE INVESTMENTS IN
PROTECTING AND RESTORING
WILDLIFE HABITAT AND OPEN
SPACE. THAT WOULD- GREAT
CLIMATE RESILIENCE FORTY PLANT
AS WELL AS CREATE ADDITIONAL
RECREATION OPPORTUNITIES. THE
REQUESTED FUNDING FOR THIS
PURPOSE BEING CAUSED BY THE
LEGISLATURE. I WANT TO ECHO
SOME COMMENTS MADE EARLIER- ON
BEHALF OF THE SONOMA COUNTY
WATER AGENCY ECHO THE COMMENTS
FROM STOP AFTER FUNDING FOR THE
INTEGRATED REGIONAL WATER
MANAGEMENT PROGRAM. WE HAVE TO
THE CALIFORNIA URBAN FORESTRY
COUNCIL ALIGN OURSELVES WITH
THOSE OF THE TRUST REPUBLIC
PLANTED TREE PEOPLE ARE CALLING
FOR MORE FUNDING TO CALPERS
URBAN FORESTRY PROGRAM. AND
LASTLY ON BEHALF OF BURKE
JUSTICE WANT TO ALIGN OURSELVES
WITH THE COMMENTS FROM MR
BLIGHTED SIERRA CLUB REGARDING
THE NEED TO NOT SETTLE FOR NEAR
ZERO EMISSION TECHNOLOGIES. AND
INSTEAD WE SHOULD REALLY FOCUS-
THESE CRITICAL INVESTMENTS ON
ZERO EMISSION TRANSPORTATION.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. NEXT TO
ALIGN WHY THIRTY. PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YEAH MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS DUTCH HOUSTON
REPRESENTED PARK AND RECREATION
SOCIETY CALIFORNIA OUTDOOR
RECREATION PARTNERSHIPS HEY ARE
NAY AND DOZENS OF OTHER
ENTITIES. WE WANT TO COMMEND
THE ADMINISTRATION FOR FUNDING
TO HOST THE PROGRAMS IN THE V.
BY DESIRE TO IMPROVE ACCESS TO
THE OUTDOORS. BUT ALONG THAT
THEY WANT TO DO KIRSTY
COMMITTEE CONSIDER AN EIGHTY
MILLION DOLLAR ALLOCATION TO
THE DIRECT RECREATION TRAILS
PROGRAM. FOR NATURAL SURFACE
TRAILS. THIS COMPLEMENT THE
FIVE HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS
FOR ACTIVE TRANSPORTATION
PROGRAM. THAT'S FOLKS KNOW OUR
PARKS AND TRAILS. HAVE BEEN
LOVED TO DEATH DURING THE
PANDEMIC. THIS PROGRAM EXPAND
TRAIL NETWORKS. AND MITIGATE
FOR THE STRESSES THAT HAVE BEEN
PLACED ON THE NETWORKS OVER THE
PAST SIXTEEN MONTHS AND VERY
MUCH APPRECIATE YOUR
INTELLIGENCE ON THIS MATTER
MISTER CHAIR. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. SO TO ONE ONE TWENTY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. GERMAN
BLOOM MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
MY NAME IS STEPS OUT OF THE S.
BOMB ON THE APP OF CHARGEPOINT
SUPPORTED THE GOVERNOR'S MAY
REVISE PROPOSAL ON YOUR MISSION
VEHICLE INFRASTRUCTURE FUNDING
THINKER TRANSPORTATION PROGRAMS
PLUS POINT LEAD WRITER YOU
CHARGING STATION HARDWARE AND
SOFTWARE NORTH AMERICA. FIRST
ONE IS A LARGE PART OF THIS
COMMITTEE'S WORK AND THE
GOVERNOR'S MAY REVISE RELATED
ZERO EMISSION VEHICLE AND
INFRASTRUCTURE PROGRAMS WE
BELIEVE THAT MORE EMPHASIS
SHOULD BE PLACED ON LIGHT
DUTIES REMISSION VEHICLE
INFRASTRUCTURE THAN THE FIVE
HUNDRED MILLION CONTAINED IN
THE MAIL REEBOKS THE VEHICLE
THAT WE USE THIS INFRASTRUCTURE
ARE INCREASING PRODUCTION
RAPIDLY AND WE ENCOURAGE THE
STATE TO PURCHASE FUNDING OVER
THE NEXT TWO YEARS. TO THE
VEHICLE SEGMENT THAT WILL BE ON
THE ROAD SECOND WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT THE CCB PROVIDED THE
FUNDING FORTY FOUR ZERO
EMISSION VEHICLE INFRASTRUCTURE
THEY HAVE THE EXPERTISE AND
INFRASTRUCTURE TO ENSURE THIS
FUNDING AT THE PLATE QUICKLY IN
THE NEXT TWO YEARS. WE LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH MEMBERS THE LEGISLATURE TO
ENSURE FUNDING FOR PROGRAMS ARE
SUPPORTED BY ITS BUDGET
RESULTING QUICK EFFICIENT
MCCONNELL THE PROMINENT YOU
CHARGING INFRASTRUCTURE.
THROUGHOUT THE STATE THANK YOU
SO MUCH. THANK YOU AND NOW. GO
TO A- ONE THIRD TWO PLEASE GO.
ONE THIRTY TWO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. OKAY WILL GO TO ONE FORTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME
IS DENNIS ALBION AND I'M
CALLING ON BEHALF OF THE WATER
DISTRICT SANTA CLARITA MAKES
THE WATER QUALITY AND SAN
GABRIEL VALLEY WE SUPPORT THE
GOVERNOR'S. COMMITMENT TO AND
THEN PLAN TO COVER ARREARS OF
PAYMENTS NOT MADE DURING THE
CALL THE CRISIS WE DON'T WE
WOULD LIKE TO SEE AN INCREASE A
SIGNIFICANT INCREASE IN THE
KEEP US MONEY FOR CONTAIN
CONTAMINANTS OF EMERGING
CONCERN BUT WE HAVE ASKED FOR
TWO HUNDRED MILLION AND WOULD
LIKE THAT AT YOU DON'T. THE
ELEMENT INCREASE THEIR FOUR
BAGGER CULTURAL ENTITIES COULD
IN THE ALLMAN ALLIANCE IN THE
COLOR GREEN FUTURE STATION WE
SUPPORT THE AG BURN BUT WE
THINK IT SHOULD BE INCREASED
THE GOVERNOR- ADMINISTRATION
CREATED THE- BY DENYING THE SAN
JOAQUIN VALLEY AIRBORNE BURNING
PLAN. AND SO THEY CREATED A
CHALLENGE AND IT NEEDS TO BE
DONE IN TWO HUNDRED NINETY FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS BUT WE DO
SUPPORT POLLINATOR HEALTH OF
THE STATE PROGRAMS APPRECIATE
THAT BEING INCLUDED. AND WE
WOULD LIKE TO SEE IN REAL.
CONCRETE THE- ORDER FOR
INCREASED. NUMBER SOMEBODY
EARLIER MENTION THE ONE BILL.
THE TO BE EDUCATE SIDE FOR-
FOR- ALTERNATE MEET I'M NOT
SHOULD BE WE BELIEVE THAT HE
COMMITTED USE AT ALL. AND THEN
THEY CANNELLA. MONEY SHOULD BE
SPENT- AND SO THE THAT THE
NATIONAL. BUDGET SHOULD BE.
THANKS FACT THANK YOU. NEXTCODE
LINE TO ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YEAH SURE COMMITTEE MEMBER MY
IS MIKE AND I AM TWENTY TWO OLD
I AM MEMBER THANK MARKETS SOME
URBAN CONSERVATION OF A EMPIRE.
OUR OUR ORGANS ARE BOTH THE
AGAIN OF PORTS YOUR COULD TELL
VALLEY AUTOMATE REVISED
INCLUDES FOR WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT AT THE THOUGHT TO
ANY DIRECT INVESTMENT TO
SUPPORT THE FORTY LOCAL COURT
LOCAL CORE BENEFITS ARE YOUNG
LIKE TO BE A OF CALL FOR TO
PREVENT WILDFIRES BUT NO
CALIFORNIA PEPPER GEL HELP MAKE
SERVICE CHANGE IMPACT ON ARC
ENVIRONMENT AND TO. SERVER
THREE YEARS SEEN WE HAD LOTS OF
THE AT LEAST THE SPECIALIZED
MEMBERS PROGRAM BOTH PLAYERS
FOR YOUNG ESPECIALLY LIKE ME TO
BE IN MY BUT I'M CAN COME UP
WITH THE AGAINST CHANGE GLOBAL
IN FACT IF YOU AMERICA MAKER
OPERATE VERY HARD BY THE I KNOW
EFFECT FROM GREEN GASES
SOMETHING ABOUT THE FEDERAL ON
A WE NEED YOUR HELP YOU DON'T
EVEN BEHIND IN A LOCAL COME
CORPS CENTER YOURS BUT THANK
AND I YEAH. AND NEXT OVER THE
LINE. FOR ONE GO AHEAD. HI
JENNIFER SEVEN THERE FOR FOUND.
WE APPRECIATE THAT THE NAY FIVE
INCLUDES CLIMATE CAN AT AT FOR
PARTICULARLY CLEVELAND MILLION
FOR COASTAL WRECKED AND
ELEVENTH FIVE FIFTY PARK
DELIVER RIGHT GRAVITY BUT THE
BUDGET AFTER FAILED INCLUDE
INCREASED. FUNDING FOR THE
COASTAL COMMISSION THE STATE
AGENCY ON THE FRONT LINES AT
THE LEVEL RIGHT PLANNING PRIOR
TO THAT COULD BE QUITE
DIFFICULT THE COMMISSION WITH
FUNDED ONE POINT FIVE MILLION
FOR YOU ALL RIGHT WORK IT. TO
THE CRISIS FUNDING WAS CUT IN
HALF AND HAS NOT BEEN RESTORED
WE'RE GRATEFUL TO SEE THE SEVEN
HUNDRED AND FIFTY THOUSAND CAN
CAN GET PICKED UP TO THE TOP
THE CRITICAL TO PROVIDE FUNDING
FOR THE GRANTS THEMSELVES. IF
YOU LEVEL RIGHTS LOCAL TO THINK
GRANT PROGRAM IS WHAT MOTIVATES
LOCAL JURISDICTIONS TO DO
VOLATILITY ASSESSMENT AND
UPDATE THEIR LOCAL COASTAL
PROGRAM INCLUDES THE LEVEL
RIGHT POLICIES IF YOU THINK YOU
CAN INEXPLICABLE OVERSIGHT THAT
NEEDS. TO BE KEPT THANK YOU.
THANKS TO THE LINE ONE THIRTY
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. WHICH IN
TURN MEMBERS CRIMES BIGGER WITH
THE COUNTY OF LOS ANGELES THE
LOS ANGELES COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS STRONGLY SUPPORTS
AND GREATLY APPRECIATE THE
GOVERNOR'S MAY BE BASED OFF OF
ATWATER NINETY ONE MILLION
GENERAL FUND OVER THREE YEARS
ON TOP OF THIRTY ONE POINT FOUR
MILLION PROPOSED IN THE
GOVERNOR'S. WAY BACK YOU CAN
CLEAN UP ADDITIONAL PROPERTY.
BUT THE FIVE MACKEEPER. LEVELS
NAY FORMER EXILE. IN THIS OF.
IN ADDITION THE BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS THE ADDITIONAL ONE
HUNDRED THIRTY TWO MILLION ONE
TIME GENERAL FUND IN THE EVENT
OF THE TRUST FUNDS ARE CALLED
EXPENDED. OVER THREE DECADES
BACK FIVE TECHNOLOGIES LET OUT
THE BATTERY RECYCLING PLANT
OPERATED- EVEN ADDED SEVERAL
TOPICS SUBSTANCE KNOWN TO BE
HARMFUL SUBSTANCES INTO THE AIR
ABOUT THE CITY OF BONN AND- AS
A RESULT THOUSANDS OF
RESIDENTIAL PROPERTIES AND- IN
THE SURROUNDING COMMUNITIES FOR
CONTAMINATED. AND THOUSANDS OF
NEARBY RESIDENTS AND WORKERS
WERE EXPOSED TO LEAD AND OTHER
TOXIC SUBSTANCES. WHICH CAUSE
SIGNIFICANT HEALTH CONSEQUENCES
SUCH AS ASTHMA CANCER AND
DEVELOPMENTAL AND BEHAVIORAL
DISORDERS IN CHILDREN THE
FUNDING IS CRITICAL TO THE
HEALTH. AND WELFARE OF THE
COMMUNITY THANK YOU. AND
ACTUALLY ALIGNED ONE OH FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
APPLICATION. A GOOD AFTERNOON-
TERRIBLE- AND MEMBERS THIS IS
LAND TRACK MY TRAFFIC CRISIS.
TODAY REPRESENT IN THE WATER
FOUNDATION AND ACTION POLICY
WOULD LIKE TO PROPHETICALLY
ADDRESSED ITEM THREE. ON WATER
IN DROUGHT WE ARE IN STRONG
SUPPORT. OF THE GOVERNOR'S
HISTORIC PROPOSAL ON THESE
ITEMS AND I WOULD LIKE TO
ESPECIALLY HIGHLIGHT THE- ONE
POINT THREE BILLION DOLLARS
ALLOCATED TO STAY FOR MAY NEED
AT LEAST THAT AMOUNT AND ALSO
TO THE- SEGMENT SATISFIED FOR.
DRINKING WATER FOR
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES I
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
YOU AND APPRECIATE YOUR
LEADERSHIP THANK YOU. AND
ACTUALLY GOT A LINE ONE OH SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN BOB REEVES ON
BHALF OF THE WATER
REPLENISHMENT DISTRICT OF
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA THE FIRST
LIKE TO ECHO THE WATER REUSE
ASSOCIATION CALL FOR INCREASED
FUNDING FOR WATER RECYCLING
PROJECTS. AND ALSO TO-
RESPONDED THE CHAIRS QUESTION
REGARDING P. FOSS FUNDING. IN
W. R. D. SERVICE AREA ALONE
THERE ARE AT LEAST THIRTY NINE
P. FOSS AFFECTED WELLS AND THIS
NUMBER IS EXPECTED TO GROW WE
ESTIMATE THE COST AND W. R. D.
SERVICE AREA ALONE TO BE ONE
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS TO
BRING THESE WELLS BACK ONLINE.
IF LEFT UNADDRESSED UNTREATED
P. FAST CAN MIGRATE THROUGH THE
GROUNDWATER BASINS AND
CONTAMINATE MORE WELLS W. R. D.
IS SEEKING TWO HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS FOR THIS AS THEIR AREAS
OF NEED IN OTHER PARTS OF LOS
ANGELES AND ORANGE COUNTY'S.
FUNDING FOR WELL HAD TREATMENT
DISTRIBUTION SYSTEMS RELATED TO
THAT TREATMENT WILL PROVIDE
GALLON PER GALLON SAVINGS-
DURING THIS DROUGHT FOR
IMPORTED WATER SUPPLIES FROM
THE COLORADO RIVER IN THE
SACRAMENTO SAN JOAQUIN DELTA
THANK YOU. IN MEXICO LINE SIXTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
AND BAKER WHAT BUT WITH CLIMATE
RESULT I'D LIKE TO SPEAK TO
ITEM THREE THE CLIMATE CHANGE
PROPOSAL. UNRESOLVED STRONGLY
SUPPORTS THE GOVERNOR'S TWENTY
TWENTY ONE AND TWENTY TWENTY
CHIU NAY REVISED BUDGET
PROPOSAL. AND THE INCREASE
FUNDING TO ADDRESS CLIMATE
CHANGE OF REDUCING GREENHOUSE
GAS EMISSIONS AND CLIMATE
RESULTS. THANKS TO THE HARD TO
THE- FIFTY. I'M A TRAINED
ASSESSMENT- TO DELIVER CLEAN
WATER MARK LOOKED TO BE A
CLOSER BE CAREFUL THE WILDFIRE
SEASON. YES TO BE OFF TO AN
EARLY START- LAUDABLE. WE ARE
ALSO PLEASED TO SEE THE
INCREASED ATTENTION TO
ADDRESSING THINKING IN THIS
YEAR'S PROPOSED REVISION. AND
HELP YOU QUESTIONS ABOUT THE
EFFICACY OF THE SPECIFIC
PROGRAMS PROPOSED FOR FUNDING.
WHILE ALL OF THESE PROGRAMS ARE
IMPORTANT AND WILL HELP THE
STATE MEET ITS CARBON
NEUTRALITY GOALS. THEIR IMPACT
ON REDUCING HEAT ARE PREPARING
CALIFORNIANS TO SURVIVE
HEATWAVES WILL LIKELY BE
MARGINAL. WE WOULD BE HAPPY TO
COMPLY THE COMMITTEE. WOULD BE
MORE DETAILED ANALYSIS WITH
RECOMMENDATIONS FOR PROGRAMS
THAT WILL HELP THE STATE
PREPARE FOR THIS AND FUTURE
HEAT WAVES SCENES. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION. MEXICO
LINE FORTY SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU CHAIR MONEY TO
MAKRAM WITH THE SLICON VALLEY
LEADERSHIP GROUP THREE ITEMS
FIRST WE SUPPORT THE INVESTMENT
IN HEAVY DUTY ZERO EMISSION
TRANSPORTATION PARTICULARLY THE
ONE THOUSAND TRANSIT BUSES AND
ONE THOUSAND SCHOOL BUSES
THROUGH THE H. UP PROGRAM WHICH
WE HAVE HISTORICALLY SUPPORTED.
SECOND THE FUNDING FOR THE
CLEAN VEHICLE REBATE PROJECT IS
A STEP IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION
FROM THE GOVERNOR'S MAY
PETITION BUT THE LEADERSHIP
GROUP WITH SUPPORT ADDITIONAL
FUNDING IS OVERSUBSCRIBED
PROGRAM HAS BEEN PROJECTED THAT
IT COULD USE OVER TWO HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS FOR EACH OF THE
NEXT THREE YEARS. THIRD ON THE
TOPIC OF COASTAL BROUGHT
WEAPONS RESTORATION THE
LEADERSHIP GROUP HAD IN SEPT
IN. TWENTY SIXTEEN- SUPPORTED A
BALLOT MEASURE MEASURE EIGHTY
EIGHT THAT THE BAY AREA RAISED
OVER FIVE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS TO FUND THE EMPHASIS GO
BAY WETLANDS RESTORATION ALONE
BUT IT IS NEAT THE NEED THERE
IS OVER ONE POINT FIVE BILLION
DOLLARS THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL
ONLY PROVIDES TWO HUNDRED
MILLION FOR THE WHOLE OF THE
CALIFORNIA COAST HAPPEN WHICH
COULD BE DEFINED AS THE SAN
FRANCISCO BAY WE THINK THAT
THAT AMOUNT COULD BE
SIGNIFICANTLY INCREASED. FOR
THE STATE SHARE OF REGIONAL
WETLANDS RESTORATION. FOR SAN
FRANCISCO BAY THANK YOU. ONE
ONE FORTY TO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU CHAIR AND MEMBERS
SANDERS SPECIALLY OUR HARD
WORKING STAFF I'M DAN WE CAN
CAMP WITH THE CALIFORNIANS TO
DO FOR BE ADVERSELY THAT DOOR
TO COMMENT ON AN ISSUE NUMBER
FOR SUSTAINABLE ACT. OUR
COALITION SUPPORT THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSED
DESIGN BUILD THE UPDATE AND
ALTHOUGH THE RECENT ADDITION
THE MATING- ABOUT THIRTY
MILLION DOLLARS FOR POLLINATOR
HABITAT- WE ESPECIALLY THANK
MEMBERS BENNETT FRIEDMAN RIVAS
AND OTHERS WHO SUPPORTED
ASSEMBLY MEMBER KALRA AS
REQUEST FOR FUNDING FOR
SCIENTISTS TO DEVELOP DNA
BARCODES ARE POLLINATORS AND
INSECTS. THAT WE ASK THAT YOU
INCLUDED ALL AS YOU MOVE
FORWARD- WE ALSO WOULD SUGGEST
IN ADDITION TO MAKE SURE THAT
THE ADMINISTRATION'S THIRTY
MILLION DOLLARS FOR POLLINATOR
HABITAT IS NOT WASTED ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BENNETT SAID THE
MIGRATORY MONARCH AND DECLINED
ABOUT NINETY NINE POINT 9% IN
RECENT YEARS PLANTING HABITAT
JUST IS NOT ENOUGH THE ANIMALS
ARE NOT THERE WE NEED A MONARCH
RESCUE TO SAVE THEM FROM
EXTINCTION AS WE DID WITH
SALMON WHEN WE SAW THAT THE
WERE GONNA GO EXTINCT IF WE
DON'T CROCOMBE AROUND DAMS.
WE'RE NOT GONNA HAVE WESTERN
MIGRATORY MONARCHS FOR ANOTHER
FIVE YEARS I MEAN AS WE ACT
TODAY AND SO WE LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH YOU AND YOUR STAFF
ON MAKING THE MOST OF THESE
INSPIRING OPPORTUNITIES AND WE
THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. NEXT WE GO TO THIRD FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIR BLOOM AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE THIS IS JIM HOLLY I'M
AT LAWRENCE BERKELEY NATIONAL
LABORATORY. THE GOVERNOR'S MAY
BUDGET REVISED INCLUDES
THIRTEEN MILLION AND ONE POINT
FUNDING TO THE NATIONAL LINE
WE'RE WATER REMEDIATION BASED
AT LAWRENCE BERKELEY LABS FOR
RESEARCH TO DEVELOP NEW LOW
COST LOW ENERGY DESALINATION
WATER TREATMENT TECHNOLOGIES.
I'M SPEAKING FOR A COALITION OF
CALIFORNIA RESEARCH INSTITUTION
WATER UTILITIES TECHNOLOGY
COMPANIES AND ORGANIZATIONS A
STRONG SUPPORT. CALIFORNIA
FACING WATER POSSIBLE SUPPLY TO
INTENSIFYING DROUGHT IN MOSCOW
NO AT. THE CURRENTLY CALIFORNIA
HAS MANY WATERS IMPAIRED BY
EXCESS ASSAULT AND OTHER
CONTAMINANTS THAT POTENTIALLY
COULD BE USED. THE STRONG
SUPPORT FROM THE SENATE BETTER
STATION AND THE U. S.
DEPARTMENT OF ENERGY I ALWAYS
DEVELOPING NEW TECHNOLOGIES TO
REMOVE SALT AND OTHER
CONTAMINANTS SO THAT WE CAN USE
AND RE USE THESE WATERS. MAY
REVISED PROPOSAL WILL BRING
SIXTY MILLION DOLLARS IN
FEDERAL FUNDING TO CALIFORNIA.
REGARDING ELLIOTT'S COMMENTS
AND FINDING NOT ALWAYS ON A
STRICT TIMETABLE SET BY THE
DEPARTMENT ENERGY AND NEEDS TO
RELEASE THE BALL BECAUSE
FUNDING THIS SUMMER TO ACTION
IS BEING BUDGET IS THEREFORE
CRITICAL THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION. THANK YOU. AND
NEXT WE'LL GO O LINE TWENTY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK
YOU TERRIBLE NUMBERS TO THE
JOURNAL THERE'S A COUPLE FOR
JUSTICE AND ACCOUNTABILITY WHAT
WE COULD BE INVESTMENT IN
COMMUNITY CLIMATE RESILIENCE
INCLUDING TPC AND COMMUNITY
RESILIENCE CENTERS WHICH
INCLUDE CONSTRUCTION AND REHAB
BUILDING AND PROPERTY UPGRADES.
PROBABLY FIFTY INVESTMENT-
SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENT IN WATER
IN UTILITY DEBT RELIEF SO THE
NEED MAY REQUIRE EVEN LARGER
FUNDS GIVEN THE EXTREME
CIRCUMSTANCES OF ENDEMIC.
SIMILARLY WERE HAPPY TO SEE THE
DRINKING WATER AND WASTEWATER
INFRASTRUCTURE INVESTMENTS AND
FUNDING FOR DROUGHT THE
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITY DESPITE
HIS GREAT INVESTMENTS WERE
DISAPPOINTED FIFTY MILLION FOR
TERRY NOTHING I FIFTY NINE IN
THE CALIFORNIANS WHICH WOULD
ALSO BE ELIGIBLE FOR KERRY DIED
YESTERDAY. AND I DON'T HAVE THE
COMMUNITIES OF INSTRUCTING FOR
YEARS THE VERY DIGESTIVE
PERPETUATE ENVIRONMENTAL
INJUSTICE GROUNDWATER
CONTAMINATION AND AIR POLLUTION
DO NOT PRODUCE CLEAN ENERGY AND
ARE BOTH KIND OF POLLUTION.
LASTLY WE STRONGLY SUPPORT THE
KNOWING PURPOSES IDENTIFICATION
IN THE MAIN REVISED WE
APPRECIATE THE THING OF THE
PAST MANAGEMENT PROPOSALS- BUT
THEY MUST INCLUDE INVESTMENTS
IN COMMUNITY PROTECTIONS TO
PROTECT WORKERS AND COMMUNITIES
FROM PESTICIDE EXPOSURE IN
ADDITION TO THEIR MONITORING
ENFORCEMENT BIODIVERSITY AND
TRANSITIONAL SUPPORT. FOR
UNDERSERVED FARMERS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. IN MEXICO ONE TWENTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIR BLOOMIN ASSEMBLY MEMBERS
MY NAME IS FINDING HIM I'M
CALLING ON BEHALF OF LOS
ANGELES ALLIANCE FOR A NEW
ECONOMY WORK CITED MISUSED
PERSONAL INVESTMENT CONSIDERED
AN WATER QUALITY INFRASTRUCTURE
DROUGHT. RELIEF AFTER MEDIATION
AND THE GOVERNOR UP THE
GOVERNOR'S COMMITMENT DEDICATED
SEGMENT FUND FOR
UNDERREPRESENTED COMMUNITIES WE
WOULD ACT SO- BUT THEN RAIN
THEN WOULD LOVE TO SEE
ADDITIONAL REPURPOSE CONSIDERED
FOR STORMWATER AND WASTE WATER.
RECYCLING AND GROUNDWATER
REMEDIATION AS WE KNOW THESE
INVESTMENTS ARE CRUCIAL FOR
WATER SUPPLY AND QUALITY
CLIMATE RESILIENCE- VOCAL WATER
SUPPLY AND THE CREATION OF GOOD
UNION JOBS AND WE'RE ALSO
GRATEFUL TO THE ALLEY- FOR
RECOGNIZING. EARLIER INCLUDE
COMMENTS THE URGENCY OF
ADDRESSING. WATER AND ENERGY
THAT REALLY THANK YOU. NEXT TO
LINE FIFTY THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. CHAIRMAN GLAM ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS BENNETT ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BENEFITS ON MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS JOHN
ALLMAN UNDER DIRECTOR OF THE
LOS PADRES CHAPTER OF THE
SIERRA CLUB REPRESENTING ENTRE
AND SANTA BARBARA COUNTIES
SOMETHING IS WRONG AT THE
DEPARTMENT OF TOXIC SUBSTANCES
CONTROL AND IF WHAT HAPPENED IS
HAPPENING IN VETERANS WEBSITE
COMMUNITY IS ANY INDICATION.
IT'S FUNDING MUST BE TIED TO
REFORM THE AGENCY ADMITTED
FAILING TO PROPERLY INFORM THE
70% LATINO COMMUNITY LONG BEEN
TRAPPED HERE AT SO CAL GAP
APPLICATION TO REMEDIATE TWENTY
FIVE HUNDRED TONS OF POCKETS
YOUR SO CAN DOUBLE ITS
COMPRESSOR PUMP CAPACITY THE
HUNDRED YEAR OLD CONTAMINATED
GAS COMPRESSORS SITE SITS
ACROSS FROM THE ELEMENTARY
SCHOOL A BOYS AND GIRLS CLUB
AND A PUBLIC HOUSING FACILITY.
IS THE ONLY COMPRESSOR STATION
CALIFORNIA HIGH HIGH DENSITY
NEIGHBORHOODS THE SCHOOL
DISTRICT. THE SCHOOL THE
PARENTS THE T. THIS. NORTHWEST
COMMUNITY CAL HADN'T IDEA WAS
HAVE WHEN LOCAL RESIDENTS JUST
AND BY GROUPS TO TALK TO
DEPARTMENT THREE THE CALL. AND
A WHOLE THE FISH PUBLIC
HEARINGS THEY WERE DENIED
INSTEAD ONLY OFF AN APP THE
FACT MEETING THAT NO FOR OF LAW
WOULD NAY HAVE IF EVER HILLS OR
MONICA IT SHOULDN'T IN WEST
LEAD TO IF YOU OF FARM JOHN
THAT MUST BE REOPENED. THANK
YOU SANTA MONICA HAD IT SHE OF
TALKS COMMITTEE. THAT CAN. AND
THAT'S A LITTLE LINE TWENTY
THREE YOU PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO EUROPE YOU GUYS ARE ALL
THERE OKAY THANK YOU HI GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS MARVIN
NORMAN HI MOM THIS IS THE
SENATE RIGHT MEAN ACTION OF OUR
MOST JUSTICE ALONG WITH AND A
NUMBER I CAN LINES AND ALSO
WE'RE SPEAKING OF THE RESIDENTS
NUMBER TODAY NO- I SPEAKING ON
THE TOTAL ITEMS- WHERE YOU FROM
THE MICHAELIDES SIDE WE ARE
PLEASED TO SEE THAT. THERE'S
BEEN A- AND IN THE FUNDING THE
ACT. PROGRAM BUT I WILL ALSO
SAY ATHLONE REGRADED MANY OUT
BUT IT'S WORKING THE ACT
TRANSPORTATION GRANTS MYSELF
WORDS CDC- PLACERVILLE SHARES
THAT- WITH THE IT WOULD BE
BETTER TO GO EVEN FURTHER OUT I
KNOW WHEN THE CDC BOARD MEMBER
TWENTY. PROPERTY BILLION AT ONE
POINT AND MAYBE NOT THAT MUCH
BUT THAT THAT WOULD REALLY THE
BILL IN. ADDITION WE WOULD LIKE
TO SEE THAT THE CVR PETE- AND
STARTED BE AMENDED TO INCLUDE
ON THE BIKE THAT ELIGIBLE FOR
THE- SUBSIDIES- DOES HAVE JUST
AS MUCH POTENTIAL. TO REDUCE
EMISSIONS IT'S HARD FOR MANY
PEOPLE ESPECIALLY GIVEN THE
TRIPS THAT. ARE DOMINATED MANY
OF OUR REGIONS IN THE STATE I
SHORT TRIPS WE ALSO GLAD TO
SEE. WHAT YOU J. J. SITE THAT-
MONEY IS BEING PUT INTO. PUBLIC
THAT WHAT BOND. COMMUNITIES AND-
THIS. BY THEY ARE CONTINUE TO
BE. UNDER OUT- CODED AS THIS
PART OUT AND- ALL. ON ALL CASES
THE- ACTORS. NOT THE FUNDING
WILL WILL GO FARTHER THAN FUND
IN ROW IN SO LET'S GET PEOPLE
BACK TO WORK AND THE STATE BACK
ON TRACK. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
NUMBER ONE ONE THIRTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MISTER CHAIR
MICHAEL BOOKER ON BEHALF OF THE
AG ENERGY CONSUMERS- THE RECENT
UNITED NATIONS GLOBAL METHANE
ASSESSMENT REFLECTS A GROWING
RECOGNITION THE WORLD NEEDS TO
FURTHER UPDATE MAP AND- IT
RECOGNIZES IT AS A SHORT LIVED
CLIMATE POLLUTANT METHANE
REDUCTION PROVIDING IMPORTANT-
SHORT TERM MITIGATION
OPPORTUNITY TO OFFSET THE
HIGHLY DAMAGING EFFECTS OF
CARBON DIOXIDE. WITH THAT IN
MIND WE STRONGLY SUPPORT THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL FOR SIXTY
MILLION PROJECT AYE GESTURES
AND OTHER LIVESTOCK METHANE
REDUCTION PROGRAMS. TO DIGEST A
PROGRAM IN PARTICULAR HAS BEEN
THE MOST COST EFFECTIVE PROGRAM
FUNDED BY THE STATE AND THE
MOST PRODUCTIVE IN OVERALL GHG
REDUCTIONS. WITH THAT IN MIND
WE'RE VERY JUST DISHEARTENED BY
THE COMMONS BUT EACH A
COMMUNITY. ADDING TO OFFICIAL
STATE AGENCY REPORT THESE
PROJECTS PROVIDE TREMENDOUS
WELL DOCUMENTED BENEFITS TO
CLIENTS. AND IN PARTICULAR TO
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES IN
TERMS OF AIR QUALITY WATER
QUALITY MOTOR CONTROL ANOTHER
BENEFIT IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT
FOR PEOPLE TO LOOK PAST THESE
FALSE CLAIMS. BUT EACH A
COMMUNITY WHEN THEY'RE OPPOSING
THESE PROJECTS TO PROVIDE MORE
METHANE REDUCTION THAN ANY
OTHER PROGRAM CURRENTLY BEING
PROPOSED THANK YOU THANK YOU.
HE SAID. ONE OF ONE FORTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THAT AFTERNOON
CHAIR AND MEMBERS CRYSTAL GET
OFF ON BEHALF OF THE ALL WAITED
FOR CREATION OF NORTH AMERICA
AND STOP WAY TOWARDS JUNK FOR
THE GOVERNOR KNEW SOMETHING BUT
YOUR LOCAL A FIFTY FIVE MILLION
TWO KARAKUL BARGAINING WITH
RECYCLING INFRASTRUCTURE NEEDED
FOR THE IMPLEMENTATION SB
THIRTY THREE BUT GIVEN THE
BUDGET SURPLUS TO REQUEST THE
LEGISLATURE INCREASE THIS
AMOUNT TO A HUNDRED MILLION. WE
OF THE COURT APPEARANCE-
PROPOSAL OF TWO HUNDRED MILLION
IN CAP AND TRADE DOLLARS TO
HELP IS THERE. THE NEEDS AND
COUNTIES DEVELOP AND BEGIN
IMPLEMENTING THIRTY THREE
REQUIREMENTS WE BELIEVE THAT
BOTH OF THESE TYPES OF FUNDING
ARE CRITICAL TO OFFER LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS RELEASED IN THE R.
TWENTY TWENTY FIVE ORGANIC.
WASTE RECYCLING TARGET THANK
YOU. IN LITTLE ONE ONE TWENTY
SO. TWO GO AHEAD. FIVE I THINK
YOU CHAU MEMBERS WILL GET TO
THE BOTTOM OF THE COMMUNITY
WATER CENTER CALLING IN VERY
STRONG OR OTHER CHEN DIED AND
THREE FOR THE WATER RESILIENT
AND DROP PACKAGE WE WANT TO
ALIGN OUR COMMON WITH THOSE
MADE BY. THE WATER ACTIONS
WATER FOUNDATION NEXT IN LINE
RELATING TO THE ONE POINT THREE
BILLION FOR KICKING WATER AND
WASTEWATER INFRASTRUCTURE THE
TWENTY MILLION FOR PEACOCK THE
POINT DRINKING WATER SYSTEMS
AND A THREE HUNDRED MILLION
PERCENT MY IMPLEMENTATION.
PARTICULARLY STRONG ON THE
SENATE SIDE OR 30% GOING
TOWARDS PROJECTS NOT TAKING
WATER AND 30% FOR BENEFIT
UNDERREPRESENTED COMMUNITIES
AND FINALLY THE TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE AND EMERGENCY
SPONSORED BY PROVISIONS FOR THE
CURRENT DROUGHT SUCH AS THE.
ONE HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION
PERSONAL. AND IT WAS ONLY
RECOMMENDATION UNDER THE DATA
FOR. AND THE WATER MONITORING
PROVISION. WE GREATLY
APPRECIATE THE ASSEMBLY NINE
COMMITTEE WE- ON DRINKING ACT.
THAT THE PATHANKOT BUT THE AND
WE WILL ONLY A THE LEVEL OF
FUNDING CLOSER. WHAT WASTEWATER
AND ARE WE GOING TO BE. BUT
WILL ALSO HELP BE THE FIRST
FINISH LINE IS AMONG TO FIND
MAKE THE- INVESTMENT NEEDED TO
CALL THE WATER. ACT THAT IN
CALIFORNIA THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR YOUR KAREN. WITH FORWARD TO
WORK. TOGETHER ON IT COULD
ISSUE. AND ACTUAL ONLINE FIFTY.
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
JERRY BROWN AND COME MOM MY
NAME IS THE NUMBER TO AND I AM
A FORMER ONE WITH THE- URBAN
CORE YEAH ALTHOUGH THE MY
BIKING OF FOUR LOOK FOR THE
DEVELOPMENT AND DOES INCLUDE
ANY BALL AMBER TO OF THE-
OVERCOME. CALLED. NO CONCORD
COMPONENTS KNOW PEOPLE LIKE TO
BE PART THE STATE WHAT PROVIDE.
COMPLY AND YOU WANT. SECTION OF
EDUCATION LEADING UP AND DURING
OF OUR STUDENTS I WANT TO BE A
PART TO BE A- UP AND TRY. YEAH
I DON'T WANT TO HAVE MIKE. THE
NO NEED WE ARE- LIKE MEETING.
CLOSED ON TO THE LAW BECAUSE
COALITION. THIS ADVICE THANK
YOU. PROGRAM AND FINAL DAY.
ALTHOUGH THE MAY REVISE
INCLUDES PARTS OF WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT IT DOES NOT INCLUDE
ANY DIRECT INVESTMENTS TO
SUPPORT FOURTEEN LOCAL
CONSERVATION CORPS. LOCAL COURT
CORPS MEMBER PROGRAM EMPOWER
YOUNG PEOPLE LIKE ME TO BE PART
OF THE STATE PARK HELP MINIMIZE
NEGATIVE IMPACTS OUR COMMUNITY
SUCH AS I NEED FOR AFFORDABLE
HOUSING IN THE CITY WE HAVE TO
DEFINE AND BUILD A TINY HOMES
PROJECT THAT HAVE HELPED
SUPPORT THE LOCAL HOMELESS
COMMUNITY AND FINALLY BATES. AS
LONG SOME OF OUR OWN FROM OF.
WE OFFER A LOT THE YOUNG
LEADERS. COUNCIL OF LEADERS
ADVOCATE FOR ISSUE ON OUR TO.
OVER THE PAST YEAR CREATING
HELPING VARIANTS TO GO DATA
BASED ON ORAL HEALTH FINAL.
PLANET DAY AT THE LOCAL FISH
WHICH FOR POLICY CHANGE FUNDING
THE FOR HOUSING FOR YOU. THAT
WAY WE CAN HELP ENSURE THAT
THEY CAN POKE ON SECONDARY
EDUCATION. THAT OF STRUGGLING
TO WORK FOR THE COST OF LIVING
IN THE CITY. HER GOAL IS TO
IMPACT GEN OF YOU TO BECOME
SUFFICIENT LEADING TO KEEP WITH
IT THE PROPER INVOLVED RIGHT
INCREASE IN THE UPCOMING YEARS.
HOW TO BE A CLIMATE WE AND I
WANT TO MAKE. PLEASE ONLY. AND
OTHER MAYBE HIGH BECAUSE ANY
DIRECT FUNDING TO THE LOK
CONSERVATION CORPS IN THE
BUDGET THANK YOU VERY TIME AND
YOUR LEADERS ON THE. YEAH WE GO
TO WAR. ONE FORTY SO. PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON SHARING
MEMBER. MY NAME IS CAN YOU PAIR
WITH NEXT GEN HOW. AND WITH THE
GOVERNOR PROPOSAL SEVEN BILLION
TO PROVIDE ACCESS FOR ALL. THIS
PROPOSED TO KNOW ABOUT MILE AN
OPEN BY BUSH IN. AN INVESTMENT
AND- JOBS HEALTH AND ECONOMIC
GROWTH HAT IS CENTER IN ACCESS
AND- SO WE RESPECTFULLY URGE
ASSEMBLY ADOPT THE GOVERNOR'S.
SEVEN BILLION PROPOSAL TO BAN
INFRASTRUCTURE AND WOULD ALSO
TO ADD OUR AND BEING AND THAT
IN MAYBE BY FOR A CONTRACT THAT.
AND THIS IS IN SEVEN STRUCTURE
TRANSPORTATION COMPANY PROGRAM.
AND ACTIVE TRANSPORTATION COSTS.
THANK YOU SO MUCH. IN ROOM THE
LINE ONE THREE ONE GO. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR PLAN KRISTIN
GOMEZ WITH HYUNDAI MOTOR
AMERICA HYUNDAI APPRECIATE THAT
THE GOVERNOR HERE P. PROPOSAL
EXTENDS FOR THREE YEARS HOWEVER
WE URGE THE LEGISLATURE TO
INCREASE THE FUNDING TO TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION ANNUALLY.
FOR A TOTAL OF SEVEN HUNDRED
FIFTY MILLION OVER THE NEXT
THREE YEARS. THE CONSISTENT
WITH THEIR BE THE ONLY NEED
THIS PROJECTIONS. RESEARCH
SHOWS THAT COST BY FAR REMAINS
THE PRIMARY BARRIER TO ENTRY
FOR EASY EVEN HERE IN
CALIFORNIA ROBUSTUS TENNIS
SENIOR THEN LATER- THAT'S
CRITICAL TO ACHIEVING A 100%
SEVEN TWENTY THIRTY FIVE. IN
ADDITION RESTRICTING CUTTING TO
THE ALLEN MY COMMUNITY IS
PREMATURE GIVEN THAT NEXT
YEAR'S NEW CARDS THAT SALES
WILL ACCOUNT FOR APPROXIMATELY
4% OF TOTAL VEHICLE SALES. WE
SUPPORT THE DEVELOPMENT OF A
STRATEGIC PLAN RELATING TO THAT
CONSUMER INCENTIVES IN LIGHT OF
AIR BEAT THAT PROPOSAL THE
TWENTY FIFTH MODEL YEAR AND
BEYOND. SUCH A PLAN SHOULD
CONTEMPLATE THE APPROPRIATE
LEVEL OF CONSUMER INCENTIVES
NEED TO SUPPORT THE RAMP RATE
FOR NEW CARTEL REQUIREMENTS
PROPOSED BY AIR B. FOR EXAMPLE
FROM 8% IN TWENTY FIVE MODEL
YEAR 226% AND TWENTY FIFTH
MODEL YEAR OR MORE THAN THREE
TIMES IN A SINGLE YEAR. WE
WELCOME THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PARTICIPATE IN THIS. KIND OF
STRATEGIC PLANNING EFFORT THANK
YOU. AND NEXT WE MOVE ON TO
LINE. THIRTY PLEASE GO AHEAD.
ARE YOU ABLE TO HEAR ME. YES
YES YOUR LINE IS OPEN. OKAY
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR BLOOM AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
VICTOR GOLF AND I AM TWENTY SIX
YEARS OLD. I AM A CORE MEMBER
WHAT THE FINAL SAY CONSERVATION
CORPS. IN FACT JOSE CALIFORNIA
ALTHOUGH MY RE BY INCLUSIVE
PORQUE FOR WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT. IT DOES NOT
INCLUDE ANY DIRECT INVESTMENT.
TO SUPPORT THE FORTY LOCAL
CONSERVATION CORPS. LOCAL COURT
FOR IN YOU PEOPLE ME TO BE PART
OF THE- WORK ON ENVIRONMENTAL
PROJECTS TO PREVENT WILD. IN
OUR HIGHWAYS AND PREPARE FOR
JOBS. WELL HELP CLEAN PEOPLE.
FOR IT- LOOKS LIKE MAYBE WE
LOST THE LAST SPEAKER. MOST THE
MOST WELL AS SOME POOR MEMBERS
WHO ARE IN NEED OF HOUSING OUR
GOAL IS TO HELP BUILD WAIT.
MORE TINY HOMES PARTICULARLY
FOR YOU AS WE SEE MANY JUDE
CORP MEMBERS IN NEED OF HOUSING
IN SAN JOSE. AND WOULD LIKE
THEM TO FOCUS MORE ON POST
SECONDARY EDUCATION. I ALSO. I
WOULD LIKE TO BE A CLIMATE
LEADER AND I WANT TO HELP MY
COMMUNITY. PLEASE DON'T LEAVE
ME AND OTHERS LIKE LIKE ME
BEHIND. AND INCLUDE DIRECT
FUNDING TO THE LOCAL
CONSERVATION CORPS IN THIS
YEAR'S BUDGET THANK YOU FOR
LISTENING. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
AND ACTUALLY MOVED THE LINE ONE
FORTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YOUR MEMBERS JERRY DOESN'T
BEHALF OF RECREATIONAL BOATERS
OF CALIFORNIA WE APPRECIATE
PROVISIONS IN THE MAIL OF EYES
THAT REDUCE THE AMOUNT OF THE
PROPOSED FEDERAL REGISTRATION
INCREASE. AND DEDICATE
ADDITIONAL GENERAL FUND DOLLARS
TO SUPPORT VOTING PROGRAMS AND
SERVICES PROVIDED BY THE
DIVISION OF BOATING AND
WATERWAYS AND STATE PARKS. AT
THE SAME TIME WE CONTINUE TO
REVERSE THAT ADDITIONAL
PROVISIONS BE INCLUDED TO PLACE
THE PROPOSED STAKEHOLDER
PROCESS IN STATUTE AS A
MECHANISM TO IDENTIFY LONG TERM
SOLUTION THAT WILL PROVIDE
STABILITY TO THE HARBORS A LOT
OF CRAP OF ALL THE FUN. AND TO
REQUIRE THE DPW CONDUCT A LONG
OVERDUE UPDATABLE YOU ECONOMIC
THE STUDY FOR. THESE PROVISIONS
AND OTHERS IN OUR COALITION
LETTER WILL GO A LONG WAY TO
ENCOURAGE BENEFICIAL OUTDOOR
ALL THE WATER RECREATION AS WE
MOVE FORWARD OUT OF THE
PANDEMIC AND TO ALSO PROVIDE
THE BOATING PUBLIC ASSURANCES
THAT THE PACT OF THE PIZZA YOU
TAKE. OR BEING ABLE THE PROGRAM
WITH. AND THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
AND NEXT WE'LL MOVE THE LINE
ONE FOR EIGHT GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR AND MEMBERS
DANIEL TERRACE ON BEHALF SAY
CAL AND BY JUSTICE ALLIANCE-
BAKER WILL COMMENT SEPARATELY
IN WRITING AND DISCUSS BUDGET
PRIORITIES WITH OFFICES BUT WE
WOULD LIKE TO MENTION A FEW
BUDGET PRIORITIES HERE TODAY-
FIRST THEY HAVE REQUESTED A NEW
ONE BILLION DOLLAR GENERAL FUND
ALLOCATION FOR COMMUNITY
RESILIENCE CENTER. I WHICH OUR
COMMUNITY LAD AND WE COULDN'T
CENTRIC PROJECT. THEY HAVE ALSO
SUPPORT INCREASING THE LOW
INCOME WEATHERIZATION PROGRAM
FUNDING TO SEVENTY FIVE
MILLION. THE FUND ENERGY
EFFICIENCY AND WEATHERIZATION
UPGRADE AND DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES. AND LAUGH THE
STAFF REPORTS THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL FOR ONE HUNDRED FORTY
MILLION DOLLARS FOR
TRANSFORMATIVE CLIMATE
COMMUNITIES GRANTS TO FIND
COMMUNITY LED. RESILIENCY PLAN.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. I AM NOT
WILL ONE SEVEN GO AHEAD.
BACKGROUND ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ADVANCED BIOFUEL
GLANCE I WANT TO EMPHASIZE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FRIEDMAN POINT
IN REGARDS TO NEAR TERM
SOLUTIONS FOR THE MEDIUM HEAVY
DUTY IN OPERA TRANSPORTATION
SECTOR WHEN YOU WILL BE GONE BY
THE BILL ARE AVAILABLE TODAY
WITHOUT ENGINE MODIFICATION. WE
WOULD LIKE TO SEE MORE MONEY
ALLOCATED TOWARDS THE
TRANSITION TO CLEANER LOW
CARBON FUELS LIKE BIODIESEL
RENEWABLE DIESEL THANK YOU FOR
HOLDING THIS HEARING THIS
AFTERNOON AND WE LOOK FORWARD
TO WORKING WITH YOU FURTHER ON
THAT. THANKS THANK YOU. TWO ONE
ONE FIFTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU CHAIR NUMBERS MY NAME
IS JORDAN WHILE SPEAKING ON
BEHALF OF THE QUEEN'S HE'S
LOVING COALITION AND THE
NATIONAL ACTION COUNCIL A
NONPROFIT THAT ADVOCATES FOR
CIRCULAR ECONOMY. STREAMY
SUPPORTIVE OF THE GOVERNORS MAY
BUDGET REVISION PROPOSAL
SECTION ON THE CIRCULAR ECONOMY
WE STRONGLY SUPPORT THE A
HUNDRED THIRTY MILLION DOLLAR
ONE TIME GENERAL FUND TO
SUPPORT RECYCLING
INFRASTRUCTURE. AND THE
FORMATION OF AN OFFICE OF
INNOVATION AND MARKET
DEVELOPMENT AND REMANUFACTURING
WITHIN POWER CYCLE. HOWEVER WE
URGE THE LEGISLATURE TO
PRIORITIZE FUNDING TOWARDS FOR
YOU CAN REPAIR BUSINESSES.
WHICH IS THE STATE'S PRIORITY
BASED ON THAT WEEK'S HIERARCHY
OF WASTE REDUCTION IN RIO'S
FIRST THEN RECYCLING. THANK YOU.
AN ACTUAL LINE SIXTEEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THANK YOU CARE
BLOOMING COMMITTEE MEMBER
STEVEN MY SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF
VALLEY CAN'T REGARDING ISSUE
THREE WE APPRECIATE THE
GOVERNOR'S DEMONSTRATED
COMMITMENT TO CLIMATE EQUITY
THROUGH THE FUNDING ALLOCATED
TO CLEAN CARS FOR ALL IN OTHER
EQUITY PROGRAMS IN THE BUDGET
CLEAN CARS FOR ALL IMPORTANT
PROGRAM THAT SERVES
CALIFORNIA'S DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES AND HELP THE STATE
REACHED CLIMATE GOALS WE LOOK
FORWARD TO SEEING THE FUNDING
BE PUT TO GOOD USE IN THE
COMMUNITIES THAT NEED IT MOST.
ON BEHALF OF CALTRANS ALSO
INITIATE THREE SINCE TWO
THOUSAND ONE CALTRANS PROVIDE
BAND FULL SERVICES TO
AGRICULTURAL WORKERS STRUCK THE
STATE THOSE WORKERS ARE
COMPRISED THAT COMPRISE OUR
RIDERSHIP THE TYPICALLY LOW
INCOME LIVING DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES OFFICIALLY WESTECH
ECONOMIC AND OTHER BARRIERS AND
THINGS CHALLENGES GETTING TO
WORK BECAUSE THEY LACK SAFE
RELIABLE CLEAN TRANSPORTATION
WE APPRECIATE THE FUNDING FOR
TRANSPORTATION EQUITY PROGRAMS
BUT WE URGE THE COMMITTEE TO
INCLUDE AGRICULTURAL PANCHAL
PROGRAMS AS PART OF THE FUNDING
SO WE CAN CONTINUE TO PROVIDE
THESE CRITICAL SERVICES TO OUR.
COMMUNITIES THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. AND NEXT DECLINED ONE
FIFTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
ADAM KIAROSTAMI HAPPY SO
STATION CALIFORNIA WATER
AGENCIES WHILE WE ARE STILL
ASSESSING THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL WANT TO THANK THE
ADMINISTRATION FOR THE PROPOSED
FUNDING IN RESPONSE TO DROUGHT
AND KOBE NINETEEN REGIONS. IN
PARTICULAR WOULD BE TWO HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS IN FUNDING FOR
CONVEYANCE THE TWO HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS FOR HABITAT
RESTORATION IN THE TWO BILLION
DOLLARS IN KOBE NINETEEN WATER
ELECTRIC DEBT RELIEF. HOW WE
WOULD RECOMMEND THAT THE TWO
BILLION DOLLARS B. ADMINISTERED
BY THE DEPARTMENT OF COMMUNITY
SERVICES AND DEVELOPMENT SAID
THEY HAVE EXPERIENCED THESE
KIND OF PROGRAMS WE THINK ALSO
THAT SOME OF THESE CATEGORIES
CAN CERTAINLY BE INCREASED- IN
ADDITION ONE CRITICAL PIECE
THAT IS MISSING FROM THE
PROPOSAL- ARE DEFINITELY DAM
SAFETY IT CALIFORNIA'S HIGH
DAMS. WHICH IS A SIGNIFICANT
PUBLIC SAFETY ISSUE IN MANY
PARTS OF THE STATE- WILL ALSO
WANT TO REITERATE OUR- SUPPORT
OF THE SENATE BUDGET PROPOSAL-
AND LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH THE LEGISLATURE AS WE
CONSIDER ADDITIONAL FUNDING I'M
PER. PROPER SCIENCE THANK YOU.
AND THAT'S A LITTLE WIND SIX
PLEASE GO. HI CHAIRMAN- ANYBODY
ALLOWED TO ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA WILL LEAVE HERE TO
COMMENT ON THE NAY REQUIRED I
JUST MEDICAL THE COMMENTS MADE
BY TPO ENTRY PEOPLE INCLUDE
WHILE WE ARE PLEASED TO SEE A
STRONG INVESTMENT ANIME REVISED
TO SPEAK. ON EQUITY AND
REVEALING SECRET SHOULD BE HAVE
BEEN CLEANING PROGRAM IN THE
TCC PROGRAM CALIFORNIA IS THE
STATE DEPARTMENT CHARGED
STATURE TO SUPPORT CALPERS
URBAN FORCES. SO WE ARE SHOULD
EXTREMELY DISAPPOINTED TO SEE
THAT THE MAY REVISED HAS
ABSOLUTELY NO NEW MONEY
PROPOSED FOR CALGARY- BEING
COMMUNITY BECAUSE SHE PROGRAM.
THIS PROGRAM IS THE- IT'S CALL.
TO DISTINCT- TRUMP IRVING GREEN
AND THE TEACHER PRO. WE HOPE TO
SEE FUNDING THE- URBAN POOR SHE
PROGRAM IN THE US BUDGET
PROPOSAL THURMOND- FOR SHE
PROGRAM IS NOT ONLY HIGHLY
SUCCESSFUL PROGRAM BUT ALSO
WIDELY RECOGNIZED AS THE GO TO
FOR COMMUNITY PROJECTS
COMMUNITY BASED PROJECTS- TO
COMBINE EXTREME HEAT TREE
PLANTING PRESERVATION. AND IF
THE PRIORITY FOR NUMBER. I'M
SORRY THANK YOU AGAIN THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. AND NEXT TO THE LINE
ONE SIXTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON JACK COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MILD MILLER WITH THE
NATURAL RESOURCES DEFENSE
COUNCIL YOUR COMMENT
SPECIFICALLY ON THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSED INVESTMENT AND YOUR
EMISSION VEHICLE AT
INFRASTRUCTURE. YOU CAN
REFERENCE WOULD BE- CRITICAL
DOWN PAYMENT ON CALIFORNIA'S
CLEAN TRANSPORTATION FUTURE AND
HELP REALIZE BILLIONS AND
PUBLIC HEALTH BENEFITS MORNING
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS. AND
HELP CREATE THOUSANDS OF HIGH
QUALITY JOBS. WE ARE GOING TO
CALL FOR INCREASING INVESTMENT
FOR THEIR TRANSPORTATION EQUITY
PROJECTS TO FIVE HUNDRED
MILLION. MAKING SURE THAT 50%
OF GREEN TRANSPORTATION PROGRAM
INVESTMENT GOING TO LOW INCOME
AND DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES.
AND WE AUTHORIZING THAT ADHD IS
TO PROVIDE A SUSTAINABLE
FUNDING SOURCE FOR CLEAN
TRANSPORTATION INVESTMENTS
GOING FORWARD THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. MEXICO ONE ONE SIXTY TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES THIS IS-
ERIK KARLSSON FOR THE
ASSOCIATION OF CONTRACT
COUNTIES FOR THE CALIFORNIA
BUDGET ARE SIX COUNTY FIRE
DEPARTMENT SUPPORT THE PROPOSAL
BY MR BENNETT AND OTHER
LEGISLATORS FOR FOURTEEN
MILLION TWO HUNDRED NINETY
EIGHT THOUSAND DOLLARS TO FUND
SIX FEEL CREWS FOR THESE
COUNTIES WHICH CONTRACT WITH
CAL FIRE TO PROVIDE FIRE
RESPONSE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
NEXT TO GO TO LINE ONE FIFTY
SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAPLAIN MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE MY NAME IS MARK
RENDON I'M THE FIRE CHIEF FOR
THE VENTURA COUNTY FIRE
DEPARTMENT IN THE CHAIR OF THE
ASSOCIATION OF CONTRACT
COUNTIES. WE REPRESENT THE FIRE
DEPARTMENTS FOR MORAN CURRENT
SANTA BARBARA VENTURA LOS
ANGELES AND ORANGE COUNTY'S I'M
CALLING IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
MEMBER BENEFITS ASK FOR OR
APPROXIMATELY FOURTEEN POINT
THREE MILLION DOLLARS TO BE
ADDED TO CALPERS BUDGET- IN
SUPPORT OF SIXTY- CRUISE FOR
THE REFERENCE COUNTIES TO HELP
COMBAT OUR WILDLAND FIRE CRISIS
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. AND NEXT
TO GO TO LINE OF ONE SIXTY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU GOOD
AFTERNOON THAT YOUR BLOOM JASON
WEBER MARIN COUNTY FIRE CHIEF
OF VICE CHAIR OF THE
ASSOCIATION OF- CAL PART
CONTRACT COUNTIES CALLING ON
BEHALF OF. THAT ORGANIZATION IN
ASKING YOU FOR YOUR COMMITTEE
SUPPORT OF THE MEMBERS- AND
YEAH NUMBER BENNETT'S REQUEST
RELATED THE FUNDING OF THE FIRE
AND FUELS CRUISE WITHIN THE SIX
CONTRACT COUNTIES. AS
PREVIOUSLY MENTIONED THANK YOU.
AND NEXT TO A LINE ELEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS INJURING ANTOLIN ON
BEHALF OF TWO CLIENTS- FIRST
THE COMMAND CHAIRMAN OF COURSE
ISN'T OVERLY LONG HEARING OVER
FOUR HOURS- WAS VERY IMPORTANT
ISSUES- FOR A CLIENT ADVANCED
ENERGY ECONOMY- WE SUPPORT THIS
UPCOMING PACKAGE- AS AUGMENTED
IN THE GOVERNOR'S MAY REVISE-
WE DO SUPPORT- THE EXTENSION OF
THE ABA CREAMS AND HAPPY TO
SEE- THE INCLUSION OF SENIOR P.
FUNDING ALTHOUGH WE KNOW SOME
OF THE CONCERNS RAISED DURING
THIS HEARING. ABOUT OTHER
INCOME LEVELS AN ELIGIBILITY-
URGENT TO CONSIDER THOSE
CONCERNS AS WELL AND FOR THE
LOS ANGELES COUNTY METROPOLITAN
TRANSPORTATION AUTHORITY TO
PROPOSALS- THE GOVERNOR'S
EMISSION BUS FOR COASTAL PART
OF HIS LAW LARGER CAN'T. THE
PROPOSAL- DOWN PAYMENT ON A
MANDATE BY THE- RESOURCES GOING
TO TURN OVER FLEETS IN TRANSIT
AGENCIES SO ZERO EMISSIONS
1100% BY TWENTY FORTY A MEASURE
HAS THE COURAGE TO DO THAT BY
TWENTY THIRTY- WE NEED A
FUNDING PARTNER TO. COMPLY WITH
THIS MANDATE BY THE STATE AND
WE APPRECIATE- THIS AS A DOWN
PAYMENT TOWARDS A LARGER GOAL.
THAT WE SHARE LOCALLY AND AT
THE STATEWIDE LEVEL. AND ONE
FOR EVERY MEASURE WE ALSO
SUPPORT- COMMUNITY SERVICE-
MAYBE VICE TRANSPORTATION
FUNDING PROPOSAL CRITICAL
INFRASTRUCTURE FOR PROJECTS
THAT WOULD HELP IMPROVE
MOBILITY WITHIN THE REGION-
THESE ARE PROJECTS THAT HAVE
ALREADY BEEN IDENTIFIED IN MANY
CASES WELL IT WAS A GREAT
OPPORTUNITY FOR PROJECTS THAT
HAVE BEEN IDENTIFIED IN MANY
CASES. FOR XCELERATED MARINE
FUNDING LOCALLY BY MEASURE M.
SO WE'D BE WE WOULD BE AN
ABSOLUTE FROM PARTNER WILL THE
STATE- YOU TAKE ADVANTAGE OF
MANY DOLLARS WOULD HAVE BEEN
THE AVAILABLE. TO GET PACKAGE
IT WILL TO PART OF THE COVERAGE
GOING. AND NEXT LINE ONE SIXTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
THAT CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF
COMMITTEE I'M JAMIE MARC WITH
B. AMERICAN HEART. REPLETE BE
AND THAT AND CAPABLE ACTOR.
WHICH WILL INCREASE BACK TO
HIGH YOU CREATE THE BEST. THE
TYPICALLY WRKER GRANT PARK. IN
YOUR NUTRITION. THE CALIFORNIA
NUTRITION INCENTIVE PROGRAMS IN
THE FARM TO SCHOOL. GRANT
PROGRAM THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU. YES A GOOD LINE ONE
SIXTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON- CHAIR BLOOM AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
BRIAN UNITY AND I AM QUITE
PRESIDENT SOUTH OF THE RAIL
PASSENGERS ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA AND NEVADA OR RAIL
PACKED. WHERE ARE NOT ALL
VOLUNTEER ORGANIZATION THAT'S
BEEN AROUND SINCE NINETEEN
SEVENTY EIGHT. AND RAIL PACKED
STRONGLY SUPPORT THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSED INFRASTRUCTURE.
PACKAGE IN PARTICULAR WE WANT
TO SUPPORT- ALLOCATED ONE FOUR
POINT TWO BILLION OF
PROPOSITION ONE EIGHTY FUNDS TO
COMPLETE HIGH SPEED RAIL
CONSTRUCTION. IN THE CENTRAL
VALLEY- GOOD BANDS WORKED A
LAWN SERVICE BRING MERCED AND
BAKERSFIELD AND ADVANCED
PLANNING AND PRODUCT DESIGN THE
ENTIRE PROJECT. AND LEVERAGE
POTENTIAL FEDERAL FUNDS AND WE
ALSO FEEL THAT- ADVANCE
PLANNING FOR THE PHASE TWO
WHICH IS THE CAUSE OF THE SAN
DIEGO AND SACRAMENTO IT ALSO
BEGINS. SOON AND THE BE
THOUGHTFULLY FUNDED. AND BEEN
SOME DOCUMENTS FROM SOME
LEGISLATORS TO. DIVERT
ELECTRIFICATION FUNDS FROM THE
CENTRAL VALLEY TO SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA AND AT THE SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA VERY OPPOSED TO THAT
IT'S VERY MUCH IN THE BEST
INTEREST OF THE STATE THANK YOU
TO- ONLY ELECTRIFY. THE CENTRAL
VALLEY THANK YOU. STE. AND NEXT
TO THE LINE ONE SEVENTY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS MY NAME'S PATRICK ROY
ON BEHALF OF FISHING GAME
WARDEN SUPERVISORS AND MANAGERS
AND THE CALIFORNIA WILDLIFE
OFFICERS FOUNDATION WE'RE VERY
HEARTENED TO SEE THE ROBUST
LASTING INVESTMENTS PROPOSED
FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND
WILDLIFE. THE DEPARTMENT TOOK
THE SERVICE BASED BUDGET EFFORT
VERY SERIOUSLY I PERSONALLY LOG
MANY HOURS ON IT AND IT
DEMONSTRATES WITH CREDIBILITY
THE URGENT NEED FOR NEW LONG
TERM FUNDING- THE MAY REVISION
ADDED FUNDING FOR EQUIPMENT IN
OVERTIME IN ADDITION TO ONE
TIME PROPOSAL FOR A NEW
OFFSHORE PATROL VESSEL. AND A
NEW FIXED WING AIRCRAFT TO
PROTECT OUR MARINE RESOURCES
AND ENHANCE THE SUPPORT FOR
MARINE. FOR HUMAN AND WILDLIFE
CONFLICT RESPONSES AN AREA I'VE
PERSONALLY LOGGED MORE THAN A
THOUSAND HOURS ON OVER THE
COURSE OF MY CAREER WE ARE YOUR
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
NEXT WOULD ALIGN ONE SEVENTY
SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. YEAH YES-
GENERATOR RIGHT THREE FIFTY
VENTURA COUNTY CRIME ABOUT
WHERE COMMITTEE STAFF THE
BETTER. AT DGSE THEIR HANDLING
OF SANTA AND I'LL HAVE BEEN
VERY TROUBLING AND NOW THE
NEIGHBORHOOD AROUND THE NATURAL
GAS COMPRESSOR STATION IN
WESTERN TARA NEEDS MORE RESPECT
TO GARDEN NOT CLEAN UP. THE
SITE NOTIFICATION HAS ANOTHER.
INTEREST OF OURS- WE NEED-
BECAUSE THE SIZE USES COMPOUND
WITH CARBON CYCLE- AND HAS
OTHER NEGATIVE ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE IMPACTS SO ALL
PROGRAMS. SUCH AS- INTRUSION
INCENTIVES THE- BUT AGRICULTURE
THE OPEN THURSDAY TO THINK
ABOUT TRANSITIONING TO ORGANIC
AND HEALTHY SOILS. PROGRAM
SHOULD NOT BE GRANTING ANYMORE
G. G. R. UP FUNDS TO USERS OF
TOXIC PESTICIDES MIGLIORE DI
BIO DIGESTERS WE ALSO
VIGOROUSLY OPPOSE THEY SUPPORT
HER SIDE THAT MUST BE CRYING
AND LIQUID FUEL INFRASTRUCTURE
INCONSISTENT WAS QUIET AS WELL
AS THE JACKAL. WE NEED TO CAP
AND PATTERSON METHANE WAS
POLICIES THAT. REDUCE THE SIZE.
HE THANK YOU FOR COMING. AN
ACTUAL LINE ONE TWENTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIR AND MEMBERS DOWN HALLS ON
BEHALF OF CANCER WE EXPRESS OUR
STRONG SUPPORT GOVERNESSES
PROPOSED BUDGET BUDGET THAT'S
NEARLY ONE POINT EIGHT BILLION
DOLLARS FOR THE EEVEE
INFRASTRUCTURE MEDIUM AND HEAVY
DUTY VEHICLES ARE NOT GOING TO
QUIT NINE AND CLEAN
TRANSPORTATION PROGRAMS SUCH AS
H. T. I. P. WE STRONGLY SUPPORT
THE ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL
TO REAUTHORIZE AND EXTEND
EIGHTY EIGHT SLASH ONE MONEY
FEES. OR ADDITIONAL TEN YEARS
WE WOULD LIKE TO REQUEST THAT
THE LEGISLATURE ACT NOW INSTEAD.
OF WAITING. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. SO HOW DOES NINE ONE
EIGHTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO BURGEONING CAMBY HAPPENS
COMMUNITY NATURE CONNECTION AN
INTERPOL. INVESTMENTS IN
COMMUNITY ACCESS MY GOVERNOR'S
NAY REVISION INCLUDING DVRS
OUTDOOR. EQUITY GRANTS PROGRAM
YOU HAVE BEEN NUMBER NUMBER AND
OVER HOWEVER EVEN GIVEN THERE'S
A BIG PURSUE AND GOT WE STILL
NEED TO FILL TO A THAT HAS AND
PROGRAMS OF TO THEM TO VISIT
THE OUTDOORS GETS UP AD DURING
INTO CLIMB AND I'LL SHOW
RESOURCE. FIRST YEAR THANKFUL
SOME OF THE CARILLO FOR
SUBMITTING A MORE TO INVEST
YOUR MILLION OF THE YEAR'S BY
SURPLUS TRICKS THE BREADTH AND
SCOPE THE BIGGEST. YOU
COMMUNITY ACCESS PROGRAM
ADMINISTERED BY C. N. R. A. AND
URGE YOU TO INCLUDE THE FUNDING
IN YOUR BUDGET PROPOSAL THIS
ONE SHOULD EVERY CALIFORNIAN
CAN ACCESS MEANINGFUL
APPROPRIATE OUTDOOR PROGRAMMING
SECOND WERE QUESTION ONE
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS TO
SUPPORT CENTER WE SHOW ENTIRE
DRAWS A SB SIX ZERO FOUR WHICH
WOULD SUPPORT MULTI BENEFICIAL.
AND WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
PROJECTS ACROSS THE STATE IS
INVESTMENTS ARE CRITICAL TO
ENSURE THAT WE ARE TRULY ABLE
TO SUPPORT OUR DISENFRANCHISED
COMMUNITIES AND THIS YEAR'S
BUDGET SURPLUS IS THE PERFECT
TOOL RECOGNIZE THE HISTORIC
SURPLUS AND THINK THE PROPOSED
INVESTMENTS TO THE
CONSERVANCY'S WILDFIRE PACKAGE
ARE A GOOD START ARE THE WILD
CARDS HAVE ALREADY GOTTEN A
HEAD INJURY. DROUGHT THANK YOU.
NEXT LINE TO- TO. PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS WELCOME HEALTH BAKER
DIRECTOR THE CAL TRANSIT SO
REPRESENTING EIGHTY FIVE TRAIN
GENERAL AGENCIES ACROSS OUR
STATE JUST WANT TO JOIN YOU ALL
TODAY TO VOICE OUR SUPPORT FOR
THE SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENTS ARE
PROPOSED IN THE GOVERNOR'S MAY
REVISE- THAT IMPACT TRANSIT IN
RAIL I IN PARTICULAR DO YOU
WANT TO CALL OUT THE STRONG
SUPPORT THAT IS- COMMUNICATED.
FOR ZERO EMISSION BUS
TRANSITION IN PARTICULAR ONE OF
OUR LONG TIME PRIORITIES HAS
BEEN A DEDICATED POP UP
PLANNING TO MOVE- THOSE
INVESTMENTS LOWERED- ADS WITH
SPOKEN TO EARLIER BY PREVIOUS
COMMENTERS- WE DO HAVE A
REQUIREMENT TO TRANSITION OUR
FLEET- 2100% GERMINATION BUSES
BY TWENTY FORTY- THAT WILL
REQUIRE DEDICATED CONSISTENT
FUNDING OF WHICH THE GOVERNOR-
INVESTMENT AND MULTI YEAR
STRATEGY- WOULD DO WELL TO
SUPPORT. I DO ALSO WANT TO MAKE
A CALL OUT TO THE INVESTMENT IN-ZERO EMISSION RAIL THE CAPACITY
IMPROVEMENT THAT ARE ALSO
CONTEMPLATED WITHIN THE
PROPOSAL- WE THINK THAT ON
BALANCE IT IS A STRONG PROPOSAL
AND WOULD ENCOURAGE YOU ALL TO
MOVE IT FORWARD- OF COURSE WHEN
IT IS HEARD. FOUR EIGHT THANK
YOU SO THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANKS TO GO TO LINE TWO OH
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH NINE THREE CLICK
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
HYDROGEN COALITION PLEASED TO
SEE SUCH A STRONG COMMITMENT TO
DEVELOPING YOUR MACHINE VEHICLE
MARKET OUR MEMBERS ARE MADE UP
OF FUEL CELL ELECTRIC VEHICLE
MANUFACTURERS HYDROGEN STATION
DEVELOPERS AND HYDROGEN KILL
PRODUCER. I THINK YOU KNOW OUR
ADVOCATE EIGHT HAS BEEN FOCUSED
ON PROVIDING A DEDICATED
SATISFIED OF AT LEAST FIVE
HUNDRED MILLION FOR HYDROGEN TO
BRING A LIGHT DUTY MARKET TO
APPOINT A PUBLICATION. THREE
AND WITHIN. HELLO TO PUT A
HEAVY MARK- TELLING YOU THAT
YOUR WE ARE NOT DOING THIS TO
BE DIFFERENT FOR. WE ARE JUST
THINKING ABOUT THE CITY AND
PREDICTABILITY BECAUSE AT THE
AIRPORT POINTS OUT 90% OF THE
COST OF HYDROGEN INFRASTRUCTURE
DEVELOPMENT WILL COME FROM THE
PRIVATE SECTORS IN ORDER FOR
INDUSTRY TO STEP UP AND
CONTRIBUTE CAPITAL TO SUPPORT
CALIFORNIA'S GOAL THE HYDROGEN
INDUSTRY IN FACT INCENTIVIZED
BY. SOMETHING THAT OFFERS
PREDICTABILITY. AND THAT AND-
WE APPRECIATE THE LEGISLATURE'S
CONSIDERATION OF THE PROPOSAL
AND THANK YOU AND LOOK FORWARD
TO WORKING WITH YOU. THANK YOU.
AND THAT BRINGS US TO LINE TO
TWENTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON- ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BILLION THIS IS TREATED WITH
PACIFIC ENVIRONMENT AN
ENVIRONMENTAL NONPROFIT AND WE
ARE THE STATE'S ONLY NGO WITH A
COMPLICATED STATUS AT THE
INTERNATIONAL MARITIME
ORGANIZATION. OR IT'S A PART OF
THE FUNDING PROPOSED FOR CARS
AND SPECIALLY THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET FULL OF FOUR HUNDRED TWO
MILLION FOR COST CONTRACT BUT
THERE'S AN OFF ROAD VEHICLE
WHICH INCLUDES FUNDING TO
SUPPORT INNOVATION AND
ACCELERATE DEVELOPMENT OF-
THEIR MISSION FOR MARINE
VESSELS. AND WERE ALSO
SUPPORTERS OF RE AUTHORIZING
THE- CLEAN TRANSPORTATION
PROGRAM ACKLEY PROGRAM UNDER AB
ELEVEN AT. ONE EIGHTEEN THANK
YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU. AND WE
HAVE NO OTHER COMMONERS IN
QUEUE AT THIS TIME. ALL RIGHT
AND I SEE NO ONE NO WAITING GO
HERE. IN THE CHAMBER AND DOS
SO THAT BRINGS US TO THE END OF
OUR HEARING I WANT TO THANK
EVERYBODY FOR YOUR
PARTICIPATION AND YOUR PATIENCE
TODAY IT'S BEEN A LONG MEETING
AND WE ARE ADJOURNED.